e
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several bills to be heard today uh for
public hearing we also have an executive
session this morning but before we get
into any of that I'd ask you to please
allegiance plge aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all thank you
everyone the first bill we will be
considering today is Senate Bill
FNA and I'll recognize the prime sponsor
Senator Sharon Carson and she is already
in position good morning Senator good
morning morning Mr chairman and good
morning members of the house um of the
house um health committee I'll just
because it's got kind of like a long
long title there um for the record my
name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 comprising the towns of London Derry
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bell
352 FNA which seeks to establish an
early detention detection can caner
screening pilot program in the
Department of Safety Division of fire
standards and training and Emergency
Medical Services for retired and
full-time active
firefighters Mr chairman um I have
handed your uh your Clerk and article
that was uh fairly recent in the union
leader talking about a firefighter uh
from the city of Manchester who did have
early detection um and was discovered to
have had uh cancer of the colon and so
um I wanted to make sure that article
was available for uh the committee
members to
read I think it's important that we
realize that prevention is extremely
important and that their our
firefighters have been facing a number
of significant Health RIS risks because
of the material that they use in putting
out fires but it's not only that it's in
the clothing that they wear we all know
about pasas but I don't think most of
you know that their clothing their fire
preven so they don't get burned contains
P so they have no choice they must wear
these uh these articles of clothing to
protect themselves so um I think it's
time that we step up and we do what we
need to do to protect them as
well um there are basically I I'd like
to just discuss eight key points when
we're talking about occupational
hazardous awareness um firefighters are
exposed to carcinogens during their
operations they uh need increased
awareness of early detention specific
dangers uh are associated with pasas the
first one is the occupation
Hazard awareness firefighters again are
exposed to numerous carcinogens during
firefighter operations which increase
their risk of developing cancer
substantially a cancer screening program
would raise awareness even more about
occupational ha hazards and emphasize
the importance of early
detection secondly I think we all know
early detection saves lives cancer is
often more treatable when detected in
its early stages implementing regular
screenings can help identify potential
cases of cancer among firefighters
enabling prompt medical intervention and
saving
lives three job related health support
firefighters put their health and their
life on the line to protect others a
cancer screening program demonstrates a
commitment to the well-being of these
Brave individuals providing them with
the necessary tools and resources to
Monitor and address potential health
risks associated with their profession
four it actually reduces health care
costs early detect early detection and
intervention can contribute to lower
health care costs in the long run by
identifying and treating cancers at an
earlier stage the financial burden on
both firefighters and our Health Care
Systems can be reduced compared to the
costs associated with Advanced stage
cancer treatment can also improve the
quality of Life timely cancer screenings
can lead to less invasive treatment
options and better overall outcomes by
prioritizing the health of firefighters
we not only extend their life expectancy
but enhance their quality of life during
and after
treatment number six is long-term
datadriven decisionmaking the cancer
screening program would generate
valuable data on the prevalence of
cancer among firefighters information
will be used to red Define uh safety
protocols enhance protective gear and
Implement preventive measures to further
minimize cancer risks in the
firefighting
profession seven enhanced occupational
safety standards implementing a
screening program sends a powerful
message about the commitment to
occupational services within the fire
service it encourages The Establishment
and enforcement of stricter safety
standards ensuring a healthy your work
environment for current and future
generations of firefighters and finally
long-term benefits for retention prior
prioritizing the health and well-being
of firefighters through a cancer
screening program can contribute to
higher job satisfaction and retention
rates I think that I I hope that we can
all agree that these eight points I
think are are critical we know these
folks are being exposed to cancerous
chemicals and I think we should step up
and we should support them and uh
hopefully you can um pass this bill and
we can provide those services for these
folks thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you Senator questions for Senator
Carson representative Leon um thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Senator Carson
for bringing this important bill um I
have some experience in the diagnostic
space I actually as an analyst covered
the company that brought that um the
colag guard the test for colar rectal
cancer and I was working with a lot of
companies that were trying to work on
this Blood broad blood BL based
screening uh my concern is that the
multi-cancer blood test um that's
detecting signals from as many cancer
types as possible um is both too broad
of a description and it's something that
currently is not approved by the FDA and
there's questionable validity to it
especially because as it's moving
towards the the approval process with
Gallery which is the one that was
mentioned in the Senate hearing um that
one even in in their data published at
the European Society of medical oncology
they used two different tests so they
couldn't actually compare the different
tests um because as they're learning
more the screening test changes so we
couldn't really use it serially for
these
firefighters um so that's pretty much
experimental so I'm very concerned about
um doing that and giving false hope to
our firefighters and the ultrasound
diagnostic screening of oncology um of
cancer when there's not already a signal
I wasn't able to find any data on that
my question would be that we know that
lung CTS and skin cancer screening are
important and they save lives my
question would be if um you would be
amenable to removing the more
experimental sections from this and
focusing at this point on the lung CTS
and skin cancer screenings and then
possibly working to see if companies um
like the one that makes Gallery might
include New Hampshire firefighters and a
clinical trial for these because this is
a population that should be addressed
and it would have a benefit to the
company for looking at this and as a
experimental diagnostic um we should
make sure that we are appropriately
setting the the goals and and
expectations for our firefighters while
contributing to science so that maybe we
can detect these early and get
actionable effort well thank you very
much for your questions what is
important to me is the actual screening
that takes place I think we need to do
that you're talking about very specific
types of testing and they're the they're
here they're going to be able to answer
that better than I can about um that
particular type of test what's important
to me is that it gets done that's what
I'm here advocating for they need to
have a a cancer screening
program thank you you're welcome
representative Paz off and then
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh
could you explain what currently stops
uh five fighters from screening is it
the price is it that they don't know
about it and um also uh do you have any
idea how how invasive and how long this
screening is and uh your bill has a cup
for not exceed $1300 so I wonder if we
have any idea
what the uh expected price for
comprehensive screening is
now thank you I'm going to try um I had
a little difficulty trying to understand
what you're saying are you asking
me about first of all the price of the
screening and then the first question I
think you're trying to what what stops
them from screening now what's the bar
barrier uh to to screening thank you
many um it's my understanding that um
many people don't normally get that type
of screening um what you're going to do
is you're going to get them when they
come into the fire service and really
that's a baseline um I would hope that
they would continue to get this type of
screening um this type of my
understanding it's not uh it's not cheap
it's more than
$100 um but those are all details that
um will get worked out as we go through
this process again my point is this is
something that we really need to
do representative mlan and then
representative Seth King uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so um I work with uh a lot of
folks in uh the volunteer firefighting
community and the call firefighting
community and so they actually were made
aware of this bill and and they came to
me and they asked me to ask this
question and and the question is just
basically looks like this bill is just
for for full-time firefighters and so is
that just because that's a pilot program
is the intention at some time to pull
those folks in or is is the long-term
intention of this just to be for
full-time firefighters so their question
is just they're just trying to
understand the the scope and what role
it might play for them in the future
thank you thank you this is this is a
beginning point this is a starting point
this is establishing this program as
with any prog program it can expand over
time so the the really the point is
let's get started let's we're going to
start with these folks and they can if
they feel that they need to be included
someone can file a bill and include
them you're welcome representative Seth
King thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking
questions this is a healthc care bill
and it's a it's a benefit of healthcare
and I'm curious
um firefighters are generally employees
of municipalities right and are there
any municipalities right now that offer
this benefit uh some do some don't or
none of them do and and uh why should
the state be taking over um paying for a
benefit that can be done and fought for
at the municipal level thank you okay
thank you um I can't answer the I I
believe the first part of the question
um those
are uh the contracts are done
individually through each municipality
and there's um some firefighters here
who could probably speak to that I would
hope that once the project gets started
and they start the state will start this
and the state will pay that it will
become part of their contract over time
that's what I'm I'm hoping that happens
but we all know how that works out
sometimes other question
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you senator for bringing this bill
before
us in regards to the funding mechanism
if I look at say an average cost of
$1,000 per fighter fighter which is I
think
reasonable given the fact there only $5
million in the if I do the math it's
5,000 firefighters is that going to be
sufficient to cover the number because
they can pay for it out of pocket my
concern is that once they pay for it out
of pocket if we run out of the money
because too many people get into the
line before they did that they won't
have the opportunity to get the $1,000
back thank you um this did go through
Senate finance and they felt that um
there was an adequate amount of money to
to for this program thank
you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak is Senator Donna
Manchester thank you very much Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record Donna Susi I represent the
town of Lichfield and five Wards in the
city of Manchester um you have a lot of
good questions and a lot of technical
questions many of which I believe will
be answered by the folks that will
follow me so let me be very brief in
saying that um part of the reason I'm
here is as a a co-sponsor of the bill
this was truly a priority of the Senate
you have both the majority leader and
minority leader here this bill did go
through um the Health and Human Services
committee policy Committee in the Senate
there was extensive testimony offered
about many of the technical aspects of
the bill questions were answered then um
it also went through the finance process
and the finance committee um and at each
stage it was unanimously supported I
think what's most important to recognize
is that we're talking about about a
small and distinct population whose
exposures to hazardous chemicals are 10
15 50 times more than what any of us
have and I know this committee has
considered a lot of legislation
surrounding pasas other hazardous
chemicals um the exposures that we're
talking about are like pasas on
steroids these individuals these men and
women who every day protect us in doing
their jobs are exposed to chemicals at
the scene of various sites and as was
mentioned by my colleague Senator Carson
um we've now come to learn that the very
gear that they are wearing to protect
themselves also May in fact be causing
hazards um I think what's most important
though is that you listen to the folks
that follow me um particularly you know
the chief of the fire department in
Manchester and um others are here that
will tell you about what's all already
been done to save lives and what's most
critical is that this bill will save
lives and will allow many of our brave
men and women to continue um in their
jobs and to continue to be able to go
home to their families at the end of the
day so with that I'd conclude my
testimony Mr chairman I I would take
questions but as I said I believe the
folks following me will be better able
to answer them with more specificity
okay and I also recognize your deadline
okay thank you appreciate that are there
any quick questions that Senator Susi
might be able to representative Lon um
thank you um thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Senator um just looking at
this policy-wise um obviously I'll hear
from the experts but if we come to the
ex with the four different areas covered
the blood test the ultrasound screening
the lung CT and the skin cancer
screening um at least in my opinion the
first two are experimental and the
second are proven and life saving
if we were to come to the decision that
just limiting it to the proven and
life-saving ones right now and focusing
on the rest in the future would you
believe that that would be a step
forward to help protect our firefighters
that we'd keep working on or would that
be a disappointment to you well I think
in part it would be a disappointment
because I believe some of these tests
have already been been run I I you know
recognize that you have concerns about
some of the diagnostic portion I believe
that the way the legislation is drafted
um that they would the committee formed
would be looking to various vendors uh
to provide the service and I think at
that point it would be the determination
of those experts what tests are needed
and what further tests are needed to
detect these cancers um I know you know
there are Physicians serving in the
legislature but I'm not one of them and
I would rather leave it to medical
professionals to make the determination
of what tests are need
needed any other questions for Senator
Susi thank you seeing gone thank you
very
be thank you
Senators also signed up to speak are
Justin cutting and Sean Tumi from the
Department of
gentlemen I guess we'll be real quick
then uh my name is Sean Tumi I'm the
State Fire missal good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee thank you
for the opportunity to speak briefly
this morning I'll Justin just Qui
introduce himself thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Justin cting I'm the director of fire
standards and training and
EMS um I think obviously we'll be brief
um what I would think are we've
submitted some written testimony through
the um online submission this um
yesterday the Department of Safety
Division of fire safety and division of
fire stand EMS are supportive of this
bill uh as We Know cancer is becoming a
or is a leading cause of death among our
firefighters in across the country uh as
I was kind of reflecting on uh coming
here this morning um this afternoon I
have to go to a wake of a firefighter a
New Hampshire firefighter that died um
with complications of cancer um and he's
definitely not the only one you'll hear
some more a couple more stories later
but that's real life today and the other
thing I was thinking about as I was
getting ready this morning I've been to
four fire scenes um this week and we
heard about the carcinogens and things
like that but as I got ready and shower
this morning after I've showered after
every fire I've been through I still
have the odor of a fire scene on me
after um after every day of clean
getting mult multiple showers every day
and I think that's to me it reminds me
of how much it lingers with us and the
after effects it has on us uh uh well
after the initial fire scene so um I
think that moving forward with this
program it's a great first step to to
protecting our First Responders and our
fire service in the state
uh I think it's important to mention the
call and volunteer that's a a huge
component of our state as well uh but I
I think is if we can take some first
steps and then bring it for you know
continue to advance this as we go and we
learn is is very important to help
protect those that protect us so uh I
don't want to go on too much further
happy to try to answer some questions
but thank you thank you very
much Mr chairman I just want to add to
the Marshall's comments that um within
this bill it gives the respons
posibility for the program to the
Department of Safety specifically our
division and I want the committee to
know that we are committed to working
within the committee outlined in this
bill and administratively to making this
program successful thank you thank you
representative shapo has a question go
ahead thank thank you Mr chairman I
don't know if it it's possible to say
but um having recently come across a
house you know fully o Blaze and the um
the smell was unbelievable um is it
possible to say to what extent the
cancer risk is a result of um chemicals
used to put out fires and protective
clothing versus the
actual stuff that's burning that fire
firefighters are trying to put
out sure thank you I I would suggest
It's a combination of all of those
things you heard from the Senators I
mean our gear that we wear our clothing
that we both have on now have some level
of past in them uh there's lots of
efforts to move forward to uh replace
those with different Alternatives but
there's definitely the synthetics are in
the that we have in our homes uh the
chemicals they're putting in our our
Fabrics whether it's our furniture our
mattresses um you know that that help
prevent the flammability then when they
when they do burn give off gasing to
that are cancer causing so I think it's
a combination of both and I I I don't
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question thank you for
being here today and thank you for all
you do um having had a house burn once
the fire Marshall's office
is very
helpful um so my question is with the
actual drafting of the bill uh as we
have heard at least one of my colleagues
has a concern about part of the bill as
it is currently
drafted and so my question for you is if
the two sections I'm I'm going to ask
this in multiple Parts if I may Mr
Speaker Mr chairman because I just
looking at drafting issues um if we
simply removed the part on lines 8
through 10 that says or 8 through 13
that has those two pro procedures that
says vendors who can do these procedures
are preferred if we were to remove
that is that a good thing or a bad thing
or how would you feel about
it I would ask someone from behind me
there speak to they're much more up to
speed on that component of the of the
bill fair enough and and um so I will
not ask you my follow-up questions which
are all in the same vein so so thank you
very much for taking the question other
questions representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you both for
what you do for the state and for people
and for being here um my question is if
the department of safety has people with
uh medical back background technology
and experience to be able to evaluate um
choosing given the number of employees
within the department I can't accurately
answer that question I think our
intention is to to work within the
committee established in this bill
identify those vendors um those
different types of tests that that may
fall in line with the legislation and
then really just make this program you
know as positive and successful as we
can thank you representative
palazov thank you and thank you for
taking my question uh I don't know if
it's a question for your department but
I just wonder if you have specific uh uh
for New Hampshire statistics for
firefighters in New Hampshire what kind
of cancers they experience if we see any
years I'm not aware of any specific New
Hampshire study but I think this program
part of the goal of it is to um identify
any uniqueness to New Hampshire to help
improve both in training and other
preventative techniques and methods
thank you other
Merchant thank you Mr chair um following
up on represent Weber um comment about
the lines 8 through 13 also looking at
lines 23 through 30 what I'm trying to
get to is rep Leon touched upon it is
somebody within the group has the
subject matter expert to what tests need
to be done to actually make it
meaningful so right now I don't see any
any any one in that list that has what I
call subject matter
expertise um to be sure that what's
going to the governor for
recommendations not just about the
process but the fact the test that we're
clinically I think uh maybe we could ask
U Brian will might who was instrumental
he's here going to testify this morning
but um I mean I think I would assume
that if we can find someone that would
help benefit the group in moving this
forward that we wouldn't want to
entertain that would be my take but um
you know I think our the fire service is
very interested in moving this forward
to try to help protect us the earli
early screenings and detection is proven
to be successful um and that's I think
the most important thing that we're
asking for your support and making
happen Mr R is signed up to speak and he
will be coming up next thank
you any other
questions representative plaz off uh
thank you for taking my uh second
question I just want to clarify oh uh
could you say on on what date did you
submit online
testimony
uh
yesterday other
you also signed up to speak is Brian
Ryle from the professional firefighters
Hampshire thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Brian ra I'm
the president of the professional
firefighters in New Hampshire and I'm a
fire captain in the city of
Portsmouth uh I'm here today to to shed
a light on the devastating reality that
is uh occupational cancer in the fire
service and I just want to give you a
statistic here 75% of the firefighters
added to the I that's the International
Association of firefighters Fallen
Firefighters Memorial in 2019 died from
occupational
cancer cancer is now the number one
killer of
firefighters it has surpassed uh sudden
cardiac death on the fire ground by a
long
shot we're here to tell you today that
we have never accepted this as the
narrative and we'll do anything in our
power to change
it Kyle Jameson Darren sabbin Jeff bokum
Sarah Fox Steve McKenna Jess Wyman and
Dan poula are just a few of our friends
that couldn't make it today their
memories are etched in our hearts as
recent symbols of the profound
sacrifices made to New Hampshire
communities they all died of
Occupational
cancer each one of these firefighters
like so many others here in New
Hampshire have fulfilled their oath to
Serve and Protect and in exchange were
given a terminal occupational cancer
diagnosis and died in active
duty when a firefighter swear as an oath
they're aware of the many inherent risks
of the job but the risks much like the
complexity of our profession continue to
be Ever
Changing in today's age many modern-day
textiles and building materials are
engineered using polycarbonates that off
gas when burned compounding the risks of
an already hazardous profession and to
make matters worse many of these
materials are coated in synthetic
chemical compounds known as pasas or
forever chemicals Wily known for
imposing a variety of health effects on
the human
body in recent years scientists have
identified the prevalence of these
chemicals in the firefighter PPE that we
wear marketed for use as durable water
and oil repell repellants this means
that the very gear that firefighters
wear to keep themselves safe is killing
them this is an Unown necessary and
unacceptable risk the International
Association of firefighters continues to
fight back against the manufacturing and
Regulatory Agencies that fail to
acknowledge the presence of these
chemicals resulting in firefighters
across the country like those that I
mentioned earlier and those in this room
today taking matters into their own
hands and that's why we're here before
you today routine cancer screenings are
proven to be the gold standard for
Education prevention and mitigation of
Occupational cancer they promote early
detection and offer potentially
life-saving interventions for
firefighters while reducing long-term
Financial exposure for employers
employees and insurance
companies fire departments across the
state have developed best practices
guidelines and policies to reduce the
exposure to these cancer-causing agents
and while we've seen a significant
cultural shift in the fire service to
eliminate these exposures firefighters
continue to die from cancer at an
alarming rate
the plan we bring before you today is
not one that we're hoping will reduce
these firefighter cancer deaths but one
that has already been tested and proven
to be successful each one of these
diagnostic
tests uh detects cancer signals through
various parts of the
body a simple blood draw has been proven
effective at identifying 21 possible
cancer signal Origins that detect nearly
50 types of cancer throughout the body
you could start wrapping up please I
will
I you know what I will cut it short
because I think that there are people
behind me that can uh testify to the
impact of these tests uh a little more
personally but I would like to uh answer
a couple of the questions that were
asked if I may sure um uh thank you
representative for your questions I am
not a uh a physician or or a clinical
expert um my apologies for not bringing
in uh Dr Hamrock um who is the uh
clinician out of Boston that we brought
in before the Senate was able to testify
to um the clinical validity of all of
these tests um and I just do want to
point out um a simple Google search will
show you um through oncology testing um
that these these tests have been proven
to detect cancer signals regardless of
whether or not they are FDA approved at
this point it is less than an
experimental test we have firefighters
throughout the country that have been
found to have cancer through
specifically the blood testing um
firefighters in Virginia Beach
firefighters in San Francisco this test
has worked and what it does is it
provides a cancer signal it doesn't tell
you that you have this type of cancer it
provides a signal that enables you to
get a follow-up testing that will
determine further what that cancer is
there was a firefighter in Virginia
Beach specifically um that had this this
blood test done they they detected a
cancer signal in his blood test he went
for further follow on testing and it was
found that he had esophageal cancer and
he didn't even have any symptoms so
regardless of uh the testing
phase um these tests have been proven to
work so much so that the organization
that represents nearly 350,000
firefighters in this country are using
it um so we would ask to keep the bill
um um to keep all parts all aspects of
the bill within it um we do not want to
damage the Integrity of the testing and
I would just remind you just to to
finish up here this is a pilot program
we're not asking the state to move
forward with this testing or any part of
it for a long-term cause we're asking
for
onetime testing funds so that we can
compile data that's necessary to look at
how we want to build along term program
thank you representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you very much
for addressing that um I did read the
testimony from the Senate hearing um
were was he speaking to the gallery test
as being the tested impr proven blood
test that's the one he mentioned in his
testimony so yes okay thank you um as a
followup um that one's showing some
signals but it it definitely is not um I
guess I I have question about whether
about your classification of it as
tested and proven I do um
um so thank you sure other questions
representative
McLean oh I'm sorry representative Weber
no no no problem okay yeah
my thank you
um my question would be um the more
specific drafting issues
um I think you've answered what would
have been my first one uh but I noticed
that in the packet from the professional
firefighters which was submitted to us
one of the things that they have asked
to remove from the bill as currently
drafted is to Simply strike out the skin
cancer screening and I'm wondering why
you want to strike that out sure thank
you representative for your question um
I would like to stress that we don't
want to strike that out because we don't
think that this in a vital piece of the
testing the only reason we would want to
consider striking that out is because uh
we have found uh in doing our due
diligence early on to work with um
stakeholders that might be involved in
this process moving forward what we've
determined is that all of our
firefighters in the state currently have
access with minimal barriers to a
Dermatology exam um just by a referral
of their PCP
um it's a very easy test to get anyone
in this room should you have I would say
average health insurance would approve
that test uh again with very minimal
barriers um and without uh having we're
trying to be purposeful and responsible
with the state's funds here um and we
don't think that it would be
necessary uh for the state to pay for
that test uh when it's so easy easily
covered under health insurance could I
have a followup um second followup from
that part of the um Bill if we were to
remove the section on lines 8 to13
requiring the preference for vendors
with the ability to test for the
following and simply left
in uh The Language online six and seven
that consists of a blood test an
ultrasound of violet or VI of vital
organs and a CT if
indicated how would that be for
you so you would strike out um vendors
with the ability to test uh for the
following shall be preferred and then
I'm sorry I don't have the lines
numbered so up to where first of all I
wouldn't strike it at all but I'm trying
to figure out with a minimum of Time how
to draft a
bill that
might be acceptable to people um so I'm
just trying to figure out what
individuals positions are on various
parts of the bill for drafting purposes
so um my question now that thank you you
can give me the lines again to
representative Shapiro for the line
numbered copy um it's the this I'm
asking you about the lines from 8 to 13
which are the ones that say these
particular vendors will be
preferred and my question is if instead
of specifying that and simply saying
that the cancer screening will consist
of a blood test ultrasound and the lung
CT if indicated because you've indicated
that you don't you're not concerned
about the cancer screening so much the
skin cancer screening um is that an
acceptable
way to go or does
that do you feel that that leaves out a
vital piece of what you want to see in
the bill sure thank you for your
question I think I understand it now um
I think that if that was what was going
to be satisfactory to the committee that
we would be agreeable to that um the
reason that we had uh those lines in
there was to try and nail down a little
bit more specifically what it is that we
were looking for but as I understand it
um that could always be developed and
presented um through the committee's
work um and then ultimately identified
through an RFP process through the state
um so as long as we were to maintain the
Integrity uh of lines 5 through S I
would be agreeable to those Chang and
including the skin cancer screening or
ex or without the skin to remove the
skin cancer screening and Mr chair may
may I have one more it's not quite a
followup but uh it is with the
submission of the professional
firefighters packet so my question would
be uh the other thing that I think you
were willing to that you were asking to
have stricken was on uh later on and
again I don't have the line numbers on
it but under Roman five striking not to
exceed a cost of 1,300 per ex per
individual and so my question is why
strike that and how much per individual
is it estimated that an adequate
screening might cost sure thank you for
your question um the reason we struck
that is we were doing um this is not a
program I I should say that we developed
from scratch we got this from other uh
iff State organizations that are doing
it New Jersey specifically has a program
in place um that is functioning very
similar to what this is um we had gotten
the $1,300 number from them um just by
looking at some of the vendors that
offered some of these tests doing some
simple addition and finding out what the
cost might be what we've determined is
that uh like everything else the costs
of tests go up over time we don't want
to paint ourselves into a corner and
then find that we can't offer all of
these tests within that
$1,300 cap um so what we like to do is
maintain the overall cost of the bill
because we still believe that that will
be enough to cover the testing for all
firefighters in in the state um but
should costs be adjusted for any
specific tests over time then this would
not handcuff us under the 1300 so what
we would propose is just to scratch that
um and keep it open thank you very much
for those answers representative McLean
and then representative McKay thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so um this is obviously not the
first time that this has been done so
you're you're building this program upon
things that you say have worked in other
areas Virginia Beach San Francisco um
you just mentioned New Jersey so in my
first question would be in those cases
is they're doing all of this in those
cases um you know or are they doing
parts of it or are they doing all of it
I'm assuming they're doing all of it but
um but then my other question is having
done that that's going to going to be a
pretty large statistical sampling this
is we're talking large population
centers um so can you speak to any
statistical shift in in the incident
rates of Occupational cancer you're
talking about 75% here it's great to
have anecdotal data but it would be nice
to understand you know are we seeing a
statistically significant benefit from
this in those jurisdictions where this
has already been tried thank you sure
thank you for your question um I
wouldn't be able to give you statistical
numbers um and really anything aside
from anecdotal but what I would tell you
is New Jersey is the only state so far
that I'm aware of in the iff that has a
comprehensive program that includes all
of these pieces um that that was a uh a
first of its kind we have taken their
model which is proven to be successful
and built off of that um to bring it
here in New Hampshire I will tell you
that um the International Association of
firefighters is paying attention to New
Hampshire very very closely right now um
to ensure that we're able to be
successful in this because this is the
model program that they want developed
they have um chief medical officers on
staff they have done the scientific
research behind this that I cannot do um
to prove that this does work just uh I I
will give you one um one number um there
were of the testing that was done in New
Jersey there were 21 ultrasound
Diagnostics that were proven to have
findings so um somewhat significant
based on you know when you look at
whether or not we're going to provide
these tests or we're not to our personal
position is if you can save one
firefighter through this testing process
then this process has been successful um
to to talk about 21 in the state of New
Jersey um is fairly
significant followup so um but did did
New Jersey have a a finished report come
out and is that something that we could
maybe have an opportunity to look at um
we might be able to find some
preliminary data for you but the tests
are
ongoing but um Ju Just the further uh
answer your question there are states
throughout the country that have done
done portions of these tests um some
have brought in for instance uh the
gallery blood testing um and they've had
success in determining cancers there
some have brought in ultrasound
diagnostic they've had success
determining cancers there we've actually
had some communities within the state
buy into this and bring them in for
themselves so that also will help Drive
the cost down some uh conquered for
instance is one of them uh they provided
ultrasound diagnostics for their members
um at the municipal level so we would
not have to then further test those
members um if it was in within a certain
period of
time thank you representative McKay and
then representative kofel thank you Mr
chairman uh this is a fairly simple
question I think I heard you say you
wanted us to keep this bill and that
would mean that we would retain it and I
think you meant that we passed this bill
we can't retain it representative it's a
that can't be done this yeah and I I
just I just wanted to be very clear that
he wanted to pass this Bill yes uh to be
very clear yes we're asking you to pass
it my my apologies for not word smithing
it
correctly representative kofalt and then
representative
Lon thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so um how many uh
the the bill refers to permanent
firefighter which I assume means kind of
a full-time career firefighter not a
volunteer um how many permanent
firefighters are there in the state of
New Hampshire uh so we would be working
off of the New Hampshire retirement
system numbers and it's approximately
4,000 okay so that's include active plus
retired correct okay uh followup
followup um so I understand that um
since 20 10 most most health insurance
plans have covered certain kinds of
cancer screenings and early cancer
detection um how much overlap is there
or I I guess my my question is could
These funds or would These funds be used
to pay for screenings that are already
available through healthare coverage
employer employer based healthc care
coverage for these firefighters thank
great question um I would say that the
that is the reason for the desire to
strike out the Dermatology exam because
we don't want that overlap again we're
trying to be responsible um with State
funding here uh but to my knowledge and
and what we've been able to to determine
working with the Physicians um and the
insurance companies these are not tests
that are covered unless you have um
symptoms so if you were to go to your
PCP and have some sort of symptom that
would drive you to get a blood test or
an ultrasound or a lung CT um then they
would send you otherwise it would not be
indicated uh representative Lon defers
Merchant thank you m Mr chairman also
thank you taking the question in New
Jersey I heard that there's a chief
medical officer somebody's a subject
matter expert when I look through in
lines 23 through
27 I don't see reference to a subject
matter expert amongst the group so if
we're looking for medical expertise to
help make sort of a fundamental decision
on what test should be done to If It
Strike if you will 8 through
13 where do you think that expertise
should come from or should it be
somebody in this bill that is going to
be a subject matter expert to help guide
the firefighter
themselves thank you for your question
um so this is somewhat interesting so
last year um we had Senate Bill 71 which
came before um the uh houseing DNA as
part of that we had put in a commission
to study uh offering cancer
screenings and by and large we were told
by uh the house
that we should not have a commission on
this in fact it should come from the
firefighters doing their research and
bringing forward the program that has
proven to work um so we were told in
that process that it was our
responsibility to meet with subject
matter experts to determine what the
best possible testing was to offer we
have done that which is why we you know
we didn't just create this out of thin
air we've we've met with Physicians that
have told us that this this
comprehensive list of testing um when
all pieced together is the best possible
screening on the market um
so to answer your question they are not
within here only because we've done our
research up to this point um but if it
makes all of you more comfortable um to
add in a subject matter expert then
that's to that's completely appropriate
otherwise we were just planning to go
about um working with the folks that
have steered us up until this point
up if we delete the reference to the um
8 through 13 those are things that
basically have been recommended by a
subject matter expert to the group so
how would we replace that if we don't
have someone that the firefighter is
going to work with within the subject
matter itself if we no if we don't
become prescriptive and more descriptive
then I'm just concerned that we don't
have the ability of having the knowledge
base if you need to replace those test
sure um I would agree with that and
quite frankly as it came up earlier I
had mentioned that um if it
was it was something that we could work
with within the committee um something
that we could work with as part of the
RFP process um even if this committee
chose to strike those lines uh that
information is still there and available
to tell us that this is ultimately um
what we would want to be looking for so
if there was an RFP drafted or the
committee determined that these are the
pieces that we were looking for that
took priority then we could still
utilize
that representative Lon and then
representative Weber um thank you Mr
chairman um so um you said that New
Jersey already passed a law like this
but when I pull that up and I pull up
the bill that was passed in 2021
their their law looks very very
different than what was proposed here um
so if you're building off that expertise
I'm trying to understand the disconnect
um between that and your bill um but I
guess probably more importantly if we
were to strike lines 8 through 13 which
is about the um Gallery test and the
ultrasound um are you saying that it
would it would be done
anyways I'm not saying that it would be
done I'm saying that if the
funds were approved in this bill were to
pass and we were looking for um and we
weren't to strike uh that the test would
consist of a blood test an ultrasound of
vital organs or lung CT
that this process would have to go
through the states RFP process and that
would go out to bid and subsequently
someone other than me would be making
the determination as to the vendors that
would be chosen I'm not saying it would
be gallery or it could be D with
Hitchcock it could be Elliott um
whoever's willing to provide these tests
um would be who I assume the state would
choose um as for the New Jersey
testing um like I said that's still in
process their testing is but as far as
their law is concerned it's broken up a
couple of different ways because some of
them have um State funed Healthcare some
of them don't um some of them have
private healthcare so they've actually
had to piece together some of these
tests in order to make it work um New
Hampshire would certainly be leading the
way as far as um I would say without
sounding offensive an organized plan for
this testing um so we would be uh a
first in first in the nation in that
respect thank you other questions
representative palazov uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh I I wonder if you can uh
follow up with sending committee uh any
data you have specific to New Hampshire
and uh cancer types uh um that five
Fighters uh struggling here and uh uh
also professional firefighters of New
Hampshire provided us with firefighter
cancer risk chat is my understanding
correct the those numbers are National
and not just for New Hampshire do you
know
correct and that's information I think
it's cited on the bottom where that K
comes
from other
you also signed up to speak is
Christopher Wyman I believe New
Hampshire State Fire
Association if I'm reading those
initials
correctly okay
you ask for five minutes sir if you
could keep it closer to three I'd
appreciate it absolutely sir good
morning and thank you for actually
putting on this hearing today my name is
Chris Wyman um I'm a 32-year member of
the New Hampshire fire service I'm a
lieutenant currently with the marac fire
department and the first vice president
of the New Hampshire State fireman's
Association and I'm here today standing
before you to support and hopefully you
guys will pass this bill um the New
Hampshire State fireman's Association
represents approximately 3 uh 3600
career call and volunteer firefighters
throughout the state of New Hampshire
and as what's been said earlier today
this is a necessary first step for what
we need to do to battle cancer and
firefighters I'm also here today for
another reason on January 5th 2023 my
wife who was a 26e member of the New
Hampshire fire servic as well a ASA
firefighter was diagnosed with lung
cancer on November 28th 2023 she died
from occupational cancer that was
directly related to her being a
firefighter in the state of New
Hampshire and for the city of nsha so if
you guys are looking for a reason to
pass a bill like this I'm here before
you to say you know what a family has to
go through what a firefighter has to go
through through this you guys want to
talk about the screenings and all that
stuff my wife for the years she was at
nsha she went through she was a
firefighter she was on the HazMat team
she was a member of the dive team nsha
fire requires annual physicals annual
chest x-rays pulmonary function tests
blood tests especially for the members
of the HazMat team
those physicals did not detect her
cancer by the time we found out she had
cancer the doctors thought she had
pneumonia you talk about the screening
parts that are part of this bill the and
the insurance that goes into it
Insurance wants you to go through the
through the leest cost thing first and
that's what my wife experienced she had
to go through through chest x-rays
multiple chest x-rays they didn't go to
a CAT scan on her chest in her lungs
until it was determined that all right
we went through chest x-rays in
September we went through chest x-rays
in November we went through courses of
treatment to to address pneumonia and
things like that and it still didn't
work and then finally the insurance
company said sure we'll approve a CAT
scan once that CAT scan was done yeah
there was no doubt but by that point so
we went through through months of going
through this but at that point my wife
was diagnosed with and bear with me cuz
I'm going to screw up the name art
ardino carcinoma non- small non-s small
cell lung cancer that was aggressive in
nature that by the time she was
diagnosed she had stage for and was
mestic cancer to her
bones so to go through that treatment to
talk about those blood tests her doctors
at Mass General her doctors at Dana
Farber all you used those if you don't
want to say they're not FDA tests they
used those blood tests to not only
Define the type of cancer she had but to
actually go after the proper treatment
and hoping to cure her cancer
unfortunately that didn't work we like
to say that she had the Dream Team
Doctor Who from Mass General Dr narges
Flores from Dana Farber Dr Flores is
probably one of the leading oncologists
for women in lung cancer
and especially firefighters and deployed
military personnel and she was my wife's
leading oncologist and every time Dr
Flores would say hey we know this blood
test or this or whatever it's not FDA
approved but it's going to help us with
clinical trials it's going to help us
better Define things for you and stuff
like that so A bill like this yeah
should fire departments in municipality
Statewide have this as part of their
program 100 100% but we have to start
somewhere the data has to come from
somewhere and like like I said using
typical fire department physicals today
they're not covering these things
insurance companies aren't necessarily
covering these things they're not
covering them until such time as
something comes up and then they say all
right we're going to move forward from
here even though my wife had lung cancer
even though she was already diagnosed
with that every single time we came up
with a PET scan so every 90 days she had
to go through a pet scan but because of
the insurance can't do the Pet Scan
first we got to go back to chest x-rays
we got to go back to CAT scans and then
if we don't get the data off from those
then we can do a pet scan what she
needed every 90 days a pet scan we had
to go through all that stuff all over
again every single
time so I ask I really do I know the
bills a lot it's a $5 million price tag
I think like I said heavy been in the
fire service myself having accepted the
risk that these guys have all talked
about today myself being exposed to the
carcinogenic smoke being exposed to the
fire scenes as not only a firefighter I
was a fire and explosion investigator
having represented and done line of duty
death investigations in the state now I
get to sit on the other side of that
same
table because my wife was determined to
be her cancer was determined to be
occupational related so now today I come
before you sitting on both sides of that
table not only is a firefight fighter
but as a spouse and a
Survivor and I hope you guys do my
wife's birthday was the 22nd which was
Monday so it would be a great gift if
this committee passed this Bill thank
you thank you chairman thank you
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you I I'm so sorry for
your wife's loss thank you for her
service and your service thank you um um
I I appreciate why it's so personal and
why it's such a challenge for you um but
I I do want to know that those blood
tests were pretty different I'm sure as
a firefighter you know not all chemical
fires are the same abut not all blood
tests are the same so I hope you
understand that I'm talk we're talking
this The Spill is talking about a very
different blood test than what those
experts and your wife was treated by the
experts because I know that field so she
was very lucky to have that exposure but
I hope you understand it's a very
different test than what's asked for in
this bill I do and that was how it
started though you got to remember that
started with not thinking that was
cancer at all and we had to start
somewhere and those those simple blood
test that they're talking about this how
they started with us and when the
markers came up and going through
everything else she went through
numerous blood tests at the beginning
you know and even procedures to
determine what she had how she had it
where was it everything else but right
so she had the gallery test she did
thank you representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair and thank you for your
testimony I am very sorry to hear about
your loss thank you um assuming this
bill goes through and we get all the the
data that everybody's looking for do you
then expect to
see um the sorts of screenings funded by
the state or then do you expect the
municipalities to finally start stepping
up and fulfilling more of their role
financially to do this I hope the data
that comes out of this I mean with any
with any pilot program call it a beta
test or even if you just follow the
scientific method you got to you got to
collect data to be able to create what's
that permanent solution going to look
like um do I expect the state to do to
do it all by themselves I don't I think
the data needs to be driven it's got to
start somewhere and if this means rather
than by the state doing this part part
of it we get to look at the State of New
Hampshire and not just one or two
specific communities or jurisdictions
that might decide to do it so at least
if we do this and a 24-month program and
we can have that broad of a reach at
least it's a start and then like I said
at the end they can better Define okay
what will local jurisdictions have to do
and whether that's for career
departments or even departments that are
volunteer and do they now start
requiring physicals and the cancer
scheming as well for call and volunteer
firefighters as well which is just as
important thank you representative Paz
off thank you Mr chair uh sorry for your
loss and thank you for for your service
uh I have a question about uh prices for
those tests if you have any idea you
mentioned that some test are not uh
covered until something uh comes up or
some tests are not uh some scans are not
uh performed uh until after x-ray is
performed so if you can give me any idea
how much I'm bet on acronyms but you
mentioned cat and I believe pet scans uh
what kind of pricing we we are looking
with those tests the pricing I sorry I I
don't know uh I mean alls I can speak to
I mean it was a it's a it's a hefty
price tag um can I break down what each
individual test cost I I can't um as an
exam I mean if you want an example just
one months of just appointments I mean I
got a bill I got a bill last month for
Mass General it's $111,000 that my
insurance company didn't didn't cover
you know so it's it and that's month
after month after month and my wife's
been gone six months almost so I mean it
it's it's it's a hefty price tag on
families and all that stuff because
insurance insurance doesn't necessarily
cover all of
it thank you representative
Weber thank you and I too am sorry for
your loss and and thank you and your
wife for being the people that you
are um I want to be sure I understand
what the timeline was with your wife's
treatment you said that she had the
gallery test but she did not have it am
I right in understanding that she didn't
have it until
significantly after she had already
exhibited symptoms which were initially
Miss diagnosed as as pneumonia is that
correct that's correct so am I also
correct in thinking that had she had
that
test prior to developing
symptoms her outcome might have been
different the last part of that's a
pretty broad reach I we don't know yeah
I I don't know um I I can tell you that
her oncologists wished that tests like
the gallery test were performed as
yearly physicals okay and maybe that
would give um you know cuz again she's
being a member of the fire department
but also the HazMat team and all that
stuff they did additional blood tests to
you know are they exposed heavy metals
are they exposed other toxins stuff like
that but you know that was one of the
thing that both Doctor Who and Dr Flor
has talked about was they wish that
tests like that were in fact given on an
annual basis that maybe would provide
the benchmarks of the flags or whatever
that would say hey there's a problem and
we need and we need to look into this
further just so just as a follow follow
up so what we're really looking at here
is that the these tests as specified in
the bills would provide a an early
warning system so that further uh tests
could be done and have a justification
for it that's the goal thank you thank
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very much again we're sorry for your
sir also signed to speaker Ryan cash and
gentlemen the record I'm Ryan cashen
chief of the Manchester fire
department chash president man
thank you committee members for having
us here today I'm going to try to
can I'm here to testify and support of
Senate Bill 352 which will provide
cancer screenings for all active and
retired firefighters the Manchester fire
department in conjunction with Dartmouth
Hitchcock Anthem Blue Cross Blue Shield
the Manchester professional firefighter
Association developed the pilot program
for early detection cancer
screenings the goal of this pilot
program is to show proof of of concept
based on statistical data that showed
that lung cancer and skin cancer are two
of the most prevalent cancers amongst
firefighters Nationwide it was
determined that a Dermatology screening
along with a lung
CT was the best course of action this
Baseline screening will act as a
foundation for all future
screenings we started with a full
Dermatology screening offered to every
firefighter in the city totaling 204
members with 184 members agreeing to be
screened
which is over 90% of the department
Dartmouth Hitchcock mobilized a team of
dermatologists and we screened 184
members in 5 days of the 184 22
firefighters were scheduled for a
followup with a Dartmouth Hitchcock
dermatologist the initial criteria if
the lung CT screening was 40 years old
with 10 years firefighting service 130
members met this initial criteria and we
screened 125 members which is over
96% of the 125 members screen we had
third 32 incidental findings from the
screenings and those members were
encouraged to follow up with the PCP an
additional 16 members referred to
pulmonary at Dartmouth Hitchcock for a
follow-up appointment of the 16 referred
to pulmonary 14 fell into what they call
a category 3 or a category
4 that's a total of 48 members of the
125 that needed some sort of follow-up
care which comes out to 38% of the
members that were screened
we are currently working with DAR to
schedule all remaining members for a
long
screening as stated earlier the goal is
to show proof of concept and we live in
a world filled with Statistics and data
today the statistic that matters most is
how many lives are saved this pilot
program has already saved One Life due
to the early detection cancer screening
program one Manchester firefighter was
diagnosed with stage two
cancer Fire Marshall Pete lon's cancer
was detected Ed and diagnosed at an
early stage and with a successful
operation at Dartmouth Hitchcock to
remove his cancer completely he was able
to return to work cancer-free in less
than four
weeks Fire Marshall lennin is alive
today because of the screening provided
his wife and daughters didn't lose a
husband and a father and there's no
better example of how early detection
can save
lives the statistical data is empirical
firefighters are going to be diagnosed
with cancer and it is a question of when
not if with this is the only reasonable
conclusion it comes down to a question
of cost as the fire chief of the state's
largest Department I entirely understand
what it means to work within a budget
this program has a price and I take that
very
seriously however I urge you we cannot
look at this in a vacuum to per form of
a complete cost analysis it will not be
just the cost of the screenings versus
the cost of cancer treatment the
analysis must also consider how long a
firefighter will be out of work and the
impact on operations it also must
consider the emotional and mental
fatigue it puts on a department all of
these factors need to be taken into
account firefighters are going to do
their jobs they will risk their lives
and perform aggressive interior
firefighting knowing that they are not
only risking their lives in the fire
ground but also putting their health at
risk every day they will still do their
jobs it is not what we do it is Who We
Are
my job as fire chief is simple make sure
my members have the tools they need to
do their job I am here today to do that
to make sure every firefighter in the
state receives a baseline early
detection cancer screening we've shown
it can be done and the statistics show
it can be
done I heard you all to support Senate
Bill 352 let's ensure that we provide
the necessary tools for firefighters to
do their jobs which is to save lives and
property I want to say thank you and
understand if some of you have some
questions I would love to answer them
okay representative Seth King and then
representative Weber thank you Mr chair
and thank you for your testimony you're
probably the exact person I'm looking to
get the qu the question answered um it
sounds like manchest city of
Manchester's really led the way on these
these screenings um do you know uh where
that came from did that come from the
city of Manchester's budget did that
come out of your budget did it come from
insurance who paid for that I can answer
that question uh the screenings were
done um Dartmouth Hitchcock paid for all
the screenings to be done we had very
intense conversations with Dartmouth
Hitchcock um and they were willing to do
this at no cost to us um as they once we
showed them the data of the cancer wide
uh the cancer firefighters are getting
Nationwide they understood the
importance of this they understood that
we were trying to also pass a bill
moving forward and then they understood
that we want to show proof of concept
and that proved concept was that we can
do these screenings you know it is going
to show results and it is needed mhm uh
follow up follow up okay thank you for
that response excellent um assuming we
go through with this bill in the future
who do you see footing the bill for the
screenings I mean Dartmouth Hitchcock's
probably not going to do this free all
the time for all the municipalities do
you see that then coming out of your
Department's budget the the the the
municipality as a whole budget or the
state would always be picking up the
bill or Insurance where do you see that
going I believe that the my personal
opinion is that moving forward the idea
of this screening program that we
currently have is to build a data set
okay that's what we did with our
firefighters we built a data set and we
showed okay that there are results from
this and it's worth taking the next step
with this data set we're going to show
those same results Statewide once having
that data set it is my belief that this
should be part of a firefighter's
personal health insurance for the record
I believe that this is a very important
bill and this is a first step
okay and in vital first step in order to
build the data that we need in order to
provide the proper screenings moving
forward for every single firefighter in
the state but I do believe that should
fall in their insurance I'll be
perfectly honest with this committee I
do not believe that our my firefighters
should be going to a fire station along
with Dartmouth Hitchcock Personnel to
perform Dermatology screenings this is
not the way healthc care should be done
the firefighters of the state deserve to
have these cancer screenings done by
their primary care physician
and the privacy of their own uh doctor
rooms that is that is my opinion I
believe that is the way it will be done
in the future I believe that this step
this bill as it is will show the
necessary data that we can then talk
with the health insurance companies and
make those changes there I have had
talks with several health insurance
companies
they understand the importance of this
they understand that the cost of cancer
is very expensive and I can assure you
from what they've told me that this is
the better way to go based on the data
that we've proved that firefighters are
going to get cancer right I cannot sit
up here and promise you that they're not
going to it is going to happen Okay the
fires that we are fighting are worse
today than they were 20 years ago okay
the chemicals in these fires are bad and
we are going to go in and we're going to
save
lives in order to do that you know as
safe as possible we have to have the
proper protective equipment the right
equipment I look at these cancer
screenings as one of those tools no
different than protective clothing no
different than a fire truck no different
than a fire hose thank you very much
representative Weber and then
representative
Lon so I have one question and a follow
up if I may Mr chair uh my first
question is um the statistics that you
gathered based on the screenings that
you did um did you submit those online
to us and do we have those or is that
something you could email to members of
the committee so that we have those
statistics because some of us didn't
write them down quite as quickly as we
uh absolutely I did not I'll be honest
with you um I don't spend that much time
up here I didn't know that was a thing
so I apologize for that um but yes I
will get them to whoever it is that I
need to get them to if you can simply
email them to the committee members or
maybe email them to the chairman so that
he can we that was really very helpful
uh and my second question because of
your discussion of the Dermatology
screening is um if I have a proposal to
eliminate the skin screening that came
from the professional firefighters are
you for that or are you against that uh
I am in support of that so what we found
through these cancer screenings talking
at length with Dartmouth with Elliott um
with the health insurance companies is
that most firefighters almost every
firefighter is eligible for Dermatology
screening so I think it would be a
better use of money that the state is
appropriating to use it towards the
other tests we can get these tests I
believe that it's an educational um uh
educational training that we can do with
our members to explain to them that you
need to be talking to your doctor you
need to be getting these tests I can
assure you that since we've done these
tests I've had more conversations with
doctors they understand better when we
first initially started this it was
difficult um but as we start making the
case and we start showing the data um
the the doctors are on board and I
believe that we can get these
Dermatology screenings through our
doctors where they should be okay thank
you very much that's very helpful
representative blon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here I
apologize that I wasn't here right at
your start I was just trying to make
sure we can get this bill done today um
as far as the pro the program that
happened in Manchester was that the lung
screening and the Dermatology or was
there anything else involved in that
screening program we did a lungs CT in a
Dermatology screening it was a decision
that we started with those two tests to
see how that would go uh some of that
had to do just strictly with Logistics
uh it is very large fire department
there's a lot of moving parts that we
had to do um this was multiple multiple
months to get this done and I couldn't
be prouder of the members of the fire
department that were contributed to help
out that's a followup followup U thank
you and as a followup do you think that
um extending that I guess you said the
Dermatology is not necessarily required
since that's already available um but
would extending the lung can lung lung
CT screening across the state be a
significant step forward because what
we're hearing now is we want to set
Baseline data and we want to get this
started but whatever we pass Now isn't
going to be the end all be all we're
just moving forward in the process with
lung screenings across the state be a
meaningful step forward for firefighter
safety in New
Hampshire yes lung screenings would I
believe all the tests are are are vital
in order to build that sample set um you
know this is an important step to find
out what that data is you know um for
example you know thyroid cancer is
really picking up across the country
okay and having a specific test to do
that which is an ultrasound test um as
I've been told is the best way to find
that cancer from medical professionals
such as people from darmouth and Elliott
uh you know I I don't do ultrasounds
I'll be honest with you um right but uh
I I believe all these tasks will provide
the necessary data so that don't the
goal is for those onetime programs to
build that data set come back look at
the data and see what happens you know I
I can't tell you exactly what this what
tests go forward you know after this um
maybe they all do maybe they don't I I
believe that's a decision that we can
make after once seeing the the full data
set of all these tests and if I have one
more followup um and so you said
Baseline data so any of these tests if
there was the blood blood screen for all
these different cancers you'd be looking
to have that be a baseline to compare
the test today with the test in the
future is that correct when I one yes uh
also when I refer to a baseline the goal
would be to get firefighters screened
upon entry into the fire service so that
we have a full Baseline of what their
health condition is when they get on and
then you know for some of us 25 years
later what it looks like then um cuz it
changes you know uh every firefighter I
know that has retired has some sort of
me uh physical issue once they retire
thank you other
questions representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair going through this I heard
before I think a testimony the
importance of a CAT scan or even a pet
scan which is different than an
ultrasound diagnostic yes so are we
going down the road where we're not in
the bill anyways
identifying the appropriate test that
needs to be
done in the bill it has certain tests
that are outlined and and I support
those tests and that test the one that's
in there is a lung CT and I had that
test performed I'll be honest with you
it was the easiest medical test that I
have ever done it took approximately 4
minutes and uh from what I'm told it's
not a super expensive test I'm not going
to talk about Elliott and dartmouth's
crost but it it was probably the easiest
medical test I have ever had in my life
followup followup so again back to what
I'm hearing then is that the CT scan is
critical is the lung the rest of the
body is not so critical no I would say
it they're all critical because the
it on harder organs inside the body the
that will find cancer in those such as
thyroid so a lung CT for example will
not detect thyroid cancer and the reason
we're doing this very expansive panel is
that we are trying to find out
exactly how much cancer is out there in
the firefighters in the state of New
Hampshire and we need a we need a larger
testing pool to figure that out there
are Cancers that are happening across
the country that do not happen at the
same rate in normal citizens they just
don't um the the data on female
firefighters which is not compiled to a
point yet is already very scary you know
female firefighters are Contracting
cancer at an even faster rate than male
firefighters thyroid cancer which I'll
be perfectly honest with you I hadn't
even heard of until a couple months ago
is apparently starting to become very
rampant there are a lot of cancers that
are not symptomatic to the normal
population that firefighters are getting
and that I think it's important to have
the widest possible range of testing so
that we as a state and the
municipalities and the entire State of
New Hampshire can look at that and then
say okay what is our best move now
moving forward that we've compiled this
data that we can make this as safe as we
can for the firefighters in this state
thank
you other
questions representative
lonza thank you uh for taking my
question I just wanted to ask you said
you'd get a baseline initially but would
you um wait 25 years years or should you
do it sooner than that especially if you
have uh the exposure for past would you
want to wait 25 years to have another
test done no I understand your question
I apologize if I misspoke the goal would
be after this
initial Baseline test the goal would be
to get every firefighter screened upon
entry when they had hired to find out
what their Baseline is when they get
hired and then continually screen those
firefighters throughout their career to
make sure that they're not getting
cancer okay thank you very much
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
just to clarify you're originally the
intention here is to cast as broad inet
as possible because it's a funnel and
once you have had a chance to look at
all the data you may jettison stuff
basically and say this is this this is
cost with no benefit so we're going to
gen but this is very effective and so we
may not be ending up with this at all
this is just the top of the
funnel that is absolutely very possible
we're going to look at the data and see
what it comes out of it at the end of
the day as I stated earlier I do believe
that this belongs within a person's
personal health insurance and that you
know we're got to have the data to back
that up so some of the tests could stay
some of them could go we could have
maybe there's other ones that the health
insurance company say you know what why
don't we do this one I I believe that's
why we want to cast this wide net and
then make that decision afterwards
any other
questions seeing
you I think this is a duplication I I
have unless there's two Chris Wyman's
here I think uh good okay there's only
one Chris Wyman right okay no one else
has signed up to speak does anyone else
wish to testify on Senate Bill 352
FNA you see IGN Christina could you give
much um three people signed all in favor
of the bill on the blue sheet and
representative Lon is looking at uh who
um online were nine in support and two
OPP post thank you
representative okay um at this point
we're going to be going into executive
session on this bill I'm suspecting the
two parties will want to caucus on this
or representative Weber is yours I I
don't think we need to caucus
particularly let's take let's take five
minutes okay why don't we take a five
minute recess if we may and I will'll be
back okay we not needing to caucus I'd
love to have everybody just come over to
go
J
for
e
okay would like to reconvene and go into
executive session at this time on Senate
Bill 352 FNA representative Webby you
have an amendment to
distribute yes I do thank you Mr
chairman um uh let's try this and then
when it gets to the end just pass any
extras over to the other side
I think there should be enough for any
all it does just so you know is remove
the skin cancer screening
from
line
um from line seven of the bill uh It
just strikes out the skin cancer
screening because um I was told that
that is taken care of routinely under
exist ing health insurance
so that's the only thing I got are you
moving its adoption representative I
would be delighted to move its adoption
Mr chairman I would like to move the
adoption of amendment 2024 1461 H is
there a second second okay
representative McKay seconds and do you
want to speak to it further or you all
no I think that was enough thank you any
other discussion representative Lon um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Weber for bringing this
um this amendment is actually for page
two lines 5 through 7 and it removes the
individual um it's uh paragraph 5 a okay
I'm very sorry I have completely
misrepresented everything so I'm glad
you took a really solid look at it I I
know you had said that there at this
point I will not if if my seconder will
remove his second
I I will not offer this one oh okay it
it does doesn't do what I thought it did
representative MCC with second thank
you okay representative L also has an
amendment for our consideration yes I'd
like to move um amendment 20241 16498 to
352 it's coming down it's coming around
caucusing yeah so um I I'm not sure if
there's a second on this one yet have
you made have you moved yes I moved in
okay representative paza are you
seconding okay representative paza
seconds thank you um so um I had
initially sent over to remove both a
blood test and ultrasound of vital
organs from lines 6 through 7 and then
also lines 8 through 13 from the bill um
I had tried to change that so that it
didn't remove the blood test and
ultrasounded vital organs because I did
find that there were some valid reasons
for it um I I remain concerned with this
multi-cancer blood test test because um
it when it does become FDA approved it
will probably be a different test so it
won't serve as a baseline but um
similarly I see that it removed the
blood test so that means you can't even
have the fecal ult blood test as part of
this program and that would be should be
at least a minimum standard within this
um so perhaps it's worth also
withdrawing this one and then just going
for the bill itself because this isn't
exactly what I asked for in the
amendment sorry I was handing it out as
I was going through this
that's what happens when we try and uh
hear an exec on the fly so sorry
representative representative Weber um
so I too have been thinking about things
and having been directed to the correct
part of the statute
um this does actually remove the limit
of 1300 and we were told that that would
be okay
um so I am going to offer this amendment
if I may and I I will just
say that for me the whole point of
this is all the things we don't know and
as we learn more we do better but this
is the first step in learning more and
therefore doing better and I am so
hoping that we can pass the bill as as
it's with with the uh extra tests left
in and send it on to finance because I
think in terms of health
policy and the learning that we will
get just as the Manchester
firefighters gathered information that
showed the risks to their members and
targeted individual members for
treatment this will also allow us to
Target members for treatment early
and I'm not a doctor but I sure know
from my own family that very early
detection makes treatment far more
effective um so um I guess I would
actually if I may renew my motion for
H and it it removes the $1300 limit per
person on line six and seven of page two
representative McKay do you off you a
second again yes representative Leon you
wish to speak um yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Weber um if you look at the fiscal note
of this bill it says that there
3,626 individuals who would be
considered eligible under this bill at
the 5 million cost that we have that
would be
$1,378 192 because we don't want to
round up so we don't spend all the money
um my concern would just be about the
equity if we were to remove that $1,300
cap I suggest that uh just like some of
the other discussions we move we we pass
the bill unamended and just move our
discussion to finance so that we're not
acting hastily so I'll be voting against
the amendment but I appreciate you
bringing it you know I think that's fair
enough actually and I will if if if
you're withdrawing amendment I will
withdraw mine for the second time if all
right if representative McKay will
indulge me in in in withdrawing his
second we're we're going to get dizzy
here pretty soon yeah I mean
this if I may Mr chairman this is the
issue with doing these very complicated
bills on the Fly and what this committee
is really good at is taking a lot of
complicated data and discussing it
together and together we are way more
valuable than the sum of our parts so
this is a tough way to proceed but I I
think if we could vote on the original
bill I think that that's the best way
forward okay do I have a motion on the
original
Bill representative Lon moves I'll move
on to
pass okay uh representative Missour
seconds any discussion or representative
land do you wish to speak to your motion
um I I think we've said enough okay M
any other discussion seeing none I'll
ask the clerk to call the rooll motion
is ought to pass on Senate Bill 352
FNA representative Leon yes
representative Barry
yes clerk votes yes representative
kofalt yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative C
yes representative POF yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Lane yes representative
Lanza yes representative tez yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to zero
and it passes okay there's no objection
we'll put that on well we can't no
that's right I'm sorry it's a second
committee
Bill okay excellent good work
everybody M Mr chairman can you sorry
could I just thank everybody who joined
us at last minute absolutely thank you
everyone that session
sure okay that is the only Bill we had
for executive session so we will uh
close the executive session and open the
public hearing on Senate Bill 458 I
thank our substitutes for joining us
this morning I hope you found it
exciting and interesting and all that
okay and uh as we proceed to the public
hearing on Senate Bill 458 I will
recognize Dy fet who is representing uh
representing the prime sponsor Senator
avard good morning Mr
frette good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Daley Fett
and I am the Senate majority caucus
director Sen aard wasn't able to attend
this hearing and he asked me to
introduce his bill on his
behalf Senate Bill 458 was brought
forward on behalf of the New Hampshire
oncology and hematology which is a
medical practice that specializes in
treating patients suffering from cancer
this legislation would allow New
Hampshire oncology and hematology to
directly dispense a limited supply of
non-controlled oral anti-cancer drugs to
patients under their care the practice
took this issue to the Board of Pharmacy
and they ruled that they needed
legislative Clarity to allow the
practice to directly dispense to
patients 39 States including
Massachusetts Vermont and Maine allow
for the for direct dispensing of
anti-cancer drugs from providers this is
enabling legislation that does not place
any new mandates on insurers providers
or patients insurance companies can
still require covered members to use
preferred pharmacies and prior
authorization direct dispensing of oral
anti-cancer drugs is gaining popularity
around the country and has many benefits
for patients including better care
coordination and patient monitoring
reduce time from diagnosis to treatment
lower barri and lower barriers to
medication uptake and
adherence thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to speak this morning Dr
Peter Crow from New Hampshire oncology
and hematology is here today and he will
be able to answer any questions that the
committee has okay you're not taking any
questions I take it that I I would defer
to the doctor okay great thank you very
with that I will recognize Dr Peter Crow
from New Hampshire oncology and
hematology good morning doctor good to
again you asked for five minutes and
where you're also representing the prime
sponsor I'll give you that's that's fine
if you can keep it right around there
though it'd be great okay great I'm
happy to um good morning uh Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Dr Peter Crow I'm an
oncology hematology specialist with New
Hampshire oncology
hematology uh Mr chairman we have a um a
letter from our regional and National
Society that we'd like to submit as
written testimony is
that sure go ahead and distribute
it and then if you can also name which
societies when you sit down that'd be
you uh the regional Society is the um
northern New England
um uh Community oncology Society NEOS
and The National Society is ASCO
um um New Hampshire oncology hematology
is a medical practice consisting
consisting of more than a 100 staff
members including nine board certified
oncologists and
hematologists physician assistants and
advanced nurse practitioners uh
certified oncology nurses nurses
clinical Pharmacists and pharmacy
technicians our mission is to provide
expert compassionate medical care for
adults with cancer and blood related
diseases I appear before you in support
of Senate Bill 458 legislation that was
requested by our
organization in order to explain the
reasoning behind why we asked Senator
avard to file this bill I'd like to step
back and provide some
background in April 2023 our New
Hampshire oncology requested a
declaratory reading ruling from the New
Hampshire Board of Pharmacy on whether
Physicians could dispense non-controlled
prescription drugs in order to meet
patients immediate medical needs without
limitation on day supply except for what
was clinically appropriate ultimately
the board ruled that the request for
ruling was outside the board's
jurisdiction and that they did not have
the authority to do so which was up to
the legislature to Grant therefore we're
here today to ask for your support for
the concept of this legislation
over the past decade alternative
anti-cancer medications or analytics
have been brought to the market
replacing traditional intravenous
therapies the medications do not need to
be mixed or compounded and are almost
exclusively pills or tablets the
prescription the prescriptions free the
patients from having to physically be in
the clinic for treatment and instead
allows them to manage their Cancer
Treatments at home with proper
monitoring by their providers we have we
have found through our practice that
there are a number of clinical and
convenience-based challenges with the
Specialty Pharmacy dispensing process
currently patients must coordinate
deliveries which at times can be delayed
affecting a patient's clinical outcome
also complicating the process uh excuse
me is altering the doses of medications
for treatment when this occurs the
adjustments necess necessitate a new
prescription which can start the whole
approval process again there are a few
things I ask the committee to keep in
mind when considering the legislation
Studies have shown that enabling
licensed cancer Health Care
Professionals to dispense a longer-term
supply of non-controlled oral
anti-cancer drugs above and beyond what
is currently authorized will optimize a
patient's adherence to their treatments
increase doctor's ability to personalize
Cancer Treatments to best address
patient needs and streamline the order
process for drugs needed for treatment
research has showed that patients serve
through direct dispensing model have a
95% medical adherence rate versus 70%
when prescriptions are dispensed in
other instances this ultimately leads to
better outcomes our facility has a
licensed pharmacist on staff who that
will uh work in consultation with a full
Medical Care team to dispense the
medications um our patients are
carefully and nearly continuously
monitored not only to develop a better
understanding of their individualized
needs and unique experiences but to
ensure their safety if there are any
issues or changes in their status we
have the ability to quickly change the
course of treatment including the doses
of their prescriptions there have been
numerous studies that have showed that
in that medically integrated dispensing
reduces the cost to patients into the
Healthcare System
overall I also want to make the
committee aware that we have continued
to engage in dialogue with various
stakeholders regarding Amendment
language that seeks to clarify the
legislation after hearing concerns from
the in the initial public hearing we're
committed to continuing those
discussions over the course of the next
few weeks to make a stronger piece of
legislation I'd like to thank you for
this opportunity to speak before you
today and we'll be happy to take any
questions thank you Doctor any questions
representa
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and pardon my
ignorance but I'm I'm not in the medical
field so what I want to understand is
the current state the limitations on the
current state and why they exist so is
it that you can't distribute things that
require mixing is that the limit ation
is on the quantity that you can dispense
so what are those current limitations
and to the best of your knowledge can
you maybe talk to why they exist and why
you think that this is okay thank
you I'm happy to thank you for the
question so there there are really two
main types of cancer treatments that are
given or two main categories one are
intravenous treatments infusions and the
other are these oral
medicines we give the intravenous
treatments to our patients in our
infusion center we've done this for many
many
years um with following the national
guidelines for or national regulations
for our Pharmacy for safety for there
are many many
um Quality programs that our National
Society ASCO um and others um have
developed that we follow as well so
we've been doing this for many many
years mixing those medicines and giving
them to patients in the office oral
medications are the ones that we're
concerned with here which have been have
developed over time and have in either
um supplemented or replace some of those
intravenous medicines so for those
prescriptions now I will I will make um
create a treatment plan I will will work
out the doses for a med for a
prescription we have to go through a
pre-authorization process and those
prescriptions now go to Specialty
pharmacies almost exclusively out of
state
um those um prescriptions then get sent
back to the patient at their house and
they are and um they take them with our
supervision so we have our pharmacist um
our nurses working together with the
patients to make sure they're getting
the right dose and that they're taking
it in a safe way what we cannot do or
what is not clear that we can do uh
through the regulations of the Board of
Pharmacy is distribute some of those
medicines ourselves to the patients and
the among the many reasons that that is
is important often these medicines get
adjusted the doses get adjusted I'll see
a patient after a couple weeks of
treatment find that they have side
effects maybe their blood counts are low
will want to reduce the dose and if the
prescriptions are being sent to them
from a from a um from a mailaway
pharmacy a specialty pharmacy it's very
hard to get those changes Incorporated
in time to start their next cycle of
treatment which might be a couple days
after I see them so we have to sort of
work to um either delay the treatment
and get the right prescription in or
sort of Jerry rig their prescription a
little bit so they get the right amount
whereas if we were able to give the
prescriptions directly to the patients
through our Pharmacy and the office we
could do that and get them on the right
dose right at the right time but right
now there it's not clear with the
regulations in the pharmacy regulations
are the it's broader than that in the
state of New Hampshire that we can give
those prescriptions to patients
follow up so I understand you know you
want to be able to make adjustments in
more real time that makes sense to me I
understand that but what is what what's
your original thinking why why can't you
do that why was it put in place
initially that that was something that
you couldn't do was there a reason or
was that was just just organically it
happened that way but there there must
be a reason why currently you can't do
it well and I I don't want to get
outside inside my Lane as they say but
um I believe that the reason is that it
was not anticipated that this was going
to happen so the the
regulations the the regulations that are
in place didn't anticipate this class of
drugs being developed and the somewhat
unique circumstances that in oncology
that that have evolved over time so the
and and it isn't so much that that again
that that it is clear that we cannot do
it it's just that it isn't clear that we
can do it and um when we asked the Board
of Pharmacy to clarify that they felt
like they couldn't do it they they
couldn't give us that Clarity and it's
this is very relevant because it's
because of the safety um
requirements of how this Pharmacy would
be run in our office it's it is a very
significant um outlay of of resources in
order to to put that in place so we need
Clarity to know that we can do that and
that we're going to be following the
regulations of the State of New
Hampshire and that that won't be you
know two years from now it won't be sort
of someone someone might have a
different interpretation and I would
note that um as was as was um was the
point that was made when when the bill
during the introduction this is a very
common practice not only um are is it
allowed in the state of Maine and the
state of Vermont in the state of
Massachusetts and New York but I'd also
say that that the that needing to go and
create an exemption like we have have
discussed here is is also something that
was needed in many of those States
because of the fact that it was not that
it was not obvious when the or when that
how these things would evolve over time
so there are there are very analogous
exemptions that were were created in
those other states because of this this
same
process representative
Weber thank you
what I think I'm not understanding is
you're talking about establishing a
pharmacy within your
practice and do is the issue that that
is not staffed by a pharmacist and that
it's other people who are doing the
dispensing that are not registered
pharmacists that you need this well the
the the issue with again I don't want to
overstep my um knowledge and
understanding but I think the issue is
that the regulation says that a
physician office can dispense up to a
certain amount of medicine for an
immediate need but it is not clear what
that is and and whether we what the
limits are and I would just make a
little note that we have a pharmacy in
our office so we have a pharmacy that
that prepares and um helps the
administration of of the infusional
treatments that are given which frankly
are much more complicated than what
we're talking about with this because
they need to be mixed and and you know
there's there's a whole another layer of
complexity to it we have that we've been
doing that um um sort of in um
accordance with the with the the
regulations of the Board of Pharmacy for
decades but what we don't have is the is
the um the the um clear approval that we
could do this with the with the uh oral
medications so representative Leon and
then representative Shapiro um thank you
Mr chairman and thank you so much doctor
for being here and taking time out of
your busy day taking care of patients um
so as I'm understanding this you are
able to do all of this with these IV
cancer drugs um people in other states
and questionably you if we were to give
it clear would be able to do it with the
cancer pills too and you have a
pharmacist who's part of this but um is
if um so the idea of not getting just
going through and doing a regular
pharmacy license is is that a lot
because in your office you have a
pharmacist but there may be a day or two
that they're not there and so being able
to immediately dispense this and give
these cancer pills to a do a patient
that you could give a cancer IV to um
being able to do this without needing to
have a pharmacy with a pharmacist always
on staff because you have a pharmacist
who is but isn't always present is that
why it's so important to make sure that
oncology practices are protected in our
law and in our rules for how you can
dispense these medications and just
continue providing the same care you've
been providing all along yes exactly
that's the point you make is is is one
of the critical issues for us that that
um we're not a hospital and and the so
there are several different classes of
of licenses that are available you know
for pharmacies one is an Institutional
license which which covers hospitals
like conquered hospital or Dartmouth
Hitchcock or whichever though they the
they are much more complicated
organizations than our independent
practice so the they there's many
different layers of regulations for them
there's many different types of
reimbursement for them which is very
different than what we get which is part
of why it's more costeffective to do
this through offices like ours as an
aside but because of that we don't have
um four pharmacists on employed we have
one pharmacist that's employed by our
practice for uh you know that
oversees um our treatments that we give
intravenously and also watches also
oversees these treatments that we're
giving now through these other
pharmacies um if she's on vacation like
she is this week for school vacation
week then all of a sudden our treatments
would grind to as to a halt so we that's
why we need a little more flexibility I
would say than than some of the other
than those than those other class so
there's the institutional and then
there's as I understand it there's the
commercial retail license and we we
don't really meet either of those so
that's that's always been part of the
discussion with the Board of Pharmacy
followup followup um so as a followup in
order to protect independent oncology
practice and the ability to do that in
New Hampshire now that we're moving from
IV drugs to these to the oral drugs does
that mean that in order to make sure
that we can still have independent
oncologists we need to make sure there's
a way for you to do this without
building out a huge Pharmacy within your
practice or having to completely
Outsource it yes thank you
representative
chero thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking this question what what
implications if any would there be for
um Financial reimbursement for these
medications if you changed the way you
did this or for the patient's
responsibility for you financial
responsibility for these medications
would there be any changes for the
patient the short answer is no um the
the um the there there would not be more
responsibility on the part of the
patients in the in the with these uh if
we were to do this this way it gets a
little bit complicated when you're
talking about all the other layers of of
um you know the um of insurance and and
how everything passes through through
but but I would say more broadly that
practices like ours because they because
we're not hospitals because we don't
have the other layers of regulations we
are reimbursed at a lower rate than than
um the same care would be in a given in
a different setting and uh because of
that that's that is why generally
speaking when when treatments are given
through a practice like ours that's
given at a it's at a much lower cost
setting um representative Merchant then
representative
not I'll defer to
representative thank you Mr chairman um
So currently you're allowed to give a
30-day prescription but not 60 no well
or you're not allowed at all right now
we're not allowed to do it's we're not
allowed to do it at all or it's not
clear that we can do it at all okay
thank you very much representative
Merchant thank you Dr Crow for being
here taking my question in regards to
dispensing versus administration of
drugs if I understand and follow the
logic here currently when something's
administered to the patient in the
office how is that build out on the
medical side or the pharmacy benefit
side so again I don't want to overstep
my uh my understanding of these things
the uh and despite the fact that we run
an independent practice and I'm oversee
all all of that I I my my knowledge of
the detail of of those of the billing
process is is not what it should be um
the uh I I probably shouldn't say
anything because I don't want to I don't
want to say something that's that's
that's ill-informed and and might be
misleading because I think it's what I'm
trying to get to is that when you get to
the dispensing toally 30 60 days of
dispensing that's normally done on the
pharmacy benefit side so I'm going to be
sure that if this is going forward that
the facility has the ability to use the
patients Pharmacy benefit that they are
using and not have them tied up into a
quandry between is it the medical side
or is the pharmacy side because it's
pretty clear when it comes to the
dispensing that goes through the
pharmacy benefit side so are we talking
about the pharmacy benefit side that's
what I'm trying to get
to and again I I can't answer your
that that should be an easy answer for
us to get for you I just I just don't
want to give you the wrong one thank you
would follow please follow up and also I
understand that the New England um
oncology group has a pharmacy license
today so we actually have um a member
from the the the New England cancer
specialist here with us today who who I
don't want to speak for them but I know
support this bill they have a license
with their practice in Portsmith I I
believe from my conversations with them
that that came about from the the
license was um predated their
involvement in that office and I think
it's through the the hospital there
through HCA rather than being for their
practice you may know better than me no
it I'll let them speak to it thank you
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
also signed up to speak of Peg Clifford
and Rob Barry from the Department of
Services
timing good morning still morning uh Mr
chairman members of the committee uh my
name is Rob Barry I'm general counsil of
the division of Medicaid uh with me is
Peg Clifford she's the Medicaid Pharmacy
director um although we believe this
bill is well intentioned we are here in
opposition to the bill today uh our
Focus though is primarily on the length
of time or the length of um the
prescription um our understanding and
our experience is that uh cancer
patients um sometimes have a difficult
time tolerating the um the oral
anti-cancer uh medication uh we're
concerned that the dispensing of up to a
60-day supply could lead to waste and
therefore extra costs and in some cases
drug shortages which I understand is um
an issue that uh is creeping up at this
point in time uh so our suggestion would
be to move the 60 days down to 30 days
um and at that point we could um
withdraw our opposition to the bill and
with that I'll pass it to Peg if she has
anything else to add yeah I just say
that typically Medicaid allows for a
30-day supply of medications we do have
exceptions for uh maintenance
medications which are typically for
chronic conditions once the patient is
stable on a dose and we consider that
120 days then we would allow up to a
90-day Supply but that doesn't really
drugs thank you
and we're happy to take questions sure
okay any
questions uh representative merant
follow up on the question I had to Dr
crow in regards to Medicaid how would
the billing occur is it going to go
through on the pharmacy side on the
medical side how would that how would
Medicaid handle that uh it would depend
how the claim came through whether they
build it on a medical or a pharmacy
claim we would we would pay it either
way the uh reimbursement would be the
cost followup so in order to accomplish
that there have to be some sort of
software within the practice in order to
accommodate the billing I mean because
what I'm trying to get to is on the
pharmacy side it's NDC numbers they
almost J codes I'm getting some of
detail here but I'm trying to be sure
that the patient doesn't get caught in
the middle between the medical side and
the pharmacy side and they don't
understand it yeah I believe we do still
accept paper claims so somebody could
submit a a paper Pharmacy claim but it
probably would be easier for the
practice if they don't have pharmacy
software to and I don't know whether
they do or don't um but you know a
medical claim could come through under a
miscellaneous code and then um the NDC
included on the claim and the quantity
dispensed and we would price it that
way representative Shapero thank you Mr
chairman are your concerns about the
number of days
um more about waste and cost or are they
also about
safety it it's more about what Medicaid
pays for so like I said we typically pay
for 30-day Supply and if we're being
asked to pay for a 60-day supply it's
it's not they're they're not routine
maintenance medications and if there is
dose changes and dose adjustment then it
does lead to um to waste which is a
concern for us as well followup so it's
really about following the standards
that are already in place for Medicaid
yeah and and for what we allow for a
claim to come through as thank you
representative
n would you believe I have a family
member in a clinical trial that takes
oral um cancer medication who has since
moved out of state and lives about 7
hours away from here and she's able to
come every 3 months for her checkups and
gets her pile of medicine so I'm just
thinking on the side of the patients
that um the 60-day supply could save
them another trip and it's not anyway
would you
believe other question yes we
believe say no other questions okay
also signed up to speak is Steven well
from New England Cancer
sir morning everyone thank you for the
opportunity to speak today so my name is
Steven rol I'm the director of Pharmacy
operations for New England Cancer
Specialists uh we have three practices
in Maine and one in Portsmith New
Hampshire within our practices in Maine
um we operate a medically integrated
dispensing Pharmacy out of our scarbo
location where we fill oral anti-cancer
medications for the residents of Maine
uh we do not currently fill oral
anti-cancer medications for the patients
in New Hampshire um but to clarify we do
have an instate pharmacy license
um at our Portsmith location uh but we
are only administering injectable
medications at that site uh at the
present
time so I just wanted to share my
thoughts um regarding medically
integrated dispensing pharmacies and the
benefits that it has to patients and as
a quick background prior to joining New
England Cancer Specialists um I was a
health system based pharmacist in the
state of Maine for 12 years um at that
time and to be totally honest um my
viewpoint was very limited and blinded
to the way that traditional Pharmacy
Works uh when I joined New England
Cancer Specialists um it quickly
recognized the benefits for which a
medically integrated dispensing Pharmacy
or in-office physician dispensing
provides to our patients to the points
that Dr Crow
mentioned um we are able to get get
medications in the hands of our patients
exceptionally faster than what a
specialty pharmacy would be able to do
uh we are oftentimes able to get a
medication in a patient's hands within
24 hours of that medication being
prescribed where these larger male order
specialty pharmacies were often waiting
upwards of 7 to 14 days for these
medications um to arrive in a patient's
hands so as you can imagine from timely
access to starting therapy that is
critical uh for our patients and then
furthermore from a multidisiplinary
standpoint having Physicians nurses
pharmacists all within an in-office
setting managing the care of these
patients with their oral anti-cancer
medications um drastically elevates the
level of care that we're providing um
when you are working with a mail order
Specialty Pharmacy um you are not
getting uh intimate you know Hands-On
care um that you would receive um at a
oncology practice that is allowed to
dispense oral anti-cancer medications so
between the pharmacists the nurses and
the providers um we are able to counsel
our patients especially as um
adjustments and doses are made um if
patients experiencing any side effects
or toxicities were able to quickly
manage it at that point as well um I
could keep going on regarding this but
one thing I did want to clarify
regarding um the medical versus
prescription benefit if that's okay um
so the oral anti-cancer medications
would be build through the prescription
benefit for the patient's Insurance
versus the injectable medications are
going through the patients medical
benefit so for Medicare as an example
Medicare Part B would be your injectable
side Medicare Part D would your oral
anti-cancer
medications questions representative
Weber and then representative
Shapiro thank you and thank you for that
last explanation which helps a lot
um uh my question is with
the the one raised by the department
about the concern about the
duration and um I understand Dr Crow's
point about and and yours as well about
sometimes you find out within a week
that somebody is not reacting well and
needs something else you don't want to
waste a 60-day
supply uh so this seems more sensible on
that end the concern about the the
dispensing for a longer period of
time am I not correct in thinking I mean
from my own experience that
either insurance or Medicare or Medicaid
whoever is doing the paying is a
separate question and that is an issue
of what the covering entity will will
cover and the the amount that they will
cover um and that varies very much yes
by that
entity but it doesn't have a great deal
to
do with the efficiency
so what I'm asking is do you see any
risks to leaving the time frame longer
or do you see any benefits to leaving
the time frame longer I see the benefits
for a short time but not I want your
thoughts on the longer time frame yeah
in my opinion I have no concerns with
allowing a 60-day or even 90day supply
of these medications so And to
clarify um to your point the
prescription benefit for the patient so
through their insurance is oftentimes
going to dictate whether you're even
allowed to dispense more than a 30-day
Supply and for several of these uh oral
anti-cancer medications you are not
allowed to dispense more than 30 day at
a time uh there's a number of
medications I could list uh where we're
not allowed to do that that being said
if you have a patient who is stable on
therapy um coming into the practice May
maybe every 3 months for their checkups
um dispensing a 3mon supply of that
medication again if they are clinically
stable tolerating their medications
there is benefit to that prevents the
patient from having to come back into
the practice or to receive their
medication from on a monthly basis from
a specialty pharmacy so I do think there
are benefits of having that as an option
but again I think from a clinical
perspective no one's going to do that
unless the patient is stable and
tolerating their
medication
followup just because you mentioned the
90day supply um are you comfortable with
the bill as it's written at 60 days
because the bill is written at 60 days
yeah I mean I I don't want to speak for
um just for
yourself yes I'm comfortable with 60
days yes I mean would I also be
comfortable with 90 days yes I would but
I think again most clinicians when
they're prescribing these medications
are not going to jump out at a 90-day
supply of the medication you need to
make sure your patient is clinically
stable on the therapy before you Branch
out thank you very much representative
Shapero and then representative Lon
thank you Mr chairman and this is a
follow-up question on the last question
so just to be so I can be more clear if
this bill passed with the language of 60
days um and you were providing
medication in office for some who had
New Hampshire
Medicaid um even though this bill allows
you to do it for 60 days wouldn't you
still only be allowed be reimbursed for
a 30-day
Supply it depends right so it depends on
the insurance and the structure but what
follow up follow I'm talking about I'm
talking about New Hampshire Medicaid I
mean regardless of what this bill does
wouldn't you still have to terms of
being reimbursed wouldn't you still be
under the aices of what New Hampshire
the way New Hampshire Medicaid
reimburses as the way it I can relate
this to how it works in the state of
Maine in that yes we would be restricted
and we'd only be reimbursed for whatever
the insurance or Medicaid allows you to
be reimbursed for so essentially it
wouldn't change any any they wouldn't
have to change their policy because we
passed this
law in Maine the way it's structured now
no okay thank you representative Lon and
then representative McLean uh thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for bringing
this knowledge I greatly appreciate it
um so you've had experience as a
hospital system pharmacist now you're in
a more um a more of an independent role
sort of a community community- based
oncologist and my understanding is
oncology move from these centers of
excellence to having these these these
Technologies and these treatments that
can really move to the community and are
sort of on on goinging um maintenance
ones because there's a lot more people
living with cancer um not just fighting
that end stage um so my first question
is because uh when you're able to do
that in office dispensing in Maine are
you finding that in this Community
Practice you're able to follow up on
signals like um side effects somebody
who's having fevers having rashes one of
these indications that the therapy would
need to change faster than you would if
somebody was going through a specialty
pharmacy yes
um and that's due to our current
structure um that we have in place at
New England cancer specialist so we have
a dedicated what we call an oral
adherence program uh where 7 days after
initiating therapy uh we are contacting
every single patient for our oral
anti-cancer medications um to ensure
that um they know what the medication is
how they're taking it uh frequency for
which they're taking it and we're
assessing any side effects and um a
distress scale on every essentially It's
weekly times four after initiating a
therapy and then it goes out to monthly
thereafter um and so that's a
collaborative effort between pharmacists
um nurses um and provider visits that we
have and so we have a very Hands-On
approach with these patients and
Incredibly Close monitoring okay follow
up follow up um so it's great to hear
that this actually increases patient
safety and probably patient outcomes by
catching those early um my second
question is because there's so many
different payers and you have employers
who are self who have their own orisa
programs the idea of opening it up so if
you have an employee who's um who is
taking basically chronic chronic uh
they're taking this on a stable basis in
order to combat their cancer and keep it
at Bay giving the ability to have 60
days or 90 days is something that
provides that flexibility for those
patients that it's appropriate for even
though you wouldn't be even though
obviously New Hampshire Medicaid
wouldn't be taking advantage of so it
has a benefit even if it doesn't help
everybody would that be correct yes I
think so thank you representative
McLean thank you Mr chair um so you
mentioned that there are patients that
are are stabilized and they're going to
go on to a maintenance mode um so in my
wife's case you know the the drugs have
changed that hey you need to get a
90-day Supply and if you don't get a
90-day Supply we're not going to pay um
and so
so that L that landscape's been changing
on us recently so um do you see a
problem with that where may be a benefit
towards going to the 90 days or you feel
the 60 days is fine I don't mean to beat
the 60 90 30 days to death but yeah I
think due to the um so as many of you
may or may not know these medications
tend to be incredibly expensive um you
know there's some therapies that can be
upwards of $20,000 a month uh for their
prescription prescription cost so most
insurance companies aren't looking to
mandate 90day supplies um there you know
usually it's more on the we're only
going to allow 30 um and there are a few
that at least that we currently fill for
now that are on the less expensive side
that the insurance companies will allow
us to extend out and so um I have not
personally experienced the situation in
which an insurance is mandated
um
yeah I representative palaza thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question do you have any numbers on um
share of your patients uh those who are
on Medicaid those who are on other
insurances so um I can't share any
information about Medicaid because um in
the state of Maine we actually do not
fill prescriptions for patients with
Medicaid and that's
um because we are not a licensed Retail
Pharmacy in the state of Maine so we do
not fill um Medicaid prescriptions in
the state we are allowed to fill for um
Medicare Advantage um Medicare Part D um
and then depending on the commercial
insurance plan Commercial Insurance is
typically the the program or the groups
that will mandate these mail orderer
specialty pharmacies whereas Medicare
being more of an open
market other question
questions representative Merchant thank
you one of the things I've looked at
around the country is that the issue of
Physicians dispensing so if you have a
full-time pharmacist working for you now
which is I want to commend you because
when I look at a lot of times medication
errors in Studies have shown that
significant part of that is prescribing
which is caught by the pharmacist it's a
second set of eyes frankly and and
working in a Cancer Center um we always
had two sets of eyes on everything we
did because Cancer drugs are very toxic
and you don't have room for
error what's the reason or why we
couldn't have an in-house Pharmacy so
you could build Medicaid you could build
everybody else it's right there it's
staffed by your staff there it's not
open to the public I think it's kind of
the concern we had before with the board
was the way the laws written it had to
sort of be retail you know looking for
retail you're looking for your own
patients so what's the downside then of
having an in pharmacy license or permit
by the board so you can do all these
wonderful
things yeah I mean I I I don't want I'm
not sure I'm knowledgeable enough in all
of the New Hampshire laws right now to
like confidently say like or would there
be more restrictions in place if you
were um licensed and would there be
Staffing requirements as far as number
of Pharmacists in place or number of
technicians in place um so I'm not sure
I'm in a good position to answer that
but what I can comment on um you know at
New England cancer specialist we do have
pharmacists um that are are involved in
this process and we have pharmacy tech
technicians that are involved in this
process as well and I was admittedly
skeptical right of physician dispensing
when I used to work in the health system
world but what I've quickly recognized U
working in this environment is that our
practice is just as safe if not safer
because we have more touch points with
our patients and because of the
infrastructure that we have in place at
New England Cancer Specialists um right
now so we have a pharmacist again um you
know readily involved in this process um
and we do have two sets of eyes on all
of our prescriptions before they're
dispensed so I guess the question trying
to understand is that if you have a
pharmacy permit there's no restrictions
there's no 30day 60-day 90 you can do
control drugs you can do anti Medics you
can do all kind you don't have any
limitations on oncology then we get into
the disc discussion what is an analytic
it gets into the terminology why not
have the board work with you folks and
saying you have a permit and then work
with the board through rulemaking to
exactly what it is that you're trying to
accomplish and stay within the confines
of what we have today to allow for that
and as Leon talked about the other day
if you have have a time in which there's
not a pharmacist available for whatever
reason the Physicians still on the short
term could fill in for the pharmacist
that have
Point yeah I mean I think so in our
circumstance right at New England cancer
specialist we have an instate pharmacy
license so my understanding is that with
our current situation we could dispense
right we are not doing that now um and
but to your point I mean I think I would
you know ultimately defer to NH o um and
engage in discussions with them um but I
think it comes down to what is the
language within that specific Pharmacy
permit um how restrictive would that
Pharmacy permit be to your I think you
mentioned like if it allows a physician
um or another licensed professional to
be involved in that process if a
pharmacist isn't present then in my
personal opinion then I'd be more open
to that but um yeah I'll leave it at
that so basic if understanding correctly
is that if we had something like that it
would be up to the you working with the
Board of Pharmacy like we did with back
in the days with compounding versus um
product preparation we worked with the
board work through the process and it
worked very well okay yeah I'm not
familiar with the any historical pieces
here
so okay uh just to point out we are
behind schedule and we'll continue with
this hearing and my thought is we'll
just continue um right along and people
can go to lunch as they as they wish at
their convenience rather than make the
extend the day representative ever do
you have any concern or oh I have many
concerns but I don't see what else we
can do about them okay okay sorry uh any
other questions for this gentleman
before he
sir also signed up to speak is Tanya
I don't want to second guess what those
initials stand for so I'll let you tell
minutes can you push the button so the
red comes up there you go thank
you so I think it's good afternoon now
so good afternoon chairman McDonald and
members of the committee my name is
Tanya Carlton I've been a practicing
pharmacist in New Hampshire across
multiple Health Care Systems for over 20
years uh currently I serving as the
president of the New Hampshire Society
of Health System Pharmacists and I'm
here to testify for
nhsp um in opposition um to SB 458 in
its current state and as I said I'm
really going to keep it short and sweet
so um basically speaking to what
representative Merchant was talking
about is really why can't New Hampshire
oncology and hematology why can't these
cancer set centers um simply request a
pharmacy license share so how can we fix
the legislation to ensure that they're
able to request a license to be able to
dis dispense these medications according
to other regulations that dispensing
pharmacies are held to the other
question is a 60-day supply they were
looking to bridge the gap originally is
what we heard from the provider um so 60
days seems a little extensive if you're
looking for an emergency supply and
really what that is is so uh originally
it was 90 it went down to 60 so if
you're trying to bridge until the
Specialty Pharmacy can fill the
medication it may be more reasonable to
to keep the supply to less than 30 days
um for medication you know waste
purposes and then um the last pharmacist
spoke about the medically integrated
dispensing Pharmacy and according to an
ncoda which is a Grassroots not
for-profit organization committed to
developing unique resources to help
medically integrated oncology teams
deliver top care and MIP is a dispensing
Pharmacy within an oncology center of
excellence that promotes patient
centered multi-disciplinary team
approach so really what we're talking
about is dispensing
pharmacy at these practices so how can
we ensure that they are able to be
registered as a pharmacy so that they
can bill the pharmacy
prescription benefit
um so how do we ensure that they can do
that thank you thank
you representative
Weber so here's my question and you may
not be the right person to answer it but
um you have some of the specialized
knowledge on the one hand um we are
hearing
from the
practices that they would like to have
their own
pharmacies we are hearing that they have
talked to the Board of Pharmacy and the
Board of Pharmacy does not believe they
have the authorization to approve the
kinds of licenses that would be helpful
to the
practices and you're saying that you
oppose this
legislation so my question is how do we
how in your opinion if you have one and
if this is an inappropriate question for
you I'll that's fine just say so um how
do we bridge that Gap because um it
seems to me like we're beginning to get
ourselves into an endless loop where
everybody is referring things to the
next person and it's not going anywhere
yet I bring up Gary Merchant
representative Gary
Merchant okay to he can answer this
question but there there is an
opportunity for an amendment where we
can um change the rsas for the Board of
Pharmacy to ensure that we have a clinic
dispensing Pharmacy category um for
providers that would meet the needs of
not just oncology providers but other
providers that would be looking to
dispense medications out of their
clinics so I believe that would be an
okay all right I guess we're all set
thank
you also signed up to speak is Heidi CR
plans you asked uh three to four minutes
better good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee um for the
record my name is Heidi croll I work at
Gallagher cahan andar trell um I'm
representing ahip which is America's
health insurance plans and I will um yes
I will do my best to keep this very
short um because a lot of what I have to
say has already been said um so we are
um technically opposed uh to sp sp 458
as amended by the Senate but I will say
that you know we have had a number of
conversations um discussions um
correspondence with the Bill's Advocates
um and we are very willing to um
continue those discussions and work on
amendments so um and we have two areas
of concern or interest with the bill um
which other speakers have raised as well
um one is the 60-day supply um we think
that is uh too long for what's being
contemplated in the legislation um and
as you've heard um these supplies of
prescription drugs are typically meant
for treating chronic diseases where the
patient's condition is stable um they've
had experience being on the drug and
it's clear that the drug is working for
them um and they're not likely to have
to change treatments um and so so in
those cases a longer term um
prescription makes sense from both a
care and cost perspective um but a a
60-day supply is typically not um uh is
not what you would typically think of as
necessary um to meet the immediate
medical needs and that's the terminology
that in the law currently where they're
trying to place this um the immediate
medical needs of the patient um and it's
you know as you've heard also not what
you would typically think of when
treating a cancer patients um whose
treatments can be subject to change
depending on their condition um and as
you've heard um these drugs are often
considered to be specialty drugs um due
to their cost and due to their potential
changes in the patient condition um
prescribing even a 60-day supply could
lead to waste of the drug um and a waste
of money which so we would share what
you heard from the Department um of
Health and Human Services on that point
um and then our other set of uh
questions or concerns falls into um
again this question of whether um or not
there would be the intention of having
an in-house Pharmacy um that would be in
network um and you know our
understanding and I think it's been
confirmed by the discussion here today
is that these oral anti-cancer drugs
would be self- administered by the
patient at home so they're not um
physician administered in a health care
facility like the intervenous um
medications are and um provide ERS um at
least for um commercial insurance so I
represent plans that offer um fully
insured plans um providers cannot buy
and Bill for outpatient drugs in the
same way that they can for physician
administer drugs um in a health care
facility um so self-administered drugs
do need to be dispensed by an outpatient
pharmacy that's in network or through a
provider's facility based Pharmacy
that's in network um and um if these are
specialty drugs which very often they
are many carriers do require that they
are filled through an in network
Specialty Pharmacy um and in those cases
typically they are limited um to a
30-day Supply or less um so I'll leave
it at that I'm happy to try to answer
any questions and again as I indicated
we're happy to work with any
stakeholders and we have been you know
being kept in the loop and so happy to
work on future uh amendments thank you
representative
Weber so having listened to the
testimony we've heard so
far um you're testifying that it needs
to be a local in network
Pharmacy and what we've heard for
Testimony is those pharmacies do not
dispense these
medications and
outside so what I'm what I'm not
understanding is why are you objecting
to bringing the work
inhouse when you still as the pharmacy
benefits
providers have the ability to dictate
how much is
dispensed either through prior
authorization or through medication
limits or anything else why does it
matter that they're allowed to do the
dispensing
because that seems to me to be a health
care quality of care issue and I'm not
sure why you're objecting to it if you
can control it so so to be clear we're
not objecting to it we we either use
in-house facility pharmacies or
specialty pharmacies for these types of
drugs so as long as there's some sort of
inhouse or INF facility um pharmacy
license that that's not a problem for us
so if I if I said the word local I I did
not that was so just just just to
clarify for me because I'm now
thoroughly confused because I thought
you said you were objecting to the bill
on two grounds one being that 60 days
was too long and the other
being uh it sounded to me like you were
objecting to the use of
inhouse we are not it's just that it's
just that the legislation is not clear
that there is going to be an in-house
license for this purpose okay yes gotcha
thank you so sorry for that
misunderstanding yep any other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is
Merchant remember three minutes
representative
good afternoon Mr chairman also
committee's members um for the record my
name is Gary Merchant representative s
County clar mon
Troon I fully support the integrated
model we used it many times at the
medical center but the model was based
upon the fact that we had a pharmacy as
well as we had the the clinic so we had
things that were infused to the patient
but we at the same time had in-house
Pharmacy I think what it comes down to
is the fact there's confusion in the law
which I totally understand because the
way the law is written is more towards a
retail pharmacy open to the public we
don't want this open to the public we
want it for their own patients Virginia
South Carolina North Carolina uh Florida
North Dakota all have what they call
in-house Pharmacy licenses they work
very effectively so what we're trying to
do with the with the law and I can bring
an amendment to this is be sure the
board has the statutory authority to
issue a permit you want to call it a
mini Pharmacy avoiding a lot of the
heavy regulations that are placed upon
retail pharmacies because that's not
what this is and I think going forward
is allowing the patient the
opportunity to have the same service
levels they would have anywhere else if
the insurance companies need to call out
a specialty pharmacy then so be it they
can apply as a specialty pharmacy and
become
um working with the insurance companies
with the manufacturers that way so I
think it's really a blend between a
pharmacy internally that's not open to
the public that but the board right now
it's confusing there in the statute
itself it's not clear so by making it
clear that the Board of Pharmacy can
issue a permit and then based upon how
the permit wants to be utilized let the
board make the rules and regulations
around it work with the stakeholders
through Ru making to be sure we can
accommodate all the needs my fundamental
concern is that when you're dealing
with the process and you're dealing with
what's in the states is anotic drugs
well patients also need to take antia
drugs they need to take things that are
not entics because they're part of
adjunctive therapy so if they're going
to have to go down to the pharmacy to
get those drugs to begin with why they
not getting the other drugs at the same
time so by having an in-house Pharmacy
all those things can be taken care of at
One-Stop shop for the patient convenient
for the patient it follows the same
Norms we have now with the insurance
regulations as far as the reimbursement
so that's my request to the board when
testifying I have testimonial submit to
the committee that I submitt it to the
Senate as
well thank you representative Merchant
any questions for representative
Merchant seeing that was easy that was
easy okay no one else has signed up to
speak on Senate Bill 458 do anyone else
wish to uh
testify seeing no one uh I did get the
blue sheet in the back and three people
did sign up one in favor and two
opposed so with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate Bill
458 and I am going to open the public
hearing on Senate Bill 560
and Senator shandley has been sitting
there very patiently thank you Senator
and sorry to keep you waiting uh she is
the prime sponsor of U Senate Bill 560
so welcome thank you very much Mr chair
and good afternoon to you and the other
members of the committee um my name is
Shannon chandley I serve the people of
District 11 in the state senate and uh I
come before you today to introduce
Senate Bill 560 I hope that uh I will
help to bring you back into your
schedule and on time um because I'm
hoping that this will be a relatively um
brief uh discussion on my part and
presentation on my part and I I think
it's it's a very straightforward bill it
is a study committee Bill not something
that all of us are always excited about
but I think the topic is extraordinarily
important and deserves to be considered
by a committee of legislators who can
then be Nimble in recommending any kinds
of changes that may be necessary and can
certainly understand the very
complicated issue of uh Pharmacy benefit
manager operations um I brought forward
this bill at the request of some others
including a pharmacist the history as we
know is long and
complicated um but also the current
status is evolving and equally
complicated
I think that having a study committee
made up of legislators who could um
perform the duties as expressed in this
uh bill would help us to uh draft future
legislation if necessary and understand
the effects of pbms on our communities
and help consumers and help to deliver
um Better Health Care so with that I
will take any questions but um really I
can speak to the study committee more
than I can speak to pbms at all so thank
you okay thank you any questions for
Senator chandley representative nut upam
and then representative Merchant um
thank you for taking my question Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question Senator um is it is it true
that um prescription benefit managers
their costs and charges are less
transparent than most other areas of
healthcare so without making the um
making a determination that the study
committee might want to explore that is
one of the charges to understand whether
how um whether there are in fact savings
or additional costs and how we can
better understand it thank you you're
welcome representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair and also thank you senator
for bringing this bill before the
committee um it's a difficult subject
matter it's complex
convoluted I would ask though would you
be cons willing to consider when I look
at the pharmacy supply chain we're
talking about this I'm also the chair of
the drug affordability board what we
found out is that there's the
manufacturers have a role pbms have a
role pharmacies have a role wholesalers
have a role they're all impacting the
ultimate price to the patient any
thoughts about expanding this Beyond
just looking at the pbms but looking at
from soup the nuts and saying you know
where is the transparency where are the
problems and not just try to take one
player out of the whole
group thank you for that question
representative um I think the bill as
drafted is sufficient in terms of it
would in fact be a lot of work to do
however I recognize wholeheartedly that
the bill is now in your hands you're the
committee that will deal with it and I
am um confident that any recommendation
you make would probably be uh well and
uh serveice well thank you other
questions I'm saying n oh I'm sorry
representative
Weber would you nevertheless agree that
this charge as it is already is a huge
bite for for people uh to deal with
despite the fact that they will have
help from any number of people who who
who will come and testify and and help
them with their deliberations I agree
with that entirely thank
you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
much also signed up to speak is Senator
Donna suusi welcome back Senator long
time no see thank you yes thank you
again Mr chairman I've enjoyed my
morning with the committee I'm Donna
Susi I represent Senate District 18 the
town of Lichfield and five boards in the
city of Manchester I'm a co-sponsor of
this legislation and I would not repeat
any of the points that my colleague made
I think she stated the the purpose quite
well I will say having served on other
study committees regarding
Pharmaceuticals and specifically pbms I
I do think it's time although the charge
is extensive to continue to look look at
this very complicated issue um we have I
think at each turn um that study
committees have made recommendations
discovered new information and each time
been able to work on things like prior
authorization like Supply and those
issues continue to evolve as the
availability of medical records evolves
um as different professions prescribe in
different ways um but the bottom line is
I think this work is important to
continue for consumers in the state of
New Hampshire so for those reasons Mr
chairman and the interest of time um I
would conclude my testimony and once
again be happy to take questions thank
you any questions for Senator
much also signed up to speak is Curtis
Curtis Barry from
pcma I'll let you tell us what pcma
stands for
that good morning Mr chairman morning
members of the committee good afternoon
actually I I apologize it is um my name
is Curtis Barry uh here before you today
on behalf of as the chair mentioned pcma
which stands for the pharmaceutical Care
Management Association which is the
national trade Association for the PBM
industry PBM stands for pharmacy benefit
manager um and I did not check off uh
any position on the bill on behalf of
pcma U pcma is um never been afraid of a
study committee uh in fact we take
advantage of every opportunity and
relish the opportunity to explain how
pbms save plan sponsors uh the people
who contract with PBM money in their
Pharmacy benefit program because the the
entity in my opinion that's often left
out of these discussions are the people
that pay for the premiums we hear a lot
from pharmacists particularly The
Independents um obviously the the
commercial insurers uh we hear a lot
about the patients but what gets lost in
the discussion of the people that pay
the premiums that sponsor the benefit
for the
employees uh so very briefly I've given
you two pages I'm going to discuss them
in in reverse order as Senator Susi
mentioned there have been a number of
studies regarding pbms uh in my time
representing this organization which is
longer than I can't or mention um
but frequently it's just the PBM that's
the focus of this and if you look at the
language of the study it seems to be
Pharmacy Centric and there are a number
of other entities as representative
Merchant alluded to uh that affect the
pharmacy economics and that brings me to
the first page this will give you a
visual depiction of I think what
representative Merchant was referring to
um it is more complex than traditional
medical
reimbursement and what we're discussing
if you will in the current structure of
the study committee is the right side
how the pbms relate to the insurer and
relate to um the patient and also
there's a connection to the
pharmacies what the study committee
doesn't recognize is on the left side
which is Pharma pricing it's very
complex won't go into it here and then
in the middle between the the the
manufacturer and the pharmacy are
entities known as either the wholesaler
who actually sell the physical drug to
the to the pharmacy and their pricing um
that relates to reimbursement Etc um but
also an an entity known as a psao a
pharmacy Services administrative
organization that serves many functions
I believe arily on behalf of
Independents I could be wrong about that
um but they have a role here too and in
many instances the PSA are the same
entity or there's significant ownership
overlap with the wholesaler um which
poses a unique circumstance so I would
agree with representative Merchant um
adding a few pieces to this study
shouldn't expand the workload too much
it is a heavy lift I recognize that um
but I think it's fair to the ire study
to the entire picture to add a couple of
pieces to this as well particularly on
the psao and wholesaler end um happy to
answer questions Mr chair thank you any
questions I don't see any questions I
understand it's lunchtime
well apparently maybe that's a factor
but thank you thank
you okay no one else signed up to
testify on Senate Bill 560 does anyone
else wish to testify
um let me check the blue sheet before we
okay that uh with that I'm going to
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
560 our next hearing is scheduled for 1:
p.m. on Senate Bill 400 we'll be in
time
e
bless
you
e
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs we're
going to resume our public hearing
schedule at this
time by 1:00 we have scheduled Senate
Bill 400 and U I would like to recognize
the prime sponsor of this legislation
Senator Regina berzel from District 19
thank you Mr chair for the record uh my
name is Regina burel state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of Derry Hamstead and Windham and I am
the prime sponsor and the only sponsor
for Senate Bill
400 um
currently uh what this was brought to my
attention um with the fact that uh when
you have a patient that um is requesting
a copy of their records uh their medical
records typically that uh those patients
get that when they access it directly or
ask for it directly they get they get it
for free but if something happens to
that patient and either they can't
request it or the family has you know
maybe they're in a coma and they they
can't request that information and they
get the um attain the an attorney then
that attorney if they request it then
there have been bills that I have seen
that go a, $2,000
$3,000 so what happens at the end of
that if there's a case there and at the
end of that case that patient is now
paying the invoice for that for their
own records so that's one of the reasons
for that I will take any
questions thank you there's uh others
behind me that have detailed information
on uh what's going on thank you
questions for Senator
berzel sen representative Leon can can I
just add one thing um what we've done
and let me address the bill I forgot to
do sorry um what this bill does actually
is um for electronic copies of Records
it limits the amount to
$6.50 and for paper copies the max that
$50 okay thank
you um thank you on thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Senator um thanks
for bringing this bill I know that
access to medical records um can be a
challenge for people especially if
they're not Health literate or
bureaucracy literate
um so my question would be um if you
would support um within this language
making it easier for somebody you know a
spouse um I know that if you are to make
the request where it still would go to
the patient um and it would still be
able to have that delivery because you
know you might not be able to argue that
you're doing it on behalf of the patient
if they're in a coma and they can't read
it that gets to be a little bit
different but if you have somebody who
doesn't know how to ask for their
medical record appropriately and
effectively to be able to nominate
somebody where they don't come take over
all your healthare decisions but they
can help you out in the request I I
would consider it I would also ask that
same question of some of the people
following me because they probably and I
know that there are some attorneys out
there that
actually um teach their clients how to
ask for particular information because
the bureau bu bureaucracy is so um big
that they teach them how to ask for the
information that they need and I'm sure
that they would do that with the uh
family as well thank you that's
helpful other questions representative
sharo thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for taking this question Senator um I
wonder if you've had any discussions
with experts in electronic medical
records and whether they're I I don't I
don't know enough about this but I
wonder if there are any concerns about
electronic medical records being
configured in a way that they can
be given over to patients or
representatives of patients in an
electronic fashion I have had some
conversations I'm sure you'll hear from
one coming up behind me too as well okay
thank
you other
questions saying none thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Holly Haynes
from
nhj thank you chairman McDonald and
thank you members of the committee for
allowing me to speak today my name is
Holly Haynes I'm a past president of the
New Hampshire Association for justice
I'm a resident of wear New Hampshire and
I'm an attorney in Manchester at abson
Brown and Dugan where I represent
patients who have been injured through
no fault of their own during Medical
Care
care this bill is about a patient's
right to access records at a reasonable
cost it's very simple um to address
Representatives Leon's question before I
get started um you were asking if this
bill could be amended to allow other
family members or other Advocates to
assist patients in assist in getting the
records the current Amendment the bill
does allow that it uh refers to the
patient or the patient's request door as
defined in Hippa and under Hippa that
includes a parent a guardian an advocate
a durable power of attorney a durable
power of attorney for health care so all
of those are encompassed already in the
bill and its amended form by referencing
the uh Hippa Federal
Regulation and additionally by adding
the patient request door that is when a
patient hires a lawyer to work for them
it would allow their lawyer to obtain
their medical records at the same cost
that the patient gets to receive
them I'm going to give you the a brief
background about why we think this is
needed why it's so important to patients
and to citizens in New Hampshire I'm
also going to tell you a little bit
about what you're going to hear and why
in the opposition to this bill and why
we think that those concerns are
misplaced and and finally um you're
going to hear from my partner at
Abramson Brown and Dugan Nick Abramson
and some other folks who were going to
tell you about the more practical
application and some of the bills that
we've received for patient medical
records that go into the thousands of
dollars and it's just it's unreasonable
for a patient to access their own me
information it should not cost that
much so how we got here um as I'm sure
all of you know almost all hospitals
Healthcare Systems doctors offices are
transitioning to electronic medical
records as you were referencing and I
think the goal ultimately is to get
everyone on an electronic
interoperable um format so all Health
Care Providers can access each other's
records and provide continuity of care
and provide good treatment to their
patients modeled on I think the VA
medical centers were the first system in
the nation who adopted that format and
the goal when um Hippa came out and all
of the subsequent acts was to get all
other hospitals on board with that
format so information would be easily
accessible by patients and providers in
2000 the Hippa Privacy Rule allowed
access to an individual's electronic
health record and it created or governed
the rate that could be charged for a
patient's access to that information and
it was a reasonable cost-based fee at
that time the problem is it wasn't
defined what a reasonable cost based fee
was so in 200 9 the high-tech Act was
passed and it extended the rule to allow
patients to direct their electronic
health records to a third party in
addition to accessing them themselves
and in 2016 the US Department of Health
and Human Services issued a guidance uh
memorandum explaining that the patient
rate which was limited to
$66.50 or a reasonable cost generally
it's been applied as
$615 $65 50 cents excuse me to an
electronic copy of your medical record
that that patient rate does apply to a
third party directive so from that point
forward in 2016 patients or their
attorneys or their representative or
their family member could request that
patients record and pay $66.50 for an
electronic version of the record um
copies of paper versions of the record
were charged whatever the state law
provided for the costs in 2020 um one of
the there's been an advent of thirdparty
data vendors who have come into creation
that are Contracting with hospitals to
make money and their hospitals are
Contracting out their record request to
these third-party vendors and these
third-party vendors are obviously for
profit so they want to make money one of
those vendors sco in 2020
challenged HHS guidance that the patient
rate should apply to all requesters of
medical records and the SC Court held
that Health and Human Services failed to
go through the proper administrative
procedure act channels to issue their
memorandum of guidance and so because of
that it didn't need to be followed by
the thirdparty vendors after that point
these thirdparty vendors who include sco
or share care or now I think they're all
under one umbrella called datab bant um
began
charging crazy amount for medical
records we've gotten bills for $1,000
$2,000 $4,000 for a patient's medical
records just to get those records so the
patient can find out what happened to
them during their medical
care all of these
um after the scx decision what happened
is patients were still charged $6.50 for
their medical records but anyone else
making the request for a patient or any
third party that the patient directed
the records to go to reverted back to
state law and these third party vendors
started charging a search fee a
retrieval fee plus whatever the paper
records fee was in New Hampshire it's 50
cents a page $15 for the first 30 pages
and 50 cents a page currently in our
statute which is why if you have a 2,000
page medical record it was costing
$1,000 to get that for the patient and
that's a lot for any patient in New
all of these medical records companies
thrived under the prior rules they
existed they were able to produce
records for $6.50 they will come before
you and testify today that they still
only charge patients $6.50 because that
is the cost um some of the reasons that
they oppose this bill is because they
are for profit corporations trying to
make money and they're going to tell you
that it's not as easy as a press of a
button and download onto a disk that it
costs a lot more money than that because
they have to have a person who's looking
at an authorization and a request and
they'll tell you they go Page by Page
through the medical records I submit to
you that's not the case because we get
medical records with other patients
records included all the time but um the
reason I think
that's not well-placed is because there
have been studies done that it costs
between $2 and $10 to get an electronic
copy of records and we already know all
hospitals in the state of New Hampshire
their Radiology departments if we make a
request for a patient's x-rays their CT
scans or MRIs the radiology department
does the exact same thing that these
thirdparty vendors do they look at the
request they look at the authorization
they compare the date of birth on the
patient they compare the medical record
numbers and then they download the disc
the uh all of the Imaging studies to a
dis and they provide the disc to the
patient or the attorney if you could
start wrapping up please yes everyone in
the state those Radiology images all of
whenever we make those requests cost
$10 Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center
who's the largest medical provider in
the state of New Hampshire provides
medical records for free to their
patients they don't charge anyone
because they obviously figured out the
electronic medical records process and
they want their patients to access their
information what this bill is going to
do is go back to the HHS guidance of
getting the electronic medical record
cost down to $6.50 for patients or their
requesters their family members or their
attorneys for an electronic copy and
capping the cost at $50 for a paper copy
of the record almost everyone now wants
electronic copies but obviously some
medical providers smaller providers
haven't been able to transition the way
Dart may have been able to so they do
have to provide paper records so we've
made the cap $50 for paper records and I
would submit to you that most of these
smaller entities already are only
charging $15 for their medical records
um Nick bis who owns all of the
ambulatory surgical centers or most of
many of them in the state of New
Hampshire charges $15 for any patient
record request it's a flat fee that's
what it is regardless of the format and
I would submit that probably any other
provider could do the same thing thank
you and thank you for your time I'll
take any questions that you may have
thank you representative
Weber as a followup to the initial
question from representative leyon that
you answered um I am now a little bit
confused because uh you referred to the
Hippa definition for a um requester but
it says specifically for purposes of
this section A requestor means the
patient the patient's personal
representative
an individual authorized to access the
patient's medical record through a valid
power of attorney or the patient's
attorney so that's in the definitional
section
here and my question
is
um am I right in assuming that doesn't
include parents because it doesn't say
parents and secondly
um when we say the patient's personal
represent ative are we talking
specifically about executive or
administrator of an estate or are we
talking about something else that would
include an executive an administrator
appropriately appointed by a court
followup followup it does it include
anybody else other than those uh it
would just include the definitional um
group that is listed in here but I
believe that the reference in the
paragraph preceding that the patient or
the patient's requesters shall be
entitled to such records as regulated by
the health insurance portability and
accountability act I think that adds in
whatever additional um
Representatives that are listed in Hippa
okay would you agree to with me that the
specific usually usually controls over
the broader and farther away as a matter
of statutory
construction and and and my followup
really is rather than arguing those
legalistic things my concern is making
this so broad that people access other
people's Medical Records who shouldn't
so I want to know what the protections
are there uh as as one who is more
comfortable with the specific language
and not comfortable with anything
broader even though Hippa
May approve it we have our
constitutional
amendment I would hope
I'm sorry thank you very much
representative Weber for your question I
would hope that this isn't going to
allow anyone to access anyone else's
Medical Records I think those are
protected by Hippa and the specific
definition that is in here is
exactly as it should be I would defer to
you and the wisdom of the legislature
and your colleagues with um how narrow
the request should be we just feel that
all patients and their representatives
including their lawyers if they've hired
a lawyer to work for them should be able
to access their records at a reasonable
cost thank you very much for that
representative Merchant representative
L thank you Mr
chairman I concur with what I think repr
Weber is trying to get to is that the
definition of patients personal
representative is that defined
anywhere if it is where would I find it
I believe that there is a definition in
the hip of Regulation and I'm sorry I
don't have that with me I can certainly
submit some following this to answer
that question if you'd like if if you
would please because if we're going to
refer to something in federal statute be
clear what we're referring to um I would
like to include somehow excuse me um a
definition of patient's personal
representative because I'm thinking
about it if I go in for something on
behalf of my spouse or my children or my
grandfather whatever it may be is how do
we Define
that outside of having a power of
attorney
representative well we can
it okay I'll set m i again um follow
follow please so I thank to Cal there is
a definition in the federal statute my
concern is that if that definition
changes how do we track it down should
we try to be redundant it and put it
into definition with our own state law
so with the state of law is governing it
not the federal law even though the one
and the same so if something changes
federally we're not impacting what we
have at the
state I'm not sure if I understand your
question or maybe I'm I'm not sure if I
maybe I don't have the answer to that on
how we would track the federal changes I
I hope
that we'd be able to keep track of that
as they do change it's been sometimes
concerned when we refer to something at
the federal statute that we as a state
legislative body don't have control over
it so therefore if we put the language
in our state statute if the federal
government changes their definition
we're not obligated to follow their
definition we still going to follow our
definition
okay representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and answering some hard questions um I'm
I'm not sure if you're aware that Hippa
allows state law to be more protect of
personal privacy than the federal
statutes um because of that and because
of this confusion over the language I'd
also like to sort of third the request
to help us get a specific list of
specifically what should be enumerated
in the requester just so that it can be
clear in New Hampshire law and apparent
to apparent to a wife who's trying to
help her husband to get his medical
records because he's not a good
communicator just so that somebody can
look at our law and understand what
their rights are so I'd really
appreciate just helping us clarify that
language okay thank you thank you
representative representative Seth King
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking
questions this is not a topic I have
ever thought about before um so this
could be a not a very well-informed
question but I do understand economics a
little bit and when it comes to the cost
that is borne by the healthcare
providers to pull up these these records
and give it to the the requester um
there is a cost we agree on that
absolutely and it seems some providers
have decided to just not charge like
Dartmouth some are doing a flat fee of
$15 and some are charging what as
ostensibly the full cost of providing
these records to you know to they're
charging that to the one requesting them
um do you in in your experience or do
you have any evidence to support any
idea that the companies that are
charging the requesters the full amount
are they wildly overcharging what it
actually costs the company or are they
basically just charging them what the
company is is is is what it's costing
the company and and maybe a little bit
more do you see what I'm saying here so
respectfully
I I wouldn't say that they're charging
what the cost is I would say that
they're charging charging the maximum
amount they're allowed to by Statute so
they can um make a profit because
they're for-profit corporations uh there
is absolutely a cost in this for
electronic versions of medical records
though it certainly doesn't cost 50
cents a page to produce an electronic
copy of medical records it doesn't cost
$1,000 to produce a 2,000 page medical
record I would submit respectfully that
it would be more akin to the charges
that a radiology department is incurring
when they're doing exactly the same
thing that these vendors are doing
they're looking at the record requests
they're looking at the hippoc compliant
authorization they're double-checking
all of the information to make sure they
aren't mispro anyone else's information
and then they're downloading it to a dis
followup follow up okay so um you've got
some providers like Dartmouth that are
not charging anything and others that
are doing a flat fee um assuming now
that they do have a cost that they have
to bear and they're not charging the
requestor any amount of money in order
to cover their bottom line they is
they're they're likely charging all of
the other customers that are not
requesting their their data they're
charging them to kind of make up for it
in a way does that make sense so I mean
they have to get that money from
somewhere instead of charging the person
requesting now they're just charging
everybody else a little bit more for
their bill to make up for what they have
to bear
the
cost I understand what you're saying and
um I'm sorry I'm not a medical billing
expert so I don't think I'm the
appropriate person to answer that but I
do understand where you're saying about
cost sharing but I would submit that um
the patient when they pay for their
medical visit they're paying for the
doctor's time where their insurance
company pays for their medical visit
they are paying for that record to be
created our statute even says that the
record and the information in it is the
property of the patient because they
have paid for that through their medical
visit so I would submit
that even if costs are shared that's
already incorporated into the creation
of the record itself because it has to
be by Statute that's part of part of
Medical Care is creating a record of
that care and that record is the
property of the patient okay thank you
representative kofalt and then
representative
Shapiro oh okay representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
um I think you would agree that um
someone's attorney is not entitled to
their
um to
someone's to their client's record
because they're their attorney they're
entitled to the client's record because
the client is given explicit permission
for the for the record to be released to
the attorney yes so it's not the
relationship it's the release of
information absolutely so I don't see
that mentioned in here at all um it's
there just a reference to the fact that
certain people representative and
attorney Etc are entitled to these
records now maybe this is covered under
the as regulated by the health insurance
portability portability and
accountability act um but I I don't know
that I don't know that it is explicitly
and I guess I would like to see that be
more explicit in the um language of the
legislation may maybe I'm missing this
but um do so do you do you understand
the the concern thank you representative
shiiro I think that I do and um
generally I'm not sure if I have an
appropriate answer to that but I can
certainly I'm happy to look into that
further um generally any record request
so even if the patient is requesting it
themselves they have to sign a hip a
comp authorization to the medical
provider and if an attorney was
requesting it for the patient the
patient has to sign that as well the
attorney can't just make a request and
ask for or get records follow follow up
I'm I'm I'm very well aware of that and
I I just you know hope that we're not
um un unintentionally changing that by
by wording this the way we're wording it
so and and even if it is um explicit
under the Hippa
um regulation that you mentioned here I
think it would be a good idea for that
to be explicit in the language of the
Bill thank you thank you representative
representative
Weber and I'm am I correct in thinking
that attorneys requesting a patient
records are also Bound by their own
ethical considerations which would
prohibit them from accessing for any
purpose other than what they were
specifically employed by the patient to
do absolutely thank you yes
representative
kofalt uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so I
guess following on on that last Point um
so if an attorney is
requesting patient records with the
patient's permission and if that is
let's say a malpractice suit does that
not put healthc care providers in the
unusual position of co-funding um
co-funding litigation against them
potentially um
if if if limiting if if this limit on
the cost of medical
records um applies not only to the
patient but to the patient's attorney
and if we recognize that the cost of
delivering those records um may very
well be higher than
the the amount set here in
statute it we're we're we're sort of
acknowledging that on some level the
medical providers are are funding that
um it just it's it seems um unusual to
me then that that medical providers
are are are on the hook to subsidize
litigation against them does that does
that make sense I mean it's a little bit
of a I think I understand your question
representative and thank you um I would
respect disagree because the record
itself is the property of the patient
it's not um when the patient had that
medical visit it's their property and
many times patients are requesting
medical records or attorneys are
requesting records not for malpractice
suits it might be a social security
disability suit it might be a life
insurance claim it might be I mean
there's any number of iterations that it
may be for I know your example it's a
malpractice claim and whether it would
be funding litigation but I would submit
that it's not because
the record is the property of the
patient which is why they don't charge
the patient or they only charge the
$6.50 that's already included in the
cost of their health care that they have
paid for for that
visit representative
Weber and also following up on the same
line
um I'm recalling my days when I was in
active practice of Law and there too the
records belong to the client they're
their records and they can come and get
them and take them away any day they
want it and I practiced back in the late
Stone Age where we would hand them a
file folder and admittedly medical
records are way more complex than that
now but isn't the
um an the analogy that we used back the
model that we used back then was that
the record Bel to the patient and went
with the Pati patient physically in
those days um but we kept copies for our
protection so we absorbed the cost of
the copying because we were keeping them
for our protection not not for the
patient benefit uh but here there there
are dual benefits but one one is that
the record absolutely belongs to the
patient and they could go to another
provider and ask for the records to be
sent if they are AR already available
but this is more complicated
because the Prov the patient may in some
cases want to go on being the patient of
the provider they're they're not using
them for
malpractice and so it's important to
have the copies both places is that TR
true absolutely the medical provider
would I presume always retain a copy
right the patient's just receiving a
copy of their medical record right okay
questions say no other questions thank
members also signed up to speak is Ben
Bradley from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
good afternoon Mr chairman uh thank you
for having me to be on the record on
this issue um my name is Ben Bradley I'm
the vice president of state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association we represent all the state's
hospitals and Specialty hospitals acute
care hospitals and Specialty hospitals
we do have concerns about s sp400 our
hospitals respond to medical records
request in compliance with both the
health insurance portability and
accountability act Hippa and state law
outlined in RSA
332i uh one of the tenants of HIPPA is
that every patient has the right to
review and obtain a copy of their
medical record we honor that Hippa
establishes a patient rate for medical
record requests made directly by
patients which may include patients
sending hospital records to their
primary care provider or patients
requesting run provider send their
record to another one of their providers
most of our Hospital members to provide
patients access to their medical records
for free upon request the federal
high-tech Act of 2009 updated the
federal framework under Hippa creating a
third-party directive for other parties
to initiate medical records requests
with written authorization from
Individual patients for records
transmitted to third party such as law
firms the patient rate established by
Hippa does not apply federal law is
silent on a fee structure for thirdparty
requests which is where state law
dictates the allowable cost for these
third party requests many of our
hospitals including critical access
hospitals contract with a vendor which
charges the third party request her
directly Approximately 80% of providers
nationally contract out medical record
copying services this process is Hippa
and state law compliant and frees the
hospital of managing the high volume of
requests and the overhead cost and
complexity of Performing the services
that eles if they choose if the existing
Contracting model is disrupted our
members are concerned about having to
assume the work and cost of completing
extensive medical records requests from
third parties with very little
compensation outlined in Sp sp400 that's
$66.50 as passed by the Senate without
access to a contracted vendor uh not
that they would go out of business
because they are large companies but
that they may not choose to do business
in New Hampshire or change their
business model with hospitals in New
Hampshire We Believe hospitals and
providers would be forced to take on
this work estimated to cost $1 billion
nationally on an annual basis finally
proponents of the bill question why a
plaintiff's attorneys requests for
medical records on behalf of their
client should be treated differently
than the patient requesting the record
themselves the committee should
understand that although the attorney
may be acting on behalf of the patient
in a legal case the attorney client
privilege is not recognized the same as
an appointed Guardian making Health Care
decisions on behalf of a patient one
other point I'd like to note um I think
the parties that are concerned about
with this proposal are willing to
compromise you know having a $1,200
request May certainly not be appropriate
um but maybe there is a a means for
looking into a cap that would be logical
uh for electronic copies paper copies I
think are a different scenario given
that the expense of the paper could
exceed whatever cap you end up putting
forward um happy to take questions uh
but want to reiterate our concerns for
how this bill was passed out of the
Senate thank you questions from M
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair so I
understand this correctly if I'm a
patient I go to the hospital there's no
charge patient request is governed by
Hippa
and that maximum would be $66.50 for a
patient request many of our hospitals
opt to provide that service for free if
a patient requests themselves so the so
if a patient then signs an affidavit for
somebody to do it on their
behalf it's still the patient that's not
the case and that's not how federal law
recognizes that requests additionally I
think there was an inquiry um recently
made I have some information um on uh
from um plain's attorneys about uh these
types of requests trying to clarify that
their request would be treated the same
as a patient request and it's still not
the
case so if I can follow up again follow
up please thank you it says a patient's
personal representative which is in
Hippa it's a federal that person get
charged so if I send my representative
down because I can't get there I'm going
to be charged
um that's I would have to look into that
I think your questions are legitimate
about what a patient advocate is yeah
and what how that is defined I don't
know the answer to that thank you sen
mlan and then representative Weber thank
you Mr chair so I'm just trying to get a
a feel for the scope of this what
percentage of requests that the hospital
Association gets are from the patient
and what percentage would go to a third
party because they're from a
representative or whatever thank you for
the question representative M mlan um
first I just want to clarify that the
association doesn't receive these
requests it would be our members that
that get the requests I know that was
the intent of your question just wanted
to clarify um secondly I don't have
information on the percentages of
personal requests versus trial attorney
or third party request
um but I'm happy to look into it and see
if I can provide you an answer
follow I mean that would just just to
understand the magnitude of this thing
because obviously you're saying this is
going to be a huge burden if you know if
it's only 20% of the qu what's going on
now then that would have a a bearing on
the decision so well I just think um
just for clarity some of our hospitals
do not use a third party some do and
that's part of I think what
representative King was getting at which
was some are able to do that some are
not or some have chosen to use a
different model to provide these
services in compliance with HIPPA and
state law so to the extent of the um uh
numbers of or percentage of requests on
behalf of third parties I would have to
look into that but my testimony provides
uh the point about several of our
hospitals and uh including critical
access hospitals use these vendors to do
these services in compliance with HIPPA
and and state law
representative
Weber thank you so now I have a bunch of
questions about
how things operate now okay and so if if
I walked into the hospital and said I'd
like a copy of my records please M um
and they chose to charge they would
charge me 650 and they'd hand me a thumb
drive or whatever I believe that we have
30 days to respond I don't believe that
we would get it to you right away but
yes conceptually yes okay so that that
answers my first question yeah it would
be the 30 days uh so if somebody is
unable physically to come and pick up
that drive when it's available at the
end of the 30
days because the patient requested it
they still would not be charged is that
correct or my I'd have to get back to
you to to understand how that works I
think representative Leon forth some
questions about who applies as an
advocate or who applies as as whatever
else um and as far as I know the
hospital would uh attempt to uh comply
with getting them that
uh it would be very helpful if you could
as a followup to representative Leon's
question because I think we're operating
in the same direction um what I really
want to know and to understand is where
the lines are because you have the
patient
themselves you might have a patient who
physically could
not be at the hospital um and perhaps
all of this could happen via the mail
and and a written authorization and
something mailed to them that's fine um
what I'm trying to get at is
um the provision in cases where the
patient is not
able um to request because of incapacity
or one form or another and then we've
got the personal representative after
death which is something else again but
my the thing that is what I'm trying to
understand and I realize it may be in
Hippa not your not your fault is why if
I can request something for
myself um why I can't represent request
it for myself and then hand it to my
attorney and why there's a difference if
I am handing it to my attorney and
asking it to be sent directly to my
attorney right I think those are fair
questions um and I think Hippa is a
complicated structure at which um does
determine and helps distinguish whether
it's case law or or the federal law
itself um what the distinction is so I'm
sorry I don't have a specific answer for
you now but I'm confident that there are
guidelines and and regulations that do
make specific reference to a personal
request from a patient versus
third-party requests um that's just some
of the reading that I've done on this
issue and heard about from the folks
that represent thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair I'm looking
at the uh Hippa rule what it says here
General Provisions that basically the
rule requires covered entities to treat
an individual personal representative as
the individual with respect to use and
disclosure of individual protected
information as well as the patient's
individual rights so if you have a
individual that has a personal
representative as far as Hipp the way I
i' like to hear something back from the
hospital association with that
interpretation that is considered the
patient and I don't know that a personal
representative is inclusive of a third-
party requestor like an attorney I don't
know the answer to that so the only
thing we're debating at this point in
time is the attorney I don't know the
answer to that specifically but my
understanding is there is a a
distinction between a third- party
request and a personal request maybe
there are others here who could help
I'm seeing no other questions thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Moren
iOS you've asked for five minutes if you
could you push the button there you go
that might help huh okay so my name is
Marin meny I'm a vice president with
share Care Health Data Services a
release of information service provider
company we operate in New Hampshire and
over 45 other states as well I'm all
also here representing our trade assoc
Association AOS um and that is
Association of health information
Outsource Outsourcing
Services um so we all operate in
hospitals in clinics excuse me um and
today I thank you for letting me come
here and talk about what we do and how
we operate and deliver medical records
um we work in many many Hospitals and
Clinics in New Hampshire and Beyond
passing this bill would be a major
change to our industry and transfer the
cost from thirdparty
requesters um and putting that cost onto
the Health Care
Systems um the type this type of Bill
illustrates that we need a little bit
more understanding of what's happening
out there with releasing information um
to requesters the process um that is out
there and it has been talked about today
is that this is nothing more than a push
of a button and that is not the way we
operate releasing medical records is so
much more than that anyone could push a
button and release records but when you
do that when you're taking a a patient's
health information their personal health
information and releasing it you need to
make sure that it's compliant and that
it's getting um reviewed and we review
it multiple times before we ever release
anything so we we just want to make sure
that you understand the practice that
goes along with this um the steps that
are involved are uh actually done by
highly trained uh Specialists who
understand the changing rules that
govern patient
releasing um we follow the Hippa rules
the health insurance portability and
accountability act and um and numerous
other state and federal statutes set
setting the cost for electronic records
at 650 would require that the
Fulfillment for each of these records be
done at a loss for either the health
care provider or an Roi vendor such as
share care the cost to comply with
federal and state rules that govern
release of information is significant
and we've already acknowledged by um
several speakers that there's a cost to
this and someone has to Bear the burden
of that cost and to pass that along by
changing the statute passing this along
to the Health Care Facilities the
clinics the providers that would be a
significant burden to them there are
different types of requesters as we know
um medical you know there's release of
information for attorneys insurance
companies um patients and as we've
already discussed a couple times hipper
governs What patients can be charged
most patients receive their records for
free or at that cost-based fee that was
already spoken about so minimal cost so
we know this isn't about the patience
this is about third-party requesters
getting their records so there's a
difference please start wrapping up oh
okay um so I just wanted to to make sure
that we understand that when we're
releasing uh companies such as share
care or the other members of heos are
releasing information there is a process
we're following all the Hippa guidelines
which there are many we have to have
those trained and certified people to
release those records and um we're
following everything to the te we're
making sure if there's sensitive
information that those records are
signed off appropriately so there's it's
it's really truly not about just pushing
a button but even more to just talk
about the fees uh to cap this the
electronic copy at
650 would be a loss for us as I already
discussed and capping the paper um at
$50 would be a huge loss I just want to
really quickly uh share one of our other
companies that we're in the association
with there was a patient record that was
240,000 pages and it was required to be
printed that is 48 cases of paper at a
material cost of over 2,000 alone never
mind the shipping cost for 2400 pounds
of
paper had this occurred with the
proposed bill in place the cost for the
hospital would have been in the
thousands capping the cost of printed
paper will drive requesters to request
records more on paper because they know
they'll get it for a flat $50 so
we just we know there's a cost we know I
I just want to level set and I'll wrap
um this I feel like this is being
portrayed potentially as this is a money
grab for vendors it is not every single
request we get there's a patient behind
every request every
single release that comes in third party
patients patients we already discussed
Hippa governs what they get charged so
they get their records free there's
portals that they can go to all the
patients can go to their Hospital their
practices go on the portal and get their
records so that's that's a big push that
everybody's making nowadays but to limit
the the charges us delivering records
for 650 capping that some we're not
going to we're in business I I heard you
know it was talked about earlier we're
for profit I I I think we get the
message okay thank you representative
Seth King thank you thank you Mr chair
you taking questions I am thank you
um if a patient let's say goes to a
hospital they go to their general
practitioner they go to a specialist
here they go to 10 different
places um and they want to get their
records for all of them can they get
them by just requesting it at their
hospital or do they have to make a
request at every single place they've
been to too and that's a good question
um and that's governed by each covered
entity if if they have visited 10
different facilities they're not all in
the same network then they potentially
would have to request those records at
each of the facilities so they could do
that they don't necessarily have to do
you know do that um by sending in a
request they can actually call there's
portals that they can go on and request
their records there's all different ways
for them to easily request their records
followup follow up um does share care
not have all of those records how does
what what what what do what role does
share care play in that so we have in
New Hampshire we have um and all across
the country we have certain customers
that we work with so that that what that
means is we have access to their records
and we if we get a request from Dr
Jones's office as long as we have access
to those records we would receive that
request and we would um deliver that
according to how the patient asked it to
be delivered um there's electronic
delivery there's paper you know there's
all different ways email password
protected and encrypted um so if we have
if we're partnered with that facility
then we would release the record but we
would have to be partnered with them
some there are other vendors in the
association that I mentioned um
that have other New Hampshire facilities
and so if they got a request at that
facility that other vendor would
complete it one final followup follow up
and if they go to Dr Jones and Dr Jones
works with you um and they want their
files but you also have a relationship
with Dr Smith and so does the patient
would you also be able to give them the
records that they have with Dr Smith as
well or would you be relegated to only
helping them with the Dr Jones visit
that's a great question it really
depends on how they um fill out their
authorization if they say Dr Jones
specifically that's all we can release
unless there there are some um things
that would could change that if the
organization decides if you know they
request Dr Jones but Dr Jones and Dr
Smith work you know work closely on the
patient then we could release that if
that's the rule of the facility if
that's the providers
rule policy we could do that but
specifically it would be better if they
said Dr Jones and Dr Smith's records and
then we would send both thank you
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here um
I'm still trying to get a grasp on why
if my medical record is my property why
it needs to go through a whole system
and some sort of scrubbing or other
process before it's given to somebody
that I've asked to request my record
I'm just trying to trying to understand
the point and the value in the system
here so you're trying to understand the
process that I you know has been talked
about what when we receive that request
we take that our team takes that request
they gather what's been authorized and
they're going through that record to
make sure there's nothing in there that
isn't compliant or if there's something
in there that is compliant to get the
appropriate sign off so my question is
about something if it's my record and I
have rights to my entire record why is
not discl why is disclosing something to
me or somebody that I've asked to
provide the information to not compliant
shouldn't it be compli only compliant to
give my entire record if that's what I
asked for absolutely we have to follow
so maybe I didn't answer that question
you know the way that the direction you
were wanting it to go um I wasn't
understanding that so if you send a
request in and say I want my record I
want all my records or I want you know
the last five years we'll send you those
last five years we're still we're not
going to keep them from you we're not
going to um you know put up any barriers
at all you're able to get your records
because to your point they're yours so
we do have to release them and as far as
share care goes we wouldn't stop you
from getting a record as long as
everything you know your release is in
place and you tell us what you need we
would deliver those records to you you
um so sorry if I follow up so if I say
that I have attorney Jones and I want my
entire record not based on what you
think is compliant but I want my entire
record to go to attorney Jones is there
gatekeeping there is there something
that happens to my sorry I didn't mean
to sorry it's been a long day I did not
mean to use a triggering word like
gatekeeping is there a process of what
happens when I'm asking for it to go to
somebody that I've asked it to go
to so if you ask us to send it to your
attorney we will send it to your
attorney and we have with every single
practice that we work with we have rules
and regulations in place if you say send
your send you know attorney Jones my
records then we're going to send them to
them but what what happens is when we
send them if it's for a trial attorney
when we're sending the record we're not
certifying that so most trial attorneys
want certified records so that's why
they're requesting them on their own so
that when we send those records out we
certify them and get them ready you know
for trial for them so one last followup
that sense so is the distinction between
a certified record and just a a a basic
record because I could understand a
value of a certified record that you
would want to pay more for where you
have a review process but I'm still
trying to understand checking for
compliance for my record that I have
right ownership of yeah so if you're
just asking us to send you send your
records to attorney Jones we're going to
send those records to attorney Jones and
um usually on the authorization it does
ask a purpose of why you're sending them
why you want them sent so if you were to
check off um you know legal or whatever
you check off that dictates if we're
going to send those records for free to
that attorney or are we're going to
build them do that make sense no but
I'll stop asking thank you
representative Weber and then
representative
kofalt thank you Mr chair and I I will
refrain from asking those questions
again because I don't understand it
either but um let me get at the other
end of these things which because it's
news to me that there are all these
third-party companies accessing my
records for period for purposes of
sharing them with somebody
else
so am I right in thinking that the way
you access these records is you have
been contracted by the hospital or the
doctor's office or something and as a
result of that contract which specifies
whatever limits they put on your access
to the records that that's how you
access the records to begin with that's
correct we have agreements in place with
the covered ID entity the hospital the
provider's office we sign a business
associate agreement so it gives us
access to the records we act um at those
facilities as if we were one of their
staff so we're partnered with these
groups all the Contracting is in place
um so we are able to access the records
so I will try one one follow up and I'm
sorry you know clearly we're all pretty
ignorant I'm certainly very ignorant
about this so
what I'm hearing is that you would be
standing in the shoes of the medical
practice with all the obligations of the
medical practice which they have then
put around your
access uh do you understand why it's
hard for us to wrap our heads around the
concept that if you're standing in the
medical practice's shoes that my
attorney my personal representative or
somebody not the personal representative
but that my attorney is isn't standing
in my shoes when what I want is all of
my medical records sent to my
attorney um
so we are acting on behalf of the
facility so we are acting as if you know
we are one of their team so we're
releasing records we're releasing
records based on what the authorization
says so we are sending records out based
on if you want your records for medical
purposes if you want them for legal
purposes if you want them just for
yourself um so our team is trained to
know which Avenue to take to release
those records does that answer your
question it ansers my question yes
representative Falt and then
representative Merchant um so I I guess
following on some of the questions that
uh came up a moment ago I want to see if
if I perhaps understand um why there is
a need to review my medical records if
you're sending them to me um several
years ago I pulled a credit report and
uh was a bit surprised to discover
accounts on my credit report that did
not belong to me they actually belong to
my father who whose name is almost
exactly the same as my own so is that
why the the process requires that
additional level of scrutiny yes exactly
so junior senior um you know what we do
we release a medical record we go
through each record because in your
record there could have been a misfile
and some other patients information
could be in your record and if we didn't
review that and go through every single
page to make sure they're only your
records then that would be a breach so
you would receive a record that didn't
belong to you another patient's record
so there is a lot that goes into it and
I know it's your record and you you have
access to and you have rights to it and
we would never keep you from that but we
want to make sure it's compliant before
it goes out follow up okay um so the the
supporters of this this bill have argued
that that medical record if my attorney
is requesting it they it's my record I
own it it's um but you've also talked
about this distinction between
certified
and so just CER so my my question is um
is is there additional cost associated
with producing that certified record as
opposed to Simply sending me a
record so directly okay so if you're
asking for your record to go to your
attorney and you've asked
and we fulfilling that
request there's a a section on the
authorization that dictates is what's
the purpose is there for legal is this
you know what's the purpose of this
authorization if you if the attorney
sends in a request and says se you know
this patient would like their records
and would like them certified for court
then we would send them and certify them
and there's the cost is that answer no
so the question is is there a difference
in cost there's a difference in cost um
for the so we certify the record by the
PID there isn't a charge for the
certification but in order for it to go
to the attorney with the certification
attached we would charge for
that representative Merchant then
representative
mlan thank you Mr
chair going back to the question about
the patients personal
representative it sounds like where the
tension is is
between what you refer to I guess as an
third party which should be considered
an
authorized an IND individual authorized
access the medical records to the power
of attorney or the patient's attorney is
that where the where the tension is I'm
sorry could you repeat that if I look at
what's here for releasing records MH it
says a requestor could be a patient you
okay with that yeah patient's personal
representative you okay with that yeah
the individual authorized to access
patient medical records through valid
power of attorney are you okay with that
yes so what about the patient's
attorney So the patient's attorney I
guess it depends on what the purpose is
and you know what I can take that
offline and get some more definition
around that question because we keep
coming back to that area we've we've had
that question a couple of times so let
me follow up and we'll get you more find
information on that rather than um you
know I want to get to the um experts and
get them to weigh in on this and we'll
get that back to you if I can Mr chair I
want I want to be clear right now that
from share Care's point of view yes if
it's the patient requesting it you're
okay with it correct if it's the
patient's personal representative you're
okay with that that's correct and if
it's an indiv idual I I authorize with a
power of attorney are you okay with that
yes those are Hipp of guidance so the
only thing right now is he's going to
get back to us is the word patience
attorney and how we Define that correct
thank you representative mlan and then
representative Paz off thank you Mr
chair and I have three just very rapid
fire questions short answer hopefully um
so just from my understanding you go
through all these steps so there's a
there's a a a a workflow that you have
when you go through that's right is
there anything in your workflow that is
different than the workflow at Basque
Imaging or Dartmouth Hitchcock is there
anything that you do over and above what
they do I don't know the answer to that
I know what we do I'm not sure what
their process is what their workflows
are um I I could share what we do well
no I I think I'm really just trying to
understand the differentiation
um
because my next question would just be
if if the workflow was identical um is
it the case then that Bas and Dartmouth
Hitchcock and these Community Hospitals
for each request are operating at a loss
are you aware um in your discussions
with them I don't know that okay no then
I I will just ask one final question
which I sort of asked the folks at the
hospital Association and maybe you have
an answer for what is the percentage of
requests that you know you and companies
like you fulfill is it you know you're
fulfilling 80% of the requests 20% of
the requests do you have a feel for that
so what type of
requesters no I'm saying of all the
requests for medical records that are
submitted from all sources um you know
because ultimately it all goes to the
initial provider and then they're going
to contract out to you right
what is the percentage of the requests
that are fulfilled by you and
organizations like you versus those that
are filled by Basque Dartmouth Hitchcock
and people like that so for all of our
customers and we have 10,000 customers
across the 47 States we're in when we're
contracted with a covered entity we do
process all of their requests that come
in so anything that came in would come
to us 42%
of those requests are third party
requests 4% yes thank yeah
representative P off and then
representative TZ thank you um thank you
for taking my question is sh care 100%
digital or if not what share of your
record keeping is not in electronic
format so we keep everything
electronically when we're working with
our different covered entities the
different hospital and practices we
actually it depends on what they have
some of them have EMR some are still on
paper some are fees we grab all of that
but we house everything that we process
digitally follow up and then in example
of uh expensive 48 cases of paper is it
your understanding that those 48 cases
of documents did not exist
electronically did did not exist I'm
sorry uh in electronic format they did
not they those were paper records that's
so there was no whatever record set that
was whatever dates of service that were
requested for that 240,000 page record
that was all in paper they were not
available in electronic format in an EMR
thank you representative
TZ thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so um I also was not
aware that this is a industry um that
there is such a thing as release of
information service providers but
clearly there's a business need um and I
can only speak from my own perspective
as a family doc um when I was practicing
I know that if I wanted to print
something like any little thing you do
you go in and print that one thing so
one Clinic Note One lab report it's not
like you just push one button you get
everything so it it is really burdensome
the other thing was I wasn't supposed to
do it right for my own patients I was
supposed to send them to medical records
and they figure that has partly to do
with like that way we know who we've
released information to and they've
everyone has signed off who needs to
sign off so I think um I appreciate you
trying to explain it all to us because
it it is a little bit um complicated and
so again trying to sort out what's this
difference between um what the
organizations themselves could be doing
versus you and you just clarified that
people contract with you to take care of
all of it correct so it's people aren't
going to their own medical record you
know downstairs in the basement uh
office anymore like they were right and
the practices in the clinics and the
hospitals don't have the staff nowadays
and they're not as well trained and well
versed in the hippo regulations and the
releasing so a company like a share care
are the members of a heos um our teams
are all specialized trained to do this
work and release the records thank you
representative
kofalt um thank you and so I'm going to
try to be clearer in the way I asked the
question y um I'm trying to understand
if the cost not the not the price you
charge but the
cost of processing a record that is
certified for an attorney
is higher than the cost of delivering
the same record to the patient in other
words yes is it 10 hours to deliver the
patient record to the
patient and 100 hours to deliver it as a
certified or is it you know 10 hours in
one minute to to deliver it as a
certified copy to the attorney I'm
trying to understand does it cost you
something extra to certify that record
and if so what's the ballpark is it is
it 1% is it 50% more what's what's the
additional cost yeah and I I I would
like to actually add that to um some of
the research that we'll do to bring that
back to you so we can Define um what you
know and have it in writing for you
exactly what the difference is to
explain it so there's no gray area why
if a patient requests it um and why if
an attorney requests it what that looks
like but I will get that back to the
committee uh in writing so you have it
so that you understand what both you
know request what that means to both and
the pricing representative Merchant I'll
try to make the last question thank you
Mr chairman following up on represent
Cal's question is there a cost
differential if you have the I would
assume that within the organization as a
service provider most of your records
are electronic I can't imagine you
having rooms and rooms filled with paper
so are the files that you have on behalf
of the patient are they really
electronic format and if somebody wants
then request it or you telling me or
understanding that you literally have
volumes of paper sitting around so it
really depends on the covered entity so
everyone is different um that scenario
that I gave you uh about the 240,000
pages that was all paper but there was
an EMR
um component to that but it didn't fall
into the scope of the the paper records
that they wanted released but some of
our customers have two and three
different EMR systems they have paper
they have microfilm they have F and we
have to go through all of those
different scenarios to pull records
either from the emrs take the paper
chart and scan that excuse scan it and
then print the feat so it really depends
on the covered entity that we're working
at um there are some that just only have
EMR and that's a whole different ball
game but there are some that have the
paper the feish the three emrs um so it
really just depends on where we are
responding to a request follow that help
so thank you for that helps me immensely
so if it's a electronic
format through electronic medical record
yes there's probably minimal cost to
take that record and send it some
because it's all electronic unless it's
certified um yeah and and so there's
just because the record is in the EMR
and it's uh you know we're going through
and pulling we're pulling the records
out of the EMR into our system because
the hospital systems don't have the
delivery mechanisms that we do to
release these records to the requesters
so we're pulling the records out of the
EMR but we're still going through that
same process we're going to make sure go
through every page it doesn't matter
what size the chart is five pages or
5,000 we're looking at every single page
and making sure there's no junior senior
records so the the steps are all the
same whether it's an electronic record
or it's paper or it's
film does that
answer it it it gets me in the right
direction okay thank you other
questions seeing no done thank you thank
time also signed up to speak is Nick
Abramson from
minutes good afternoon everyone thank
you very much for your time I'll try to
keep this this as brief as I can um my
name is Nick Abramson I'm an attorney in
Manchester New Hampshire I'm part of the
New Hampshire Association for justice uh
I worked down the street for many years
at the US attorney's office as a federal
prosecutor before seven and a half years
ago starting to represent victims of
medical malpractice that's my entire
case load at this point is I represent
people who have been harmed by medical
negligence so this issue comes up for me
every single day we are requesting
records for clients every day we are
getting bills for thousands of dollars
on a weekly basis for these client
records and so this has an big impact on
us it has a big impact on our ability to
um investigate claims on behalf of New
Hampshire citizens and it has a big
impact on our clients so um I want to do
two things very quickly one is talk to
you practically about what this looks
like on the ground what we're doing and
what we're seeing in response to to
these record requests um but first very
briefly I just want to rebut some of the
testimony that we heard from the past
few Witnesses um I think representative
Lon and several others have your finger
on the issue here which I think we're we
lose the force for the trees a little
bit here and we get into the details
about what these vendors do what Hippa
says what all of these regulations say
the bottom line is that any patient can
get their record for
$66.50 but when I request it as their
lawyer I'm getting charged
$4,500
$1,800
$900 really the critical question is
what is the
justification for charging a patient
lawyer a thousand times more than they
charge the patient and I can tell you I
feel like I'm banging my head against
the wall in in a dozen meetings with
these vendors I have not been able to
get a straight answer about the
justification for that increased cost
for the lawyer versus the patient and I
will tell you that in one meeting that I
had with one of these thirdparty vendors
it was told to me that if I as the
lawyer asked for the full complete
unredacted record of the patient just
like the patient would ask for that
there is no additional cost incurred so
in all of these communications all of
these side meetings not a single time
have I ever been provided with any basis
or justifiable reason why a lawyer
should be charged more than the patient
and I also want to bring it back to this
we talk about uh potential burden on
businesses in New Hampshire on hospitals
on the hospital
Association every every patient can get
it for
$6.50 which means every one of my
clients could do that if I sent them to
the hospital to get it it's going to be
the same burden on the hospitals whether
the patients have to get it or I have to
get it it's just whether we C we can
justify this additional unnecessary cost
for the attorneys and let me put it in
perspective for you with one simple case
that I'm looking at right now a client
approached us um we're looking at a
possible delayed diagnosis of sep
following an operation um she went into
septic shock she's lost all of her
fingers and toes so this client is
coming to me asking me if if I can
investigate whether she is a victim of
medical malpractice now I have a choice
I can tell this woman who has no fingers
and toes and is recovering from septic
shock to go to the hospital and get her
records for
$6.50 or I as her attorney can request
those for her to save her that time and
effort uh and frankly she's unable to
even sign an
authorization um so of course I do that
and the next thing I know I get a bill
uh from either sco or Sharecare for
$4,500 and I think that's the perfect
example of why this is such a critical
issue that the people who are requesting
these records through their attorneys
are doing so because they've been
catastrophically injured they're going
through late diagnosed cancer
catastrophic injuries they are suffering
and they need their lawyers to be be
able to do this and so I've heard the
response many times well just send the
client send your client into the
hospital and they can get it for
$66.50 why why can't I get that for them
for the same cost and I think that it
all boils down to that if the vendors
can provide some true justifiable basis
that has evidence to back it up that
they are incurring substantial
additional costs to get these records to
US versus our patients uh our clients
and the patients will listen to that but
nobody's provided that to us yet um so I
know I've I've probably already gone
over two minutes three over three now
okay I'll I'll keep the rest of this
really brief one other aspect I think
that is important to consider which has
to do with the the impact of the
citizens in New Hampshire is that this
process of overcharging lawyers for
getting these records prices out a lot
of New Hampshire citizens from having
their claims reviewed because we have
people come to us where we're not sure
if it's a claim or not we don't know it
might be it might not be but if we have
to pay $2,000 or $3,000 to get the
records on behalf of that client it
precludes us from conducting a free
legal review for them to determine
whether they have a claim or not so you
may have people who have viable claims
who have been injured by medical
negligence or some other kind of
negligence who are having their claims
lost through the cracks because of these
unnecessary costs okay thank you the
last point I'll make I I promise is just
just very briefly practically what we're
seeing on the ground so we're getting
these charges for requesting these
records what we see routinely is uh
duplicative Records thousands of
duplicative pages and essentially an
electronic shoe box full of disorganized
records this is not a curated uh perfect
organized record that we're getting that
would justify these costs of $2,000
$4,000 it will be 3,800 Pages where
there's maybe hundred original Pages the
rest is disorganized duplicative records
that we're getting charged for we often
don't get the complete record so we
often have to make multiple requests to
these vendors just to ensure that we're
getting the complete record and what we
find routinely in our cases is that we
will get an incomplete disorganized
record but the defense attorney on the
on the other side of the case who's
representing the hospital will have a
perfect complete organized record where
we're getting a completely disorganized
record than thank you so representative
Weber and then representative Seth
King thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my
question in the case of somebody who
might have requested their own record
and then passed it on to
you um would you as an attorney then
have chain of custody problems if you
tried to get it admitted to trial that's
a really good question the answer is it
depends so if they get the record
certified um and it's a complete record
we can use that but what we find mind
that is the difficulty you know our
clients and the patients run the gamut
in terms of legal and medical
sophistication so some of them will get
their records but they don't know how to
get it so they'll only get a little
piece of it or they they will get a
record that's not certified and so when
we come to they come to us what we find
inevitably is that they'll say I have my
records but they have maybe 5% of what
we actually need and so to make things
efficient and effective we just say okay
we'll we'll take care of that for you
will'll get all of your records and we
need to follow up so follow if I may
have a followup so what I'm trying to
get my mind around from from your side
of things is why you are not supplying
your client
with the request that you would have
made if you were doing it directly get
them to sign it and get them to send it
on and and I understanding the point
about uh patients being either
vulnerable injured
sick recovering or
whatever isn't it the
hospital's requirement to accommodate
those disabilities in requesting the
records it absolutely is it's a great
question so what I can tell you is we do
do that we often do that in cases where
we want to try to circumvent these
unnecessary costs and my initial point
would be why I mean why do we have to
take these extra steps and put these
people through this to get yeah no no
that's fine um so we do do that what we
run into is we still have patients who
are so catastro catastrophically injured
I mean we have a lot of clients who are
literally late like end stage cancer
catastrophically injured from bad um
surgeries to to have them try to go
through that process to go to the
hospital and get the records and then
get them back to us can be more
cumbersome than you might think given
their personal circumstances we do have
some clients who are able to do that and
we do do that with them thank you sure
representative Seth King and then
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you for your testimony
um I'm over here
sorry your testimony was very
informative I appreciate it um my
question for you is have you read C the
current RSA 332 D ion one comma I have
you read that I'm sure I have but I if
if there was something in front of me or
if you wanted to read something I don't
have it in front of me um but I'm just
curious because it sounds like based on
your experience that individual patients
are being only charged 650 and you are
potentially being charge thousands it
sounds like there's already price fixing
to answer your question why the
disparity it sounds to me like there's
already price fixing going on mandated
by the government that does not allow
these companies to release it to the
patients for anything more than 650 but
it does allow them to charge you and and
to answer your question I mean I don't
know I'm just speculating here but it
sounds like the true cost would be even
potentially thousands of dollars for the
patient as well but they're not legally
allowed to and so therefore the price
sharing kicks in where now other
patients that don't have anything to do
with these medical records are having to
bear the cost for the percentage of
patients that do request these records
so I'm just curious uh it might be
something worth looking into what are
your thoughts on that that maybe you
know what you're paying is potentially
the true cost and the the patient uh
requesting it directly is paying a a
subsidized cost yeah I hear what you're
saying and I would I would have to look
at the specific language of what you're
referring to in terms of the RSA but the
way I would respond to that is what I
started with which is at bottom the fact
that a patient can get this for 650 is
not going to change I can't honestly
can't foresee that ever changing and so
you have this funky aspect of the system
where the patient could get it for 650
and it's essentially a litigation tax
and and to go to that I will tell you
that in front of the Senate when we had
a hearing on this a representative of
the hospital Association essentially not
essentially explicitly acknowledged that
they when they see a request from an
attorney they basically say this is
litigation so we're going to charge more
so um to me it's a question of patient
rights I mean should should that patient
be charged more because their lawyer
requests it versus is them getting it
and should that be the mechanism of
spreading around that cost sharing but
it I understand your question it's a
perfectly Fair one thank you sure
representative Merchant and then
representative
Lon so I understand this thank you for
your testimonies very helpful of
course it really comes down to tension
mentioned before between the attorney
and the hospital who's going to bear the
cost so at this point in time what I'm
hearing from the argument if I'm a
patient outside of litigation and want
my files I can get up at 650 but if I'm
a trial attorney or malpractice attorney
and I ask for the records I'm going to
get charged at a different rate I think
it came down to a court decision with
Cox yeah
so given the fact that as an attorney
your livelihood is built upon finding a
case that you can justify so what I'm
trying to do is how do we avoid fishing
Expeditions that cost us money because I
would sit there and say at this point
time I support what we doing but at the
same time not having it so wide open
that we have an opportunity we're going
to create a lot of work to try to find
work so given the fact that you win the
case would not at that point in time pay
back the fees in other words as an
attorney you have a retainer what you're
doing is part of winning the cas is that
you have to then take the proceeds from
the settlement and part of that goes
back to paying for the work you had to
put into it yeah it's again a very good
question so what I would tell you is the
the way we operate is a contingency fee
basis that's the standard in the
industry what that means is we front all
of these costs for our clients these
patients to get the records investigate
the claim pursue the claim if there's no
recovery we eat that cost if there is a
recovery the those costs are then
reimbursed to us so that $2,000 $2,500
we lay out up front but if we win the
case for the client we get it back I
understand what you're saying about the
fishing Expedition aspect but but I
think that contingency fee basis really
precludes that because I as the lawyer
am putting my money where my mouth is
I'm not going to pursue a claim I'm not
going to spend the money on those
records spend many thousands of dollars
on an expert review for a case that I
feel is frivolous um and that goes even
from the outset when we get an intake
from a client most cases we can tell
right off the bat whether there might
something there or not if we don't think
that there's a very viable claim we're
not going to spend that money to get
those
records follow up so thank you that
makes very sense to me so therefore
could it be part of the contingency fee
that if you'd win the case that part of
it is you pay back the cost of those
records because that's really part of
the process I think the issue with that
would be if we win the case what that
means is that the hospital malpractice
somebody and cause them extensive harm
so I think as a principle um I I would
find that objectionable because I would
think that's really part of what the
hospital should have to compensate the
patient for is they've caused harm to
them they then give the records we
review them we work up a viable claim
and that's sort of part of the
cost thank you sure representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here um my question would be
if any other states have passed similar
legislation and what the charges and
costs look like there yeah that's also a
good question and we're happy we've done
50 state surveys um so we're happy to
provide that to you and give you all
that information the answer is yes this
this really is a national movement where
um patients and lawyers across the
country are fighting back against these
unnecessary costs and I know recently
there
were
uh yeah there were two states I know
very recently that
passed similar legislation to this where
I believe the Caps were under well under
$100 and if you look at the 50 state
survey they run the gamut I think the
lowest state was $10 the cap so this
would be the lowest um but it goes I
think from $10 to a high cap of maybe
250 or something like that I I guess I
shouldn't make representations that I
don't know for certain but it's roughly
that range um I can tell you that it
does seem like the momentum is to bring
these down further and further for all
of these reasons that these questions
that you've been asking which is what's
the justification for those costs thank
you sure representative palazov thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question as you explained you often want
uh as as a big a picture as possible but
is there an option to ask for a partial
record and is there any communication
when they tell back to you oh this
client has a lot of Records on paper and
then macra film so it will cost more for
you to get get a full
record yeah good question so um what I
can tell you is I can't speak for every
lawyer who does this work but I I think
I can say with confidence that most
lawyers request everything
electronically where it is electronic in
other words I there aren't many lawyers
now who are saying I want reams of paper
records we want things electronically um
I do I I think there are statistics to
back this up that most major medical
providers do maintain their records
electronically it's a not 100% but very
close and actually that that's federally
regul regulated they should be kept
electronically now um in terms of how we
request them we do try to be judicious
about that so when we when we get a case
and we look at records we don't just say
we want every record Under the Sun in
the history of this person we look at
when the injury occurred what their
medical history is based on discussing
it with the client um and we try to make
targeted requests so that we're not
wasting the hos the vendor and hospitals
resources we're not wasting our own
resources and then we take it one step
at a time we get sometimes we might just
get an abstract sometimes we might get a
full set of records from one provider
out of 10 or two providers out of 10 and
then if we review those and we think
there might be a viable claim and it's
worth the effort and the patient
client's effort to look further than
we'll request a additional record so I
can tell you it's it's very unusual for
us to have a client come in unless it's
Crystal Clear you know they came in and
the wrong leg was amputated or something
like that then we're just going to say
okay let's get all the records but most
claims were very targeted and specific
about how we request
those sure anyone else any other
much um two of your colleagues have also
signed up from the New Hampshire
Association of Justice do you folks have
anything new to
add okay we'll have to hold you to one
minute because you've already had one
bite sure and please keep it to the one
minute
each thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Marissa Chase I'm the executive director
of the New Hampshire Association for
justice which is the Statewide
Professional Association of trial
attorneys and we want to thank senator
berzel for bringing forward this
legislation this is a national movement
I will send
um the our 50 state survey to the
committee there are um they do run the
gamut and Nick misspoke just a bit um
there are a few states that provide
anyone who requests the record for free
and then the L the highest cap in the
country I believe right now is Maine at
$150 so I just want to clarify that um
this is I wanted to share a bit um you
know I remember you have a minute the
representative from um share care some
of our firms have their own contracted
agreement with any of these entities
where if their Law Firm requests these
records it will it will charge them no
more than $20 I will also send that to
the committee so if you can do it with
oneoff law firms and you can do it with
individual patients why can't we have
some predictability across the board why
can't they justify their cost and tell
us what the actual cost of doing
business is um I will also say that
share Care's third quarter 2023
Financial results they are a $25 million
company yeah and I will follow up more
with written testimony and trying the
speed tuck appreciate that Heather men
menzes yes thank you U Mr chairman and
members of the committee um I am also a
personal injury attorney I do other
things other than medical malpractice as
well I don't want paper ever for for the
rec I we do typically request electronic
um a few things just to bring up there
was something mentioned about the
P about the patient portal um
that does not include all the records so
it's not like I could just log in and
get everything um and also it I found it
interesting that not only the patient
themselves they get the records it's 650
the provider to a provider so my primary
care provider gets my orthopedist
records no charge for that why is it
different if the attorney on behalf of a
client then gets charged um and I'm I'm
happy to answer any other questions uh I
I do other things other than medical
malpractice so um I do have one quick
other point I wanted to make this uh the
fact that these charges are very high
affects not just plaintiff's attorneys
but defense attorneys as well and the
insurance industry because they also
will request authorizations and we allow
that they get the medical records and
it's just it drives litigation expenses
up for both sides we understand any
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank you I don't nor talked that fast
so sorry that's fine we we did you did
well okay I have no one else signed up
to speak on sp400 does anyone else wish
to speak if not uh
repres and representative Lon is looking
up to see who signed up online uh
Senator bird I'll need a pink card from
you for the next
one oh you've already got it okay way
you thank you representative
freus uh two people signed up one uh in
favor and one against and online we had
two in support and zero
opposed okay and with that I going to
close the public hearing on S
sp400 and open the public hearing on S
sp402 uh thank you senator burel for
your patience and I welcome you back uh
to introduce this Bill thank you uh
thank you committee for the record my
name is uh Regina berzel state senator
for district 19 which is encompasses the
towns of Derry Hamstead and
Windham and I am here to introduce Bill
uh Senate Bill 402 which is allowing
pharmacists to administer FDA approved
vacines without explicit approval from
the general court this was a bill that
um back in 20
2023 um I had um we had to we pulled it
out of one of the bills that went
through HHS and apparently I had
promised to go ahead and put it in so um
I have and basically this um allows
pharmacists to continue giving get
vaccines without having to get
legislative approval each time is so
long as the vaccines are approved by the
Food and Drug
Administration and with that I'll take
take any questions thank you questions
Senator
bzel representative Merchant thank you
Senator thank you Mr chair um in regards
to what you looking here the bill
expands the administration of the
vaccines to all vaccines for certified
techs not limited to licensed Advanced
pharmacy technicians technicians so
why why include if you will certified
technicians when all the vaccines just
from a safety point of view um some of
the vaccines are problematic and having
somebody who's only certified not
licensed given the vaccine could be
problematic I'm just curious to why we
expanded it to all certified Tex uh I
believe I spoke with Beth sergeant from
the um earlier today and I I believe
what was supposed to happen which didn't
happen is there was a period after
public and and then then it would go on
to the regular vaccines so if you want
to entertain a an amendment for that I'd
be more than open to it thank you
because I picked up on the period
turning into a
comma so did Beth other questions
representative Weber and then
King okay so I'm really confused because
the title is very confusing when I
compare it to what the bill
says um because the title is relative to
allowing pharmacists to administer
influenza covid-19 and other FDA
licensed vaccines without explicit
permission from the general court well
this is explicit permission if we pass
it and what I see the bill doing and
correct me if I'm
currently uh influenza and covid-19 are
already in the statute as being allowed
to be
administered by a pharmacist or a
pharmacy intern or a licensed technician
or a Certified Pharmacy Technician and
it appears to me that all of that is
already in the statute they can already
do
that what seems to me to be changing and
the only thing I can see that's changing
is that instead of the list of what can
be administered we're changing the langu
AG to all
vaccines licensed by the US Food and
Drug Administration that are recommended
by the
CDC or successor organizations so am I
correct in thinking that what the bill
does or is this different from your
intent that is the intent the intent is
to allow any that comes online that's
um can then be administered without
having to list the name of that new
thing that is correct okay thank
you uh representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair thank you senator for
taking questions um why why are
influenza and covid-19 also not
scratched out with what is being
scratched out why not just say vaccines
Li by the United States blah blah blah
why not just stick to that why why are
why are those two explicitly named and
kept in there why not just give rid of
those as well I believe and um
representative Merchant may be able to
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
the reason that's in there is because
the pharmacists the interns um are
eligible to um give those um vaccines
and that's why there's a period needed
followup um no I would just maybe
representative Merchant can better
explain that I don't know if that's
allowed I'm sure he had his hand up did
did you hear the question representative
uh could you repeat it please yeah why
why are Co am I not allowed to do this
you can
testify my apologies I didn't I I will
not ask him I will not ask okay thank
you I know it's cumers representative
believe um I think the clarification is
by striking after the word period under
the general public my concern is that we
took the phrase out a pharmacist
pharmacist intern in licensed pharmacy
technician on the supervision of
licensed Pharmacy then what we want to
do at that point in time is Strike
listing all the vaccines and then say
vaccines licensed by the United States
Food and Drug Administration are
recommended by the US centers of Disease
Control and prevention advisory
committee so we're trying to do is get
get away from listing for the pharmacist
pharmacist intern and licensed pharmacy
technician a list of vaccines so as we
go down the road and the FDA puts
another vaccine on that list we have the
authority to do it correct fundamentally
I would believe that thank you other
questions representative
paza thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh so um State
epidemiologist uh Dr Benjamin Chan
testified in this committee that
covid-19 vaccines are associated with
increased risk of
myocarditis specifically for younger
males uh do do you know how long did it
take for FDA and CDC to recognize this
fact and stop
censoring uh Medical professionals on
this topic and what makes you believe
that they a good entities for us to
follow in vaccine
recommendations if I understand the
question correctly you're just you're
asking whether or not what makes me
think that um
covid-19 is an authorized
vaccine uh G given the P for example
in uh how long it took FDA and CDC to
recognize the risk of for younger males
from of my carditis from uh covid-19
vaccine uh what makes you believe that
those entities are good better than
General uh Court in approving a list of
vaccines I I can't really answer that
question but thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you Senator
thank
you no one else s signed up to testify
on
sb42 does anyone else wish uh
representative Merchant are you in the
process of filling out a pink card or
are you leaving okay yeah would you like
like to testify Abby Rogers uh I need a
leave thank you um Abby Rogers
legislative LS on the division of Public
Health Services uh the Department's not
taking a position on the bill but I just
wanted to draw your attention um in the
bill on line five where it says covid
and a covid-19 vaccine if available to
the general public that line allows
pharmacists to give um covid vaccines to
children so that that's important to
keep in the bill just wanted to clarify
that the Gen the general public Clause
allows um allows that for children and
uh pharmacists can give flu vaccines and
covid vaccines to children and that
Clause that says to the general public
is is uh important to keep that to in
there to to signify that okay are you
taking questions or uh I can are you
just anyone any
questions M Rogers where she's from the
Department representative Paz
off thank you and thank you for taking
my question so if the intent of the bill
is to
allow
new uh vaccines that coming down the
pipe uh uh are you aware of anything
that is coming our away from FDA and
CDC I'm not uh I'm not aware of that um
but I certainly can get you that
information I can go back to the
department and and ask if and certainly
R relay that back to you sure anyway
anyone else any questions for SL our
representative frus yes I just have a
question about children on the bill it
says to individuals 18 years of age or
older so did I misunderstand when you
said children oh yes so the bill when
you see the strike out there um and then
it comes down and it says um this bill
is intended to be for 18 years and older
to remove those requirements but I was
just pointing out that in the in line
five where it says
um onsite immunizing pharmacists May
administer flu and covid if available to
the general public that means that flu
flu the only two immunizations I believe
that pharmacist can give right now are
flu and um covid to children but that
Claus general public accompass his
children okay I just if that's if that
answers your
question well sort of because it says
individuals 18 years age or
older I don't I that's a conf F in my
head thank you representative
Weber is it
true
that the stuff that is not in bold
letters is already in statute and the
stuff on lines 1 through
five
allows the co FL influenza and Co to the
general public which is people over 18
and people under 18 is that true part
that's true and that's currently instead
and is it
true that the language despite the fact
that we're going to have to Noodle a
little bit with what happens right after
the
period um
that everything else is restricted to
persons who are 18 and older so they're
two different things flu and covid to
everybody and everything else that we
choose to authorize is 18 and over
that's correct
okay representative Shapero are you did
you have a question okay anyone
else thank you and you could do a pink
card for us that'd be great does anyone
else wish to testify on S
sp402 okay representative fedus could I
trouble you for the blue
sheet online two people signed up in
one person signed up on the blue sheet
in favor of this of this bill on S sp402
all right with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on S SP 402 and open
the public hearing on S SP 559 FN I
don't see uh oh yes there she is I'm
sorry uh Senator frce
welcome I recognize Senator Apprentice
FM thank you chair McDonald and members
of house hhhs and elderly Affairs I
always seem to be sitting behind these
speaker so I can't always see rep
Shapiro like in a straight line you know
so good afternoon and um thank you for
for having me here today to introduce to
you Senate Bill 559 as amended for the
records Su Prentice State Center
District 5 large part of Grafton County
part of san county and one lovely
community in maram County New London so
again I'm here today to introduce this
as amended version so this bill is an
update updates RSA 126 Q that's the New
Hampshire vaccine Association statute
and by doing this what we're well by
amending the statute what we're doing is
number one adding a new definition
Within this statute of biological
product two we are updating the
definitions of Assessments assess
assessments and accessible lives to
include the reference to the biological
products including monoclonal antibody
products again this is for the again for
the purposes of the New Hampshire
vaccine Association this is a technical
transactional change what will allow for
two things
to happen one to more accurately reflect
immunization products that are currently
available and recommended for children
to protect their health number two it
will enable the New Hampshire vaccine
Association to receive payments known as
assessments from payers from our health
insurers for newly available
immunizations and in this case we're
talking about this monoclonal antibody
as included in the new definition a
biological product offered so this would
be for offering it to commercially
insured children through the New
Hampshire immunization program as it
stands today Insurance funds these
assessments largely fund the New
Hampshire imization program and their
vaccines for children also their
vaccines for children programs so that
they are able to provide all New
Hampshire children from birth through
age 18 with routinely recommended
vaccines at no cost to the healthcare
Pro provider or family with parental
consent a new timely and important
immunization product has become
available for babies so this would be
newborns babies toddlers up to 18 months
to protect them against RSV this is a
respiratory virus that usually causes
mild symptoms but they can also be very
serious symptoms for example pneumonia
leading to a
hospitalization the protection the
immunization this product is now
available and comes in the form again of
a biological product a monoclonal
antibody these proteins made they're
proteins made in Laboratories meant to
stimulate your immune system and
probably as I look over representative
Merchant who's our resident pharmacist
he can speak to this uh probably better
than anybody but that is that's what
we're talking about here in order for
the New Hampshire vaccines for children
program to offer this biologic product
we need to technically correct the
statute so the RSA 126 Q to continue
allowing for the purchase the trans the
purchases and the transactions by the
New Hampshire vaccine Association
through an equitable assessment paid by
all commercial payers again our insurers
for the commercially insured children
which will save insurers and patients
their families money and provide access
to immunizations again with the consent
available for New Hampshire children so
in closing this bill allows for the New
Hampshire vaccine Association to receive
payments known as assessments from
commercial payers for newly available
immunizations here via a biologic
product offered to commercially insure
children through the New Hampshire
immunization program two this technical
change is related to the financing and
provide financing and providing access
to immunizations through through the New
Hampshire vaccine vaccination for
children's program and three parents
make the decisions on their children's
immunization needs um I
am it's it's this has been this has been
a product of working with the payers the
insurers um and the vaccine Association
to get this right knowing that we had to
make this technical change in order to
be able to make this available to those
that want it so I want to thank everyone
that has been working on this over the
last few months
um I am happy to answer any questions
that you might have I do have some
experts here that are better suited to
talk about the technical side of the
assessments um the vaccination
Association the vaccines for children
program basically how this all works so
thank you for your time and I hope to
come out of committee with an aop pass
um as we were we saw on the Senate
unanimously thank you okay uh Senator uh
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair thank you senator for taking
questions um the covid vaccine would
that go under a definition of vaccine or
biological product uh
biological um
products I believe it's under vacine so
thank you for the question believe it's
vaccine I'm looking over to
representative Merchant but it's not
it's not a biologic product is it I
don't know it's interesting because you
you referred to the biological products
um as like monoclonal antibodies right
which is my understanding is that's what
the vacc was no am I incorrect
that it's mRNA okay it's a different
it's a vaccine um not to get into
technicalities but there's active and
passive an active one is actually
stimulates the body to make its own
antibodies which anent antigen if you
will passive which is RSV is actually
antibodies injected into the body which
are relatively quick acting but short it
lived and only last for up to 3 or four
months okay so can in that in that vein
thank you um can you can you name a
certain I suppose shot right now that
would be classified as a biological
product as opposed to a vaccine so yes U
representative King thank you for the
question so uh re I'm going to RSV it's
for RSV reab
which um I'm just not doing well with
the name that is what we're talking
about here that's the biologic product
okay thank you you're welcome new to me
it's all new to me thank you good other
question too did I see a hand go up down
it's also signed up signed up to speak
is Heidi CR from America's health
insurance plan hands May You' asked for
two
minutes good afternoon um Mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Heidi croll I work at
Gallagher cahan and gartell and I
represent ahip which is America's health
insurance plans um we are here today in
support of SB 559 as amended by the
Senate um so New Hampshire um ahip
members share in the commitment to
ensure that children have access to
their routine age appropriate
vaccinations and remain committed
partners with the nhba um we have
appreciated the proactive dialogue that
we engaged with starting back probably
last August um with the um New Hampshire
vaccine Association and other
stakeholders around the challenges of
including the RSV immunization in the
state's program um as you have heard uh
this bill will amend the current law to
enable the vaccine Association to
continue to equitably assess um continue
Equitable assess assing um the
statutorily defined uh accessible
entities um including carriers and third
party administrators based on child
covered lives uh consistent with the law
and also consistent with the association
um's plan of
operation which is a document that's
available on their website um fully
insured and self-funded Commercial
payers have been participating in the
New Hampshire immunization program for
many years um and through assessments we
have been financing vaccine purchases
for commercially insur insured children
through providers that participate in
the program this bill will um continue
that partnership with the program for
the RSV RSV um uh
immunization um I did want to point out
that the New Hampshire um ahip members
have been covering the RSV vaccine
without cost sharing since the early
fall um so even though the RSV vaccine
has not been part of the state's program
it has been covered for INF and children
receiving the vaccine either in the
hospital or in a provider setting and um
it will continue to be covered in
hospitals and provider settings um where
the hospital or the provider is not a
registered participant in the New
Hampshire immunization program um so
there's coverage whether you're in
whether the provider is in or out um
I'll leave it at that I know there are
people behind me who are um
much more versed in this than I but I'm
happy to try to answer any questions
representative Seth King thank you again
uh Mr chair and thank you for taking
questions I'm still trying to wrap my
head around this a little bit that
before these new biological products
came about there was an RSV vaccine
right there there there was such a thing
as an RSB vaccine I don't believe so
there never was not that I'm aware of
I'm probably not the best person to
answer but what I've come to understand
this is something new that came came to
the market specifically for that okay um
but um in in your testimony a moment ago
at first it seemed like you called it
the RSV immunization but then a moment
later you called it the vaccine but it's
it's not a vaccine it's a biological
product what what do I call this what do
I call this in you know because it's
easy to say oh I'm going to go get this
vaccine what do I call these new things
I'm going to go get this biological
product I mean what do I I don't know
what to call it I think probably
immunization is
the more proper term I um I think it's
if you read in the press for example or
that was I think you see them referring
to it as an RSV vaccine but I think
technically speaking you're correct I
believe technically it is not a vaccine
as in meeting the statutory definition
okay sounds like the media has their
work cut out for them on this one thank
you other
questions saying no other question oh
representative
paza thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh so my
understanding is
that uh there's a a good science behind
monoclonal antibody uh products
technology and
U but we are opening here
for very open definition of biological
product and I wonder if you will be am
able
to uh staying focused on uh antibodies
uh because uh there are so many
technologies that are not ready for
prime time uh but uh there's a concern
that there will be a market incentive to
um uh to open them up like for example
um we have mRNA based vaccines but now
there's a talks about in inting them
into food so food would deliver mRNA
particles and force the body to produce
some proteins like toxic uh covid-19
Spike protein and others so I wonder uh
what's your thought about being focused
on just
antibodies so thank you for the question
I would respectfully um if you don't
mind defer that question to people um
who are going to speak next because
that's really not my area of expertise
thank you other
questions representative
mour thank you Mr chair and I don't know
if you can answer this but
um we we hear a lot about mRNA is that a
part of anything to do with this
bill I see nods and I see headshakes I
don't so I don't believe so but again I
would defer to The Experts behind me
follow up follow up yeah would you
believe that the past 3 years have made
bills like this cause me a lot of
anxiety when I see this so um I really
would love an answer to that question
before I leave here sure representative
Merchant if I can clarify it I went on
website I'm going to ask a question if
you go on a CDC website will you find
mRNA covered under the child's vaccine
program I would I would believe that
any other
you also signed up to speak is Patrick
Association I guess you have some
testimony to pass out or um I did hand
oh you did okay you've asked for 3 to 5
minutes please keep it close to three
we'll do my best and we'll have
questions after anyway sure absolutely
um good afternoon um chairman McDonald
and the committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to present this testimony
and behalf of the New Hampshire vaccine
Association uh the New Hampshire vaccine
Association is a not for-profit
voluntary Corporation created by State
Statute chapter 126q in 2002 it's an
efficient funding mechanism for
immunizations for commercially insur
insured children and children covered by
Group Health Plans administered by
thirdparty administrators under New
Hampshire's childhood Universal vaccine
purchasing
program the program operates through a
public private partnership involving
more than 80 commercial Health insurers
and thirdparty administrators more than
220 Pediatric and family care practice
sites the New Hampshire insurance
department and the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human
Services it's a structural funding
mechanism and it saves approximately 30%
annually on childhood immunization
purchases and has a total administrative
cost of less than
1% which are born 100 100% by the
commercial insurers and the group health
plans administered by thirdparty
administrators the nha's funding
mechanism ensures that all healthcare
providers that require access to
childood immunizations receive them at
no cost whether the patient is privately
insured has Medicaid or is uninsured the
New Hampshire vaccine Association does
not set vaccine policy or receive state
funds the NHA is in support of s SP 559
which passed the Senate unanimously last
month this bill is required due to
immunization technology advancements
made since the New Hampshire vaccine
Association was created in 2002
specifically the market introduction in
2023 of the monoclonal antibody nura
maab which is an immunization for
children up to 19 months of age for
respiratory sensial virus or
RSV Senate Bill 559 provides an
important technical fix to chapter 126q
to ensure the funding for the purchase
of immunizations recommended by the
federal advisory committee on
immunization practices or asip continues
both providers and payers depend upon
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
funding mechanism to meet the needs of
their
patients in addition to an annual
publicly available Financial audit and
annual report the New Hampshire vaccine
Association has multiple public
reporting requirements that ensure
accountability including to the
insurance department the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives the Senate President and
the governor it has Representatives on
its board appoint from all of these
entities as well as pediatricians and
the payers who fund the program thank
you for the opportunity to present this
testimony and I'm happy to take any
questions that you might have thank you
very much any
questions representative Palazo thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
so uh regarding
uh immunity from persecution uh would
biological product uh that is
recommended by advisory committee on
immunization practices uh
also be exempt
from um like regular vaccines are exempt
from certain L yous
and not sure understand the
question so that so so there are certain
uh protections uh That vaccine
manufacturers uh
enjoy uh with regard uh to vaccine
injury loss you an so would this
biological products as defined here uh
are they also uh um
have so um in order for um any type of
immunization whether it be a vaccine or
biological product to be paid for
through the state's program it has to
receive multiple levels of approval
there's an FDA approval uh there's a CDC
approval and ultimately the state itself
can determine uh through the
commissioners of health and Human
Services whether or not that will be
actually something added to the list so
um we're treating biological products um
in this uh language adjustment this
technical fix to be the same language
that we use for vaccines does that
question okay I'm sorry representative
Weber
yes and isn't it true that the New
Hampshire vaccine Association is simply
an organization which procures product
at a discount because it is a
huge procurer of product and the
distributor of product amongst its
members and others and it has nothing to
do whatsoever nor does this statute have
anything to do whatsoever with limits of
liability for the product or anything
else right so um that is almost correct
um in terms of the Hampshire vaccine
Association it's truly a financial
mechanism so there are Health insurers
there's 80 or so that we work with and
essentially we assess or tax them a
certain amount of money we then transfer
those funds to the Department of Health
the Department of Health leverages those
funds against federal funds at this
discount procures them and then they're
sent directly to the provider offices so
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
again doesn't make any policy it was
developed really as a cost saving
mechanism um for everybody at the end of
the day but also I think even more
importantly for the providers um they
don't have to procure things on their
own and then build the carrier
separately it all comes as one Blended
stock and I know there's providers here
today um and so whenever a child
presents no matter what the type of
insurance they have this program because
a universal program ensures that that
physician can make that available as
long as you know the parent and and the
you know agrees that that's what's going
to be given to the child so we're really
just a funding mechanism and this is
really this biological product language
is just to allow us to assess those 0
Health insurers for biologic products so
that we can buy them at a discount and
provide them to the provider offices
thank you does that
questions I'm seeing no other questions
also signed up to speak is laa Condon
from
Bedford you have some testimony it looks
you've asked for five minutes I really
need you to keep it around three please
let me do my best I will have to ask you
please
okay go ahead when when you're ready
good afternoon shamman McDonald my name
is Laura Condon I'm from Bedford New
Hampshire I'm a volunteer New Hampshire
director of advocacy for the national
vaccine information center I have also
served in the board of directors of the
New Hampshire vaccine Association for
five years and continue to attend all
their meetings I know this program very
well I'm here today to testify an
opposition to Senate Bill 559 this is
not a simple transactional change has
been representative has been represented
the vaccine Association may want to
expand its business but this bill opens
up a mechanism for for a state takeover
of the purchase sale and distribution of
countless numbers and types of
biological products there is no other
state that engages in a scheme of this
type most concerning is that this bill
opens the state for liability for
injuries including disabilities and
death from these biological products the
state and manufacturers and others are
shielded from liability for injury death
caused by
vaccines by the 1986 National childhood
vaccine injury act but there is no
immunity from liability when it comes to
other biological products the risk is
very great with these new and unproven
monoclonal antibodies targeted newborn
infants has anyone calculated the
liability against the state and
taxpayers that would be for disability
or death to these infants they certainly
should this should be reason enough to
reject this unnecessary Bill remember
doctors and hospitals are already
purchasing these drugs as part of their
routine drug purchases and we heard from
Heidi koll here who represents the
entire Health industry here in New
Hampshire that these products are
already being provided without any
co-pay to the patients there's no need
for
change um this bill is not about whether
RSV monoclonal antibodies are available
they already are and it is not about
whether you would choose these shots or
not I support Choice believe it or not
this bill would make a wholesale change
to what type of drugs are purchased and
sold by DHHS and the vaccine Association
the vaccine Association was not created
as a funding Agency for biologics or
other Pharmaceuticals to treat or reduce
symptoms the vaccine Association is not
an all-purpose mechanism for drug
purchases and sales yes indeed this
change would allow for the purchase and
substitution of mRNA shots in place of
trusted antigen-based vaccines that have
been used for decades and the mandates
on children would stay in
place again um let's see I'm going to
skip through here because you can read
it all but I would like to point out to
the legislatures and the public should
be aware of important facts this nurse
of simab is only has only been approved
by the FDA since July of 2023 less than
nine months ago there is really no track
record on this drug for safety or RIS
the RSV season runs from October to
March so the very first season just
ended last month um we don't have data
on the efficacy yet and so fling
incidents of RSV hospitalization the CDC
always refers to RSV Associated because
RSV itself doesn't send children to the
hospital is the shot effective clinical
trials only detected some reduction in
symptoms for only 150 days after
injection what about the use of this
shot at the same time vaccines are given
isn't that a concern the clinical trials
and safety measures are scant but it re
it appears that vaccines um the Adverse
Events from these new shots are similar
to what we experience with vaccines
which of course can be disabling and
even deadly um what is the system for
tracking the adverse effects from these
new monoclonal antibodies well you were
advised here and you'll see a beer
statement I provided to you this is the
federal government's program here if
this RSV shot is given at the same time
as a vaccine um it is being the public
is being told to report it through veers
and on here I'm going to note that it
does say that nurse ofab is not a
vaccine that's from the federal
government so anybody wonders whether
it's a vaccine or not it's not okay
please start wrapping up um so um there
is no adequate reporting system for for
injuries and there are other concerning
audities about the bill why is
biological product listed as a
subcategory um the methodology DHHS
continues to refer to this as an ination
the federal government is clear that it
is not um it is a monocolonal antibody I
would be very happy to take questions
thank you thank you representative Seth
King thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony um so are you do you
believe that somebody who would be
1986 uh law that gives immunity to
vaccine companies uh for you know
adverse reactions to patients if you're
against that idea that you should also
be against the idea of adding that for
biological products as well is that what
you're saying no that's not what I'm
saying it's the federal law determines
what products have immunity from
liability um for all injuries and death
and that is limited to vaccine products
the federal government is very clear
that these RSV shots are monal
antibodies they are not vaccines so they
don't enjoy that immunity from liability
okay so when we have the state
purchasing and holding inventory on
these and it's being funed through the
vaccine Association now they are the
owners and the promoters and the sellers
of this product and the liability would
direct directly to them so if you have
an infant who's been injured by these
shots or some combination with vaccines
you won't be able to go to the federal
vaccine injury Compensation Program for
compensation you will go directly to the
state and the taxpayers of New Hampshire
for disability and death cause to your
newborn for these brand new experimental
questions see no other questions thank
you also signed up to speak is Suzanne
tarski representing herself in dmouth
health
once again you've asked for five minutes
if you could keep it to three I'd really
appreciate it thank you good afternoon
uh representative chairman McDonald it's
nice to see you again I saw you just a
few weeks ago thank you all for the time
and I will not read specifically all of
the words on here and please forgive my
original the the first paragraph
reflects the original and not the
amended but further in the uh document I
talk about the amended um the amended
Bill uh so my name is Dr Suzanne tansky
I a practicing pediatrician at Dartmouth
Hitchcock um Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center in Dartmouth Health children's
I've been here as a resident for 19
years and I've been a pediatrician for
more than 25 years and you've talked a
bit we've talked a bit about the the
mechanism of what this B bill is I want
to talk about the why RSV is a very
common childhood infection it's an it's
a CO common cold that all of us get over
and over get throughout our LIF SP span
generally speaking the first infection
you get when you're very small is the
most severe pediatricians see hundreds
of kids every single year who have
severe RSV disease as a pediatrician
I've taken care of hundreds and hundreds
of children with RSV RSV in a little kid
with a tiny little Airway they have so
much mucus so almost snot debris in
their airways they struggle to breathe
watching them as a parent as a doctor
it's agonizing to watch these kids when
the idea came forth that there was going
to be a vaccine or an immunization
something to prevent severe RSV disease
pediatricians around the world rejoiced
indeed this came out just in July of
last year and we were so thrilled
because the opportunity to reduce the
burden of disease by 80% the Studies
have shown that we have 80% fewer
hospitalizations from RSV and kids who
come to the hospital for RSV we don't
have a lot to do for them we can give
them oxygen we can give them fluids and
we can give them TLC so we don't have a
lot of things in our toolbox to help
these kids except for Respiratory
support so the idea that we've got
something to protect protect them from
severe disease with a passive
immunization this isn't immunization
this is a passive immunization giving
children antibodies so instead of a
vaccine like representative merchin was
saying where a vaccine will stimulate
your immune system to make your own
antibody this is giving the baby the
antibody directly it doesn't last very
long it lasts between three and five
months but it's very effective we have
many other things that we use passive
immunity for as well like rabies
imunoglobulin is another passive
immunity if you come in contact with
someone an animal that might have rabies
you get rabies imunoglobulin so there's
other things that have precedent with
that we use as imunoglobulin or
monoclonal antibodies so this is a tried
and truee Technology we just have the
very first opportunity to present it to
lots of babies in the past there was a
previous version of a monoclonal
antibody for babies with severe with um
prematurity it's called cagis had to be
given as a monthly injection tens of
thousands of dollars per baby so it was
really limited to only a certain
population who were eligible for that
and this makes that not needed any
longer because it has more persistent
protection so this is a life-saving
immunization we had tremendous demand
for this we had Parents calling on the
phone asking when are you going to have
it when can I have it for my baby and
the phone calls started as soon as the
media let let it be known that we had
protection for babies for RSV which
again can be very severe in little kids
so this technical change will make it so
much easier for parents to get this very
desired immunization during the rest
season and I fully support uh Senate
bill as amended 559 so that we can make
sure that we provide this recommended
needed helpful immunization for our
youngest babies at the highest risk and
I'm very happy to answer questions
because I'm I've been living and
breathing this for months and months and
months thank you any
questions uh representative uh palaza
and then representative Seth King thank
you Mr Jen thank you for taking my
question uh is it that is it true that
uh it's already available to parents so
what exactly this bill changes this bill
makes it a whole lot easier as we heard
earlier this is available on the
commercial Market but as as noted the
the ability for us to have it in one
population makes things much much easier
with every other product that we have
for immunization in the state of New
Hampshire New Hampshire's ahead of the
game we've got Universal immunization
practices so that it doesn't matter if
you have insurance not Insurance what
that product is I can just go in the
refrigerator I can get the vaccine
that's being requested by the parent and
administer That vaccine without having
to worry about anything it's really
simple with having to have two
populations I needed a vaccines for
children bucket and a bucket for
commercial vaccines the logistics of
that were really difficult because we
had access problems the state was much
easier to procure it it was a lot easier
to get a supply from the state than it
was to buy it commercially on the market
several of my colleagues in private
practice couldn't obtain any
commercially available vaccine because
of some some shortages and so they were
not able to offer this desired
immunization to their patient
populations so making this level so that
there's one way that that we pay for it
really creates a an equity equation so
that we can offer to everyone who wants
it great question thank you
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair um would you be able to rebut any
of the arguments that the previous
testifier made um about the concerns
about putting the state on the hook
financially for
lawsuits um anything like that thank you
um so I don't think I have the legal
understanding to know about the limits
of liability um that would not be my
understanding but I am not a lawyer I am
a pediatrician and I will I will stay in
my lane for that one um but um this
again passive immunization to answer a
couple of the other questions passive
immunization has been around for a very
long time and this technology is is
again a huge advancement and it's
extraordinarily well tolerated we we
don't see fever we don't see side
effects I for myself in my practice I
don't believe we made any um uh concerns
to medat which is the tool for biologics
or to
Bears representative palazov uh thank
you for taking my second
question when newshire can expect uh
some data on efficiency of those
vaccines because uh there already been
administered to kids so when we see like
if it helps with uh RSV cases uh I I'm
eager for that as well so as I said in
the original studies that were conducted
there was an 80% reduction in
hospitalizations and severe disease from
RSV and I am certain that the CDC is
actually actively collecting that data
Nationwide so we'll have better numbers
looking at the Nationwide population
disappointingly we were intending to be
able to provide this immunization up to
the age of 8 months of age so really
getting kids through that first year of
Life the respiratory season again being
about 5 months um and because of supply
issues we really only got to immunize
kids up to about four months which is
still great uh but we will have we will
be having some data on that as well
thank you other
questions seeing done thank you thank
much also signed up to speak is Kate pry
she still here oh there she okay I'm
organized you have a testimony to pass I
do have written testimony that I will
leave with you and testimony from a few
other Advocates my name is Kate fry from
new futures um we are as I've asked the
others if you could keep it to three
minutes I'm going to be able to do that
perfectly so as you heard from others
this bill is about the vaccine
Association it changes the definition
within the vaccine Association that
helps ensure the access of all vaccines
that are on the New Hampshire schedule
to be free of charge to parents this is
this program is um a very important
Nationwide of copied by many other
states in the nation um and it only
affects that definition it does not add
the RSV immunization to the vaccination
schedule it remains option for Grand
State families it's about the uh choice
for parents but one thing I I will leave
this testimony that's more comprehensive
but you had heard from a previous
speaker that um infants with RSV rarely
go to the hospital um and actually an
estimated 58,000 to 880,000 children
under uh 5 years old are hospitalized
each year due to RSV and if I can I'm
just going to share with you quickly um
a testimony I received today from an um
a mom who said she supports uh this bill
uh her daughter who's now 24 almost died
of RSV when she was only a month old we
noticed she was having difficulty
breathing and keeping anything down we
took her to the doctors and they
realized um they had to send her to
Boston Children's Hospital immediately
because something was very wrong upon
arriving to the hospital they noticed
notice she was not breathing for moments
in time obviously this was very alarming
she had to go to the end um
niku um the doctors ended up doing a
spinal tap and a nasal sve on the brand
new baby on her brand new baby and
discovered she had RSV uh because of
that she was placed into an oxygen gent
to help her breathe all of this could
have been prevented if this science was
available when um this young woman was a
uh baby so um I encourage you to read
that testimony I also have testimony
from a pediatrician on the importance
but I think it's really important to
focus on what this bill does and set
do thank you any
questions representative Palazo thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so following up on your last
line uh so would you be comfortable if
we limit this bill only to uh this uh
monoclonal antibody uh technology
and uh if we ever Pro develop a food
that provides ammonization through some
mRNA technology would that that
technology uh be according to the
definition of biological product as it
defined in this bill so can you clarify
on what it does and what it does not I
am supportive of this bill that defin
signes within the New Hampshire vaccine
Association law so that it can cover
every child regardless of whether it's a
monal antibody for RSV or traditional
vaccine this way they can be purchased
under the vaccine
Association and if parents choose to
have that vaccine for their child they
can do so it has nothing to do with mRNA
or I I think you mentioned something
about food and vaccine it is very
specific specific to the vaccine
Association law and the B the business
structure of how we purchase vaccines to
provide universally follow up so follow
up I I'm just not comfortable because uh
on line 14 page one it says uh any
product including uh antibody so it
doesn't say antibody in traditional
vaccines it says any biological product
so when I see the word any it it opens
up to any future technology as we heard
in some previous testimonies so there
are several people who worked on this
bill I do believe the Department of
Insurance assisted too with this
definition I feel very comfortable that
this bill addresses what we needed to do
so every child in the state who chooses
uh uh whose parents choose to have an
RSV uh vaccine have access to
it other
also signed up to speak is AA Hawks from
Society and you asked for three minutes
I will do my best to keep it less good
afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Ava
Hawks and I the director of advocacy for
the New Hampshire Medical Society uh we
support Seno 559 I'm not going to read
my testimony word for word I'll just
summarize um as you've already heard
today this bill makes a simple yet
impactful technical change to RSA
126q uh the statute that governs the New
Hampshire vaccine association's ability
to receive payment or assessments from
payers for immunizations offered to
commercially insured children in New
Hampshire um our providers pediatricians
in particular appreciate the benefit
that the vfc program provides to our
state's Children and Families as a
program affords all children under 19
access um to all routinely recommended
vaccines at no cost to the healthcare
care provider or the family uh sential
559 would increase access to
immunizations admin administered through
vaccination that have been approved by
the FDA and would further allow
providers to offer certain immunizations
such as Nur camab which I think I got
correct uh that prevents RSV and babies
and toddlers so I'll I'll stop there for
those reasons the medical society
supports this bill I am happy to take
questions but based on the line of
questioning today I will remind the
committee that I am not a lawyer nor a
physician but if there are questions
that require a physician's response I
can get that okay thank you yeah any
you also signed up to speak is Abby
Rogers from the Department of Health and
Human
Services thank thank you good afternoon
Abby I'm Abby Rogers um legislative Len
for the division Public Health Services
um and I'm with anarie
mccu good afternoon I'm an Mar mccu I'm
the immunization section chief I just
wanted to um also state that the
department has the authority to purchase
and distribute um immunizations under
New Hampshire RSA 141c 17A which
specifies the commissioner May purchase
and distribute antitoxin serums vaccine
immunizing agents antibiotics and other
pharmaceutical agents which the
commissioner deems advisable to prevent
prepare for or respond to an outbreak of
communic disease or other serious threat
of Public Health so under that Authority
the program was able to procure nurse
avab but only for our vaccine for
children elig eligible children and this
was due to the fact that currently RSA
126 Q would not allow for the assessment
through the New Hampshire vaccine
Association and subsequent reimbursement
to the department for this product so
we're in a really difficult place the
CDC supplied an allocation of this new
immunization to us yet we were only able
to give it out to a fraction of the
population as a result the providers
were in a very uncomfortable position
they had to decide whether they could
afford to buy and Bill for this product
I I had heard anec toally that um there
were families that actually were charged
for the purchase of the product because
the mechanisms to go ahead and Bill for
it weren't quite established yet because
it was a newly evolving situation with
the product coming out very quickly
during the midst of our SV season so we
were really placed in a very difficult
position so this um Senate Bill 559
really does fix that it allows for that
biological product so that it allows for
the funding mechanism to support New
Hampshire immunization programs
Universal purchase of the immunization
so that all children regardless of their
insurance status or ability to pay could
receive these asip recommended
immunizations at no cost to the patient
family caregiver or provider so this is
just really good health care to allow
the accessibility of the immunization
we're in a very difficult place we're
not able to um provide it to the
providers only 50% of our providers who
were enrolled with our vaccine for
children program offered nureva map
because they were really placed in this
dilemma do I give it to the vfc eligible
kids only which would be our Medicaid
uninsured underinsured Alaskan native or
American Indians or do I have to try to
figure out another way to try to get
this for the commercially insured
children and frankly half of them just
decided I'm not going to offer it at all
and that was very difficult we had
families that were calling trying to
find this product um there were families
that actually went over the the line
into Massachusetts and were able to
obtain it there um I know that there are
other vaccine associations that don't
have this difficulty because their um
language of their vaccine Association um
rsas are not as restrictive as New
Hampshire's is so this is really kind of
a unique problem to just a few States um
that have this difficulty and we would
really like to be able to offer this
program thank you um I just wanted to
add a couple of things um just to let
the committee know that this is not just
a New Hampshire unique problem this
there are many stage grappling with this
and trying to expand their statutes to
to um be able to accommodate this new
technology because based on the
definition of aine and 126q monoclonals
do not fit into that so when when we
were working with stakeholders on how to
fix this problem we thought well maybe
we'll extand expand the definition of
vaccine to include that uh that was not
something that the Senate wanted to do
they were more comfortable with adding
biological product um just to share also
with the committee that in our uh work
with the um Association of imization
managers and um ASO that we work with
that it is really important it has been
emphasized to State Health departments
that nomenclature around these products
are try to be standardized whether we
call them um biological products
vaccines like products they are not
vaccines they're referred to as
immunizations but in order to align with
Federal payer statutes recognition on
the federal level um they're not to be
they're not vaccines or immunizations
but they are biological products and
they also are vaccine like products so I
understand that um the federal at the
federal level the um uh vaccine injury
Compensation Program is looking to add
these products I think that was alluded
to before um this is a product uh
licensed by the FDA so
um instead of reporting any kind of
adverse effect if you would a vaccine to
vs this would be reported to the fda's
medat um if if a child were to receive a
vaccination um with a monoclonal then
you would could report it to vs because
it encompasses that vaccine but it
really is medwatch and it's sort of
evolving if you will so as Amry said
this is a technical fix this is allowing
the vaccine Association to um allow the
commercially assured to have this
product and right now there's not parity
between the Medicaid population and the
commercially insured so it is truly a
technical fix that um you know we hope
that can move forward as RSV season
approaches and people place orders for
these medications in the fall it really
does affect infant as Dr tansky said you
know really newborn you know under year
one year old when the devastating
effects of RSV and hospitalizations are
not only impactful to that child but
also to Medicaid into you know hospital
um admissions um I do believe it was
either last year the year before um some
states had declared a public health
emergencies because their beds were F
due to RSB patients so it really is a
problem that needs to be addressed and
um we're happy to answer further
questions but just wanted to kind of
level set on that it's not a New
Hampshire unique problem right now with
trying to get this these new
technologies identified in statute and
accepted thank you representative Lon uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you very
much uh sorry I've been running back and
forth to the Senate um so my question is
if um are you aware that this sort of
payer lag and the and the approval lag
is something that exists throughout all
sorts of different therapies including
life-saving therapies and that usually
there is a lag between availability and
before full payer coverage this is
standard in medic medicine yeah I you
know I'm just familiar with this
particular issue that I know that um it
was represented that um claims could be
filed for patients that have commercial
insurance but that is still parents
paying out of pocket for
the cost of the drug and then waiting to
be reimbursed um so you know we're
trying to solve this problem but I can't
answer that further to on the broader
scope if I can further elaborate um yes
even though there's there may be a payer
leg um Universal purchasing solves many
more issues than that um because the
first off the product is very expensive
so um under the contract with the CDC
the purchase would be $395 per each dose
as compared to on the market private
cost of $519 per dose so it's an extreme
um cost savings but there's also the
difficulty in being able to you know
decide okay this child is a vfc eligible
child I I need to pay for it and take it
from this inventory this child is a
commercially insured I need to go ahead
and take it from this inventory so it
goes deeper and Beyond
um any payer Gap it goes to the
logistics and the feasibility and Clinic
flow um on you know on a busy birthing
unit um you know nurses are not going to
be able to take the time to to be able
to really sort out and go to the record
and find out what insurance they have so
it just goes beyond a payer
Gap I'll say yeah no I think that's it I
mean it's heart valves too I mean heart
valves will directly save a life but
there's this challenge too so it's not
unique but thank you representative
Missour thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question so I I've heard a
lot about
RSV and that correct me if I'm wrong if
this bill was mostly written to allow
RSV
um access to um the vaccine but so if
that's the case then why use or create
the term biological product and instead
of just keeping this specific to
RSV why opening this up to this big
umbrella I
I've could it could it open things up to
you know future Thing Future vaccines
that um just I'm going to reiterate just
like this allinclusive language in
instead of if so if this was written for
a specific reason then keep it specific
but then kind of muddying it
with these kind of words the biological
products and everything else I'm here it
just to me this when I read this bill
and then I listen to you speak it's just
not lining up for me so I don't know if
you can why why not I I I only see the
word RSV you know at the under
methodology at the very end like I don't
see it anywhere but I'm
no thank you for your question um so as
the the the the drug nurse fbab which is
a monoclonal product does not fit into
the definition of vaccine so instead of
just limiting the bill by adding that
one drug or that one monoclonal um you
know the previous bill that this
committee heard um would would basically
you know for the pharmacist statute
where you would have to come into the
legislature to add every every single
vaccination it was similar to to that to
say um are this monoclonals are included
under biolog um biological products
there could be other vaccinations but
this bill is targeted really for like as
you said to solve this particular
technical problem but in order to um we
didn't think that it was great to put
policy into place where it was only on
one thing whereas you would have you
might have other um biologics that might
be added and fit under that terminology
the extent was not to be expansive what
inclusive Al set
any other questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh I don't know
much about AR Vis to correct me if I'm
wrong but my understanding is uh the
challenge with immunization from common
cold is that those
viruses mutate uh a lot so I wonder how
often we will be facing new product with
this
RSV uh antibodies uh uh and if that new
product uh won't require any further
authorization uh if if RSV virus mutates
we will probably would need a different
kind of
antibodies uh to
administer thank you for the question so
my understanding is that this uh
monoclonal antibody um is the first sort
if you will treatment for almost newborn
shortly after newborn baby birth um that
would prevent severe disease in infants
so this is really just to give those
little babies a chance not to get RSV in
an RSV season under the age of eight
months and Dr tansky can probably
correct me if I'm wrong so I'm not a
medical person um but the this is a
groundbreaking drug for infants during
RSV season there's been high rates of
RSV and flu and also covid-19 and this
drug would help those newborn babies in
the who are born during RSB season to
avoid severe illness um hospitalization
and maybe long-term problems going
forward with residual asthma or uh
respiratory issues so I don't I can't
speak to whether there would have to be
a new variation of that but I believe
that um the the thought is to have this
drug to prevent severe illness during
their the baby's first RSV season when
babies get older and lungs get bigger it
doesn't seem to be as much as a problem
as it is during that first period but Dr
tansy can come back up and and correct
me if I'm wrong did you have a followup
you all set okay any other
questions see no other questions thank
you thank
[Music]
you representative Merchant did you
thank you Mr chairman also members of
the committee for the record my name is
Gary
Merchant representing Sullivan County
district 6 clar M and Cen and it's been
a long day so I'll try to make this
short for the folks on the committee
went back and looked at CDC currently in
the vaccine program covid vaccine is not
part of the program so we're not talking
about Co
number two when you look at the price
differential it's a lot less expensive
on the federal contract and is doing it
commercially and private so it's going
to save the state and everyone else a
tremendous amount of money three this is
voluntary it's not
mandatory um you can go into a
physician's office today in the hospital
and you can get access to it um you're
not required to have it it's not a
mandatory thing although you have a
child in the hospital uh by the
pediatrician if your child needs it
you're probably going to get it cuz it's
logical thing to do
medically um I also would suggest to the
committee I looked at the Washington
statute this is something is a lot of
states are wrestling with is how to
include it in the state statute is Chang
it from a vaccine or biological product
to an immunization product to avoid the
issue of biologics and so forth and
narrow it down those are some
recommendations I can have to the
committee and also share to you I've
worked at the medical center inventory
Logistics that spoke to are real it's
difficult when you have a provider going
into the refrigerator trying to figure
out which ones for the program which
one's not for the program we tried to
work through that at the medical center
for probably several months we could
never solve the problem and it became
very very difficult because the
providers doing the right thing by the
patient would probably take the wrong
product and we build it out which is
what we shouldn't have done but we had
to go back and reverse it the logistical
problem of having two sets of inventory
in the same location was very very
problematic so for that I'll in my is
that with my two minutes I didn't time
you but I oh I trusted you to know the
drill so thank you um are you taking
questions
or representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair and thank you uh representative um
are there other states that use the term
biological prods in statute does the
federal government use the term
biological pro products in any of their
statutes and if so um how old is this
term biological product well the term
biological product's been around for a
long time since the uh evolution of
biological products going back probably
several
years the question I think you're asking
is regards the vaccines and the use of
the word biological project products
with vaccines and that's relatively
recent and the reason why let's being
changed I think a lot of our state
statutes is to comply with what's going
on with CDC and have access to the
federal contracts because the contracts
talk about vaccines per se but they're
changing the vaccine themselves at the
federal level but we also have to do
something at the state level in order to
be in compliance with the program so
changing it from say vaccines and
biological products maybe the word
immunization or would probably be more
acceptable to the committee I'm not sure
but that's kind of where the history
is representative
Weber thank you um setting aside the
actual terminology because it sounds to
me like biologic is broader than just
the RSV
treatment um and immunological products
are is broader still is not the purpose
whether you agree with the purpose or
not for using either biological product
or immunological problem products so
that the next vaccine the next
immunization product that comes down the
line which they do fairly
quickly we don't have to come back again
and again and again to modify the
statute in order to have that once it is
approved by the listed people and with
the request of a
we would be able to have that new
treatment available quicker and not have
to wait for the statute to change which
often takes a whole year I concur with
what you're saying grips and weer I was
just talking about trying to Wordsmith
it to use the word humanization products
versus biological right no I understand
that and I'm I'm not an expert in the
words that pertain to these products so
I was trying to take that out of the
equation but I I wanted to be
clear uh that the the the reason for
trying to come up with the appropriate
term whatever it is is to allow for
changing science as as science goes
forward and you may be comfortable with
that or you may not but it would make
more things accessible more quickly to
the parents that want their children to
have them I concur I think the goal here
is to make it
encompassing and what word we use to do
that I'm open to the discussion I think
your point is well made we have to be
sure we don't box ourselves in to
something without looking down the road
and saying there could be something
coming down the road that we don't don't
want to have to go back legislatively to
make it
work other
questions representative pazo thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh so um in this committee uh
we
had a lot about vs database and some
difficulties around it so do do you know
anything about medwatch reporting uh how
it's uh compared reporting to FDA where
medat how it's compared to reporting to
CDC where V
database representative um I understand
the words I have never used the Sy per
se myself so I would not be able to
address the question you have as far as
medat versus the vaccine registry um or
the vs if you will so I leave that
somebody else has probably used the
system to speak to that versus myself
getting out of my knowledge
base other
questions he I'm seeing no other
questions thank you representative
Merchant no one else has signed up to
testify on SB 559 FN does anyone else to
testify seeing no one um representative
predus thank you for the blue sheet
oh I thought it uh thank you for the
blue sheet um we have one two three four
five signed up in favor one signed up
against uh online we had 86 sign up in
favor and 106
against uh that it concludes all of our
um I'm going to close the public hearing
on S SP 559 FN that concludes all of the
hearings we had scheduled for today will
be reconvening next Wednesday which time
we'll have further hearings and I
believe an executive session as noted in